merci à
vous bien monsieur le ministre chers
collègues nous allons pouvoir procéder à
votre audition préalable à l'examen de
la loi immigration je pourrais d'abord
procéder à deux nominations la
nomination du rapporteur d'application
de ce projet de loi qui appartient
nécessairement à un groupe de
l'opposition et le bureau de la
commission des lois a nommé un membre du
groupe les républicain la candidature de
Monsieur Éric poet nous devons également
désigner un rapporteur sur la
proposition de résolution européenne
visant à faire respecter le droit
international dans le secours des
migrants en mer Méditerranée la
situation est un peu paradoxale puisque
nous avons déjà adopté tacitement cette
PPRE comme elle est inscrite à l'ordre
du jour mardi prochain en séance il nous
faut nommer un rapporteur de la
commission des lois qui sera monsieur
Guillaume Gouffier Vallante et donc
enfin la loi immigration c'est une loi
qui nous arrive du Sénat une loi qui
venant du Sénat et jouflu certainement
excessive et j'attire l'attention de la
commission des lois sur que le fait que
certaines de ces boursou flures ne
résisteront pas à un œil juridique avisé
ou du constituant ou du Conseil
constitutionnel pardon ou par ailleurs
de l'examen qui sera celui de la
commission des lois je renvoie les
sceptiques et les critiques d'ailleurs
aux décision du Conseil constitutionnel
sur la lopmie d'une part et notamment
sur les ajouts sénatoriaux qui avaient
été censurés ou sur la lobgie plus
récemment avec les articles 2 4 8 10 20
et notamment concernant le légal
privilège qui ont tous été considérés
comme cavaliers législatif
j'insiste j'invite aussi chacun à
constater que certaines ajout sont
politiquement regrettables ce sera
certainement commenté ici sur la
politique de santé publique sur les
mineurs non accompagnés sur le code de
la nationalité et que en de toute
évidence les arguments juridiques ne se
suffisent pas à eux-même j'invite la
commission des lois à retrouver
l'ambition et la lucidité du
gouvernement initial en matière
d'immigration et je pense que c'est sur
cette loi la partie la plus utile au
français qui sera le moins commenté
c'est souvent le cas c'était le cas
d'ailleurs de la loi séparatisme sur la
police des cultes puisque la
territorialisation et l'accélération des
procédures d'asile qui concernera près
de 300000 personnes et bien sera
certainement étudié dans le plus grand
des consensus par cette commission
d'ailleurs si Monsieur le Ministre poura
dans son introduction confirmer que il y
a bien une liberté la cndda de
s'organiser pour la forme formtion de
jugement en juge unique ou en
collégialité ce serait utile la
simplification des procédures de 12 à 3
peut-être de 12 à 2 sera également très
profitable à tous les requérants et
viennent ensuite les dispositions qui
ont été largement débattues avant que
nous réunissons cette commission d'abord
les mesures en matière de fermeté et je
serait curieux de savoir qui pourra
s'opposer à des mesures qui concernent
l'expulsion des étrangers délinquants
des mesures qui concernent la fin des
excuses notamment les levé des réserves
d'ordre public qui par ailleurs font que
on ne pourra plus également enfermer de
mineurs dans les centres de rétention
administrative d'ailleurs j'étais avec
certains des membres de la commission
dans ces centres de rétention chacun
devrait pouvoir le visiter pour en
connaître la réalité j'attire enfin
l'attention de la Commission sur le
volet qui a été aussi très débattu avant
même que il n'arrive au Parlement le
volet sur
l'intégration je regrette pas pour la
première fois en 20 ans que ce soit C
majorité F ministe qui est permis de
parler positivement d'immigration voilà
et je pense que ça mérite d'être dit je
salue le fait que la droite sénatoriale
après avoir longtemps critiqué le fait
que cette mesure soit inscrite dans une
mesure législative celle de la
régularisation les fait elle-même on des
termes qui sont pas à ce stade je crois
satisfaisant mais il faut quand même le
saluer il faudra trouver d'ailleurs une
écriture qui convienne à toute la
Commission et puis je vousis attirre
l'attention aussi de tous les
commissaires sur les obligations
nouvelles qui sont créées celles de
formation à les Gard des salariés sur la
régularisation donc dans les métiers en
tension sur l'autorisation de travail de
demandeur d'asile sur la fin de
l'exploitation des personnes en
situation d'activité libérale ou sur la
sanction administrative qui pèse à la
fois sur les personnes qui sont les
employeurs ou les logeurs si je peux le
dire ainsi qui ne sont que le miroir de
la criminalisation aujourd'hui des
réseaux de passeur voilà un texte donc
Toufu qui conservera toute une partie de
de son volume en tout cas de son intérêt
et donc je passe immédiatement la parole
à Monsieur le Ministre pour nous le
présenter merci monsieur le président de
la commission des lois Mesdames et
Messieurs les les députés heureux de
vous retrouver pour un mois de novembre
et de décembre qui sera sans doute un
mois d'échange nourri et important sur
un texte en effet annoncé depuis un an
qui découle directement du programme du
président de de la République dans ces
trois grands accès tels que nous
l'avions défini dans le projet de loi
initial du gouvernement déposé en
premier lieu c'est vrai au au Sénat pour
la première fois c'est un texte régagen
qui est déposé en premier au Sénat pour
arriver ensuite àassemblée nationale et
qui évoque évidemment les trois grands
sujets de notre projet de loi le premier
c'est celui comme vous l'avez très bien
dit de la simplification drastique des
procédures nous avons aujourd'hui et je
crois que c'est la continuité directe de
la loi
Colom beaucoup de difficultés notamment
dans ce qui concerne les difficultés qui
touchent les juridictions
administratives mais pas que pour
pouvoir dire rapidement à quelqu'un si
nous le voulons ou si nous voulons pas
sur le sol de la République Sonel les
règles que l'on a définis le deuxième
sujet c'est évidemment les exigences et
les moyens en terme
d'intégration c'estun volet très
important qui permet de toucher
l'intégralité du champ de l'intégration
et qui fait suite au 25 % d'augmentation
du budget d'intégration que vous avez
voté dans la loi de programmation du
ministère de l'intérieur la lopmie voilà
à peine 1 an et qui a déjà des
concrétisations dans le budget 2024 vous
l'avez sans doute vu troisièmement c'est
effectivement la fermeté vis-à-vis des
étrangers soit par leur éloignement soit
par leur expulsion lorsqu'ils commettent
des actes graves de délinquance ou de
criminalité nous y reviendrons je vais
me concentrer monsieur le Président
peut-être dans la présentation du projet
initial du gouvernement parce qu'en
effet d'autres dispositions ont été
rajouté rajouté de la part du
gouvernement postérieur notamment au
drame d'Ancy et au drame d'aras mais
également rajouté par le Sénat
d'ailleurs avec des amendements qui
viennent de tous les groupes politiques
du du Sénat et je veux d'ailleurs dire
ici que je partage si vous me le
permettez votre vision du débat
parlementaire c'est-à-dire que après
l'avoir dit très clairement dans le
débat sénatorial il y a clairement des
cavaliers législatifs ce serait mentir
aux Français de croire que les questions
certes importante parfois abordé par les
sénateurs mais qui n'ont pas utilisé
l'irrecevabilité puissent être dans ce
texte-ci puisque à coup sûr comme vous
l'avait dit ils seront censurés par le
Conseil constitutionnel et que cela me
paraît déjà un sujet assez compliqué en
soi que celui d'immigration parce que
nous parlons des femmes et des hommes et
des enfants et évidemment de ceux qui
sont chargés d'appliquer les règles de
la République pour pouvoir rajouter
des mensonge aux Français en expliquant
qu'on on a trouvé la Martin gale alors
alors que ce ce texte ne prévoit pas en
effet d'autres dispositions que celui du
code des étrangers tel qu'initialement
prévu par le gouvernement si je reviens
sur les trois grands axes qui soutend ce
ce projet de loi je veux revenir sur
l'écosystème qui permet malheureusement
l'immigration irrégulière alors que
notre travail collectif c'est évidemment
de pouvoir prévoir une immigration
régulière avec des critères définis par
le Parlement et de lutter contre
l'immigration irrégulière qui est
toujours source de difficulté bien sûr
pour notre état mais aussi pour les
femmes et les hommes qui le subissent et
il y a un écosystème irrégulier des
passeurs qui sont des marchands de
misère et qui trafiquent les êtres
humains contre des sommes d'argent
jusque à ceux qui les logent dans des
conditions évidemment absolument
inaccepable et si je devais résumer le
projet de loi par petit bout évidemment
mais lui rendre sa cohérence nous
essayons et je suis très ouvert
évidemment aux amendements et aux
discussions comme je l'ai été au Sénat
quel qu'il soit pour contre cet
écosystème irrégulier premier sujet vous
allez passer de délit en crime le fait
d'être passeur aujourd'hui c'est un
délit puni jusqu'à 5 ans de prison plus
grave si jamais il y a mort de la
personne on pense tous à ce drame qui a
eu lieu dans la Manche avec 29 migrants
qui sont morts dans les eaux froides
dans des conditions ignobes des femmes
enceintes des des enfants et
malheureusement les très nombreux
passeurs que nous interpellons ne sont
pas puni à la hauteur des drames qu'ils
font naître parce que les tribunaux
appliquent la règle de la République qui
ne prévoi pas le même quantum de peine
que lorsque on est un criminel deuran un
trafiquant de stupéfiant ou quelqu'un du
grand banditisme ce que nous vous
proposons avec le garde des sauts
puisqu'il s'agit là d'une mesure du code
pénal c'est de passer de délit en crime
le fait d'être un passeur et donc
jusqu'à case un 20 ans de prison
notamment 20 ans si il y a entraînement
de la mort deuxième sujet après le
passeur qui est évidemment criminel que
nous devons combattre comme tel il y a
le sujet de ceux qui quand il arrive sur
le sol de la République utilise on
pourrait qualifier ça de
difficulté administrative de notre pays
pour créer nous-même des irréguliers je
je m'explique nous pouvons en France
créer une auto-entreprise au sein du
ministre de l'économie et des finances
en ligne sans jamais que quelqu'un ne
vérifie la régularité du séjour de cette
personne et donc les étrangers
irréguliers qui créent ces
auto-entreprises ne sont en le faisant
pas contre les règles de la République
ils utilisent les manquements de notre
droit il créent ses auto-entreprises il
travaill souvent pour des entreprises
qui les exploitent du fait du statut
d'autentrepreneur qui blanchit si j'ose
dire ce statut il paye des impôts il
paye des cotisations sociales sans
jamais bénéficier de protection sociale
par ailleurs s leur arrivé quelque chose
et puis au bout de 3 4 ou 5 ans ils vont
vers la préfecture et demandent à être
régularisé puisque il payent des impôt
ils payent des cotisations ils ont un
papier du ministère des Finances qui
leur dit bah voilà j'ai le droit de Cré
mon entreprise évidemment il y a
beaucoup de mal pour les régulariser
puisque il s'agit manifestement d'une
filière d'immigration irrégulière créée
par le propre État français avec
évidemment la promotion de
l'auto-entreprise qui répondent à
d'autres questions autour du droit du
travail mais je ne vais pas évidemment
le en parler ici mais vous avez débattu
de ce sujet je crois précédemment avec
le ministre du Travail et donc il rentre
dans une catégorie que pourrait
qualifier de Nini comme on dit ni
régularisable ni expulsable pas
régularisable parce qu'ils sont
étrangation irrégulière et on verra il y
a un sujet travail plus tard pas
expulsable parce qu'évidemment aucun
juge ne vient accéder à la demande
d'expulsion d'une personne qui serait
sous qtf alors que l'État français
lui-même lui a permis d'avoir une
entreprise en France et donc ce que nous
prévoyons et c'est le rétablissement
d'un article après qu' ait été supprimé
par la commission des lois monsieur le
Président dans l'hémicycle du Sénat et
je voudrais remercier bien sûr le Sénat
de s'être rendu compte et notamment
majorité sénatoriale de la difficulté
qu'il créait et et je pense que c'était
une bonne chose de se débat
parlementaire nous proposons que nous ne
puissions plus créer une entreprise et
encore moins une auto-entreprise en
France sans avoir la régularité du
séjour vérifié par bien sûr les services
de l'État donc on ne pourrait plus créer
une auto-entreprise au la publication de
cette loi si évidemment quelqu'un est
sous le cûp de l'irrégularité afin de ne
pas créer cette filière supplémentaire
de régularisation ou de mise en
clandestinité sans être expulsé d'un
nombre de personnes dont il suffit de se
balader dans les rues des grandes villes
pour pour s'apercevoir qu'elles sont
nombreuses troisème sujet il s'agit des
employeurs que l'on pourrait qualifier
de voyou parce que siamment ils
embauchent des personnes qui ne sont pas
en règles au titre du droit au séjour
alors attention il y a des entreprises
qui embauchent des étrangers qui sont
des étrangers irréguliers et qui ne le
font pas exprès je peux prendre
l'exemple de quelqu'un qui est embauché
par une entreprise qui arrive avec un
titre de séjour de travail ou un titre
de séjour d'apprentissage et pour des
raisons et varié soit parce que la
personne cache son statut administratif
au bout d'un certain temps soit parce
que la préfecture n'ose pas ou n'a pas
pu lui donner à temps un rendez-vous
pour donner la régularité de la personne
il arrive que quelqu'un qui a un contrat
de travail qui paye des impôts qui paye
des cotisation ne puisse qui a été
embauché comme régulier soit irrégulier
par son changement de statut il s'agit
pas de ces personnesl on aura l'occasion
d'en reparler évidemment parce qu'en
général ces personnes là l'employeur est
d'accord pour signer le SERFA pour
régulariser la personne il s'agit pas
non plus de ceux qui pourraient
emboucher des personnes en étant trompés
par un allias ce qui est tout à fait
possible alors soit évidemment il faudra
distinguer ce qui relève de la tromperie
pour de vrai ou de la tromperie calculée
organisée avec l'état civil déffectueux
mais ça c'est le travail de l'inspection
du du travail notamment il s'agit de
gens qui embauchent des personnes
irrégulières sans papier sur le
territoire national qui ne leur fait
droit à aucun contrat de travail aucun
droit syndical aucune protection sociale
avec des horaires extrêmement difficiles
sans aucune possibilité de pouvoir
répondre à la force du travail comme
dirait l'autre de de l'employeur de sa
force du capital et donc de pouvoir
sanctionner ses patrons voyou qui
embauchent des personnes sans papier
clairement dans un dans une fin
d'exploitation mais aussi dans une fin
de concurrence qui n'est pas pur et
parfaite avec ceux qui eux respectent
les règles de la République et la
difficulté que nous avons c'est que des
procédures judiciaires existent elles
sont très peu utilisées malgré les
demandes de l'inspection du travail et
du ministère de l'intérieur on a 15000
contrôles par an 500 procédures
seulement et moins de quelques dizaines
de condamnation alors que nous
connaissons évidemment cette économie
parallèle dans chacun de nos
départements de nos territoirees je
constate d'ailleurs que 50 % selon les
procédures judiciaires qui condamn les
personnes de ces personnes sont
elles-mêmes des étrangers parfois
elles-mêmes en situation irrégulière
notamment dans le secteur du BTP par
exemple ou dans le secteur de de
l'agriculture il s'agit donc de prévoir
des sanctions administ
extrêmement forte qui complète les
sanctions judiciaires qui ne les remplac
pas et qui prévoi des amendes
extrêmement importantes pour ceux qui
siamment embaucheraiit des travailleurs
irréguliers les exploiteraient sans leur
donner le droit syndical ou le droit de
protection du travail écosystème
irrégulier encore pour les marchands de
sommeil nous connaissons tous des
étrangers en situation irrégulière qui
sont exploité par des propriétaires
verreux qui se font payer en liquide et
parfois sans quittance de loyer
l'exploitation notamment des femmes des
enfants des personnes vulnérables avec
des conditions extrêmement difficiles
c'est pas toujours le cas mais c'est
souvent le cas des mérules des des
sorties de secours qui n'existent pas le
froid en hiver l'extrême chaleur en été
et qui subissent parce qu'ils sont
vulnérables parce que ils régulier cette
système d'exploitation qui d'ailleurs
souvent est en lien avec le travail
irrégulier lui aussi et il y a un
écosystème de personnes vreuses et qui
peuvent travailler parfois avec les
passeurs contre ce ce ce fonctionnement
que nous devons lutter fortement contre
cela et notamment dans l'habitat ancien
dégradé il y a un lien évident entre
habitat indigne et action de
vulnérabilité le gouvernement avait
déposé une disposition pour lutter
contre ce qu'on appelle des marchands de
sommeil extrêmement fortement j'ai
accepté le le Sénat a voté un amendement
du groupe communiste notamment monsieur
brossa pour permettre le titre de séjour
temporaire à une personne qui
dénoncerait son marchant de sommeil un
peu comme sur le modèle de la personne
qui est prostituée qui dénonce son
proxénet quand il est irrégulier et une
disposition qui fonctionne bien je
voudrais leur dire ici que j'avais
accepté monsieur le Président sous
l'ancienne mandature un amendement de
Madame richarge buffet sur le fait
qu'une femme victime de violence
conjugale pouvait avoir un titre de
séjour provisoire lorsqu'elle était
elle-même alors qu'elle était
irrégulière
dans un cycle de violence de la part de
son conjoint et je peux remarquer que
les choses fonctionnent et permettent de
sécuriser ces personnes dans l'idée de
lutter contre les marchands de sommeil
contre les
trafiquants de de misère le fait de de
pouvoir voir ce tytre de séjour
temporaire en échange du dépôt de
plainte contre son marchand de sommeil
nous permet évidemment de pouvoir
documenter de lutter contre les
travailleurs qui utiliseent le la la
force de travail des des personnes et et
un financement illégal et qui est en
effet un écosystème irrégulier donc ces
dispositions extrêmement importantes
sont dans la première partie du du du la
vraie première partie si j'ose dire ané
Sénat les articles 2 les articles 5 les
articles 8 et et donne des dispositions
très fortes puisque elles sont complètes
avec les mesures d'intégration et
notamment une mesure d'intégration qui
est extrêmement importante qui là aussi
été supprimé par la commission du Sénat
mais rétablie en séance le fait que
désormais pour pouvoir embaucher un
travailleur qui demain passerait un
examen de français on en reparlera vu
les exigences de la loi c'est pendant le
temps de travail que l'employeur doit
laisser le temps à cette personne de
prendre des cours de français et
éventuellement les cours sur les valeurs
de la République puisque c'est a été
rajouté par par le Sénat c'est très
important puisqueaujourd'hui l'étranger
doit en dehors de ses es de travail
accéder à des cours donnés par des
préfectures donnés par le fit donnés par
des associations en dehors des ordes du
travail alors qu'on sait tous que la
plupart des étrangers qui rentrent dans
ce cadre-l ont un travail difficile
beaucoup de transport en commun et ne
rentrent pas toujours dans la
possibilité de pouvoir avoir le loisir
de prendre ces cours de français surtout
au moment où on va mettre un examen nous
y reviendront ce que nous faisons c'est
à 1 % finalement come on dirait dans
dans la région nordpcalé à 1 %
intégration comme il y a 1 % logement
les employeurs désormais ils ont une
vocation sociale aussi ils ne sont pas
là que pour faire un profit même si
évidemment il est tout à fait
respectable ils doivent pendant l'heure
de travail donner quelques heures la loi
le dit dans la semaine pour pouvoir
prendre ses cours de français et afin de
pouvoir accéder au maximum à la capacité
d'intégration d'une personne je me
réjouis que le Sénat finalement a
été compris les les intentions du du du
gouvernement sur cette disposition très
importante et tout à fait nouvelle ces
mesures de lutte contre l' migration
irrégulière et contre l'écosystème
irréguliers les passeurs les employeurs
patrons les difficultés administratives
que nous avons créé et évidemment les
marchands de sommeil nous permettent
d'avoir des exigence d'intégration plus
forte et notamment c'est la mesure la
plus importante sans doute de ce projet
loi jusqu'à présent les Français qui
voulez permettre par l'embauche par
exemple de personnes ou parfis faire
venir des personnes personne devait
permettre à l'étranger par le jeu de
l'OFI notamment de prendre des cours de
français donc une obligation de moyens
mais il n'y avait pas d'obligation de
résultat et ce que évoque ce projet de
loi c'est qu'il y a désormais une
obligation de résultat pour avoir un
titre pluriannuel c'estàd évidemment de
plusieurs années puisque le titre de
cours séjour n'est évidemment pas
concerné par la mesure que nous
proposons comme énormément de pays
autour de nous puisqu'il n'y a que deux
pays dont la France qui ne le fait pas
les les étrangers doivent désormais ou
devront demain des passer un examen de
français que d'ailleurs le Sénat a
lui-même je pense en utilisant le
pouvoir règlementaire mais enfin il l'a
évoqué qualifier de de A2 ce qui est la
moyenne des cours que nous demandons
dans les autres pays européens et cet
examen de français s'il est réussi il
donne droit au titre de séjour
pluriannuel s'il est raté ne donne pas
droit au titre de séjour la contrepartie
de cette exigence de la compréhension et
du la discussion de la langue qui
évidemment peut être difficile pour un
certain nombre de d'étrangers euh
évidemment c'est la gratuité des cours
autre amendement que nous avons accepté
en en en séance au Sénat et évidemment
les moyens que nous avons débloqué c'est
plus de 100 millions d'euros par an
désormais pour notamment les cours de
français que la lopmie a permis de
mettre en place et donc on aura
l'occasion d'en rediscuterent cette
exigence d'intégration autour de la
langue et des valeurs de la République
puisque ça a été rajouté par le par le
Sénat il faudra que nous en reparlions
sans doute dans le débat est très
importante puisque c'est le avant et
après du texte de loi sur l'intégration
nous savons qu'il y a entre 25 5 et 40 %
d'étrangers qui ont des titres de séjour
qui parlent mal voire très mal le
français qui écrivent mal voire très mal
le français et notamment plus de la
moitié de ces personnes sont concerné
son son des mmigrations féminines qui
souvent sont sans doute les plus
susceptible d'être vulnérable pour les
réseaux ou pour ce qu'on pourrait
qualifier de comm de communautarisme
donc il y a tout un pan monsieur le le
président de de lutte contre
l'écosystème d'immigration irrégulière
de conditions d'intégration deux moyens
d'intégration largement facilités et
évidemment d'exigen comme la réussite de
cet examen de français désormais pour
les tytres prannuel le sujet de la
simplification administrative les titres
3 4 et 5 est très important c'est mon
deuxième point parce qu'il vise à lutter
contre le mal français qui consiste à
multiplier les procédures multipliant
les procédures à multiplier le temps
malheureusement auquel on dit OUI ou on
dit non un étranger sur So national et
donc à rendre quasi impossible une fois
qu'on lui a dit oui ou non et notamment
quand on lui a dit non soit son
éloignement et avec l'application des
fameuses qtf désormais rentré dans le
langage courant soit évidemment de son
intégration parce que pendant tout ce
temps il ne peut pas travailler et vivre
correctement au sein de sa famille donc
que prévoit ce cette simplification de
procédure inspiré directement du rapport
buffet du président de la commission des
Lois du Sénat qui a été adopté à
l'unanimité des groupes politiques voilà
plus de 2 ans qui lui-même s'inspirit du
rapport Stal du Conseil d'État c'est la
simplification de 12 alors monsieur le
Président à trois procédures aujourd'hui
euh j'entends deux va falloir que nous
en discutions c'est-à-dire la division
par tro ou par quat des procédures pour
la première fois le gouvernement ne
vient pas devant vous en vous disant on
va changer les règles de l'asile avec
des critères différents des pays sûrs
qu'on va éventuellement évoquer pour
savoir quel pays mérite ou mérite pas
d'être sur la liste nous avons fait un
choix radicalement différent nous ne
touchons pas les règles de l'asile nous
touchons en revanche la rapidité avec
laquelle nous répondons à une personne
la loi colon a permis de passer à 5 mois
les délais de l'offre pr en moyenne euh
alors il y a bien sûr bien sûr moyenne
il y a il y a des dossiers plus larges
en temps parce qu'ils sont plus
complexes il y a des dossiers plus
courts mais 5 mois c'est déjà deux fois
du temps de gagner par rapport à ce qui
existait auparavant puisqueauparavant
2018 c'était 1 an mais ce qui ne va pas
c'est pas le délai de l'OFPRA ces 5 mois
sont raisonnables on pour peut-être
imaginer jusqu'à 4 mois ou 3 mois mais
il faut aussi laisser le temps aux
personnes qui arrivent sur le sol
national par exemple et qui viennent
demander l'asile de pouvoir évidemment
reprendre leurs esprits parfois se
soigner parfois être accompagnés bien
sûr donc on peut pas non plus réduire à
zéro ce dél le temps de la l'action de
juridique des tribunaux administratifs
et parfois des tribunaux judiciaires est
beaucoup trop long quand un demandeur
d'asile arrive en France il va demander
son asile à l'OFPRA en 5 mois on va lui
répondre imaginons qu'on lui dise non
comme dans 70 % des cas je veux iussi
dire que la France est un des pays où il
y a le plus de refus d'asile en Europe
donc nous ne sommes pas laxistes
contrairement à ce qu'on peut lire nous
sommes trop long c'est l'objet du projet
de loi de lutter contre cette lenteur
quand on dit non à une personne ils font
un appel à la CNDA et là les choses sont
plus compliquées puisque des 5 mois du
temps de l'OFPRA se rajoute 9 à 10 mois
de la CNDA ça fait déjà quasiment un an
et demi 1 an et et 3 mois exactement en
moyenne une fois qu'on a dit non comme
dans 70 % des cas sur la demande d'asile
on appelle à CNDA on va mettre un eqtf à
cette personne on va lui dire faut
repartir dans votre pays je rappelle que
cetteqdf il est suscepti de recours et
il est suspens
c'est-à-dire que l'action de l'État
l'action des policiers des préfets ne
peut pas intervenir puisque quand il y a
recours il y a suspension donc quand on
regarde le nombre de qtf et quand on
regarde les applications on peut dire
qu'il y en a que 15 à 20 % qui sont
appliqués on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler mais c'est surtout 80 % d'entre
eux sont suspensifs donc Vous demandez
au Préfet et au policiers d'appliquer
des recours qui par la droit par le
droit que vous créez Mesdames et
Messieurs les parlementaires ne permet
pas d'être appliqué puisque il y a il y
a un aspect suspensif dans ces eqtf donc
à la fin de la scène CDA donc un an et 3
mois on met un eqtf à une personne cette
personne va contester leqtf il en a tout
à fait le droit on est reparti pour 6
mois à 1 an ça dépend des tribunaux
administratifs et vous savez que 50 % de
vos tribunaux administratif c'est du
droit des étrangers 60 % du contentieux
des cours d'appel donc pendant ce
temps-là le le service public est mal
rendu dans sa justice administrative sur
l'urbanisme sur l'action évidemment que
peuvent demander un certain nombre de
Mair puisqu'on est embolie c'est le
c'est le mot qu'évoque les juges
administratifs eux même par le droit des
étrangers trop complexes trop nombreux
trop répété on fait donc un appel pour
cette qtf pendant ce an on est suspendu
à l'appel de qtf 1 an plus un an et 3
mois ça fait déjà 2 ans et 3 mois et
quand on dit non tribunal administratif
on fait un appel à la Cour
administrative d'appel ou au Conseil
d'État on est encore reparti pour un an
bref quelqu'un qui arrive en France à
une réponse au bout de 2 ans et demi et
3 ans pendant ce temps-là mesdames
messieurs les députés qu'est-ce qui se
passe cette personne a peut-être fait
des enfants elle s'est peut-être mariée
elle a peut-être inscrit ses enfants à
l'école et elle elle a peut-être eu
l'occasion de travailler ou de créer son
auto-entreprise peut-être qu'elle a même
travaillé dans une entreprise qu'il a
embauché soit par alias soit
illégalement et donc combi même nous
voudrions appliquer le qtf au nom de la
vie privée et familiale et l'article 8
de la CEDH beaucoup de juges nous disent
bah là vous pouvez pas l'expulser
puisque vous avez mis 3 ans pour lui
répondre et entre-etemps il a fait sa
vie privée familiale pour une partie en
France et ça c'est évidemment le N
gordien auquel nous devons euh trancher
on doit pouvoir répondre vite à
quelqu'un soit c'est oui soit c'est non
parce que si c'est oui imaginons
quelqu'un qui a une réponse positive de
l'État au bout de 3 ans pendant 3 ans il
a vécu de Lada pendant 3 ans il a vécu
de la me pendant 3 ans il a vécu de des
difficultés dans le dans la dans l'adna
pendant 3 ans il a vécu de des
difficultés administratives extrêmement
fortes que lui impose l'État et une une
insécurité évidemment que né dont on est
dans lorsqu'on a le qtf alors qu'il
pourrait très bien vivre de ses
cotisations sociales de son salaire de
pouvoir d'avoir sa protection sociale et
d'être respecté en tant que femme ou en
tant qu'homme sur le territoire national
ce qui au bout de 3 ans sera une vérité
puisque l'État lui aura dit oui par la
force de ces recours au tribunaux donc
ce que nous souhaitons c'est la
simplification drastique de ces délais
et si je devais faire très vite parce
qu'avec monsieur madas qui est votre
rapporteur on en parlera j'espère plus
longuement qu'au Sénat puisque ça a duré
une demi-journée le débat au Sénat sur
des sujets aussi importants et aussi
complexes juridiquement de passer grosso
modo de 2 ans à 3 ans ce qui est notre
délai aujourd'hui à moins de 9 mois pour
qu'en moins de 9 mois on puisse dire oui
on puisse dire non à toutes les
personnes qui sont sur le territoire
national et je pense que ainsi nous
aurons évidemment bien travaillé puisque
ça fait très longtemps que le Conseil
d'État la CNDA bien évidemment le
Parlement souhaite cette simplification
drastique et tout à fait conforme au
droit au droit européens le troisième
sujet c'est l'expulsion l'éloignement
des étrangers qui ne respectent pas les
règles de la République mesdames
Messieurs les les députés aujourd'hui
euh je ne peux pas euh expulser éloigné
euh énormément de personnes qui sont
soit sous qtf surtout lorsque elles ont
commis des crimes et des délits pourquoi
parce qu'il y a des réserves d'ordre
publique qui ont été inventé par le
législateur au début des années 2000
dans un contexte sans doute très
différent enfin qui aujourd'hui empêche
le mur de faire son travail puisqu'il y
a des réserves d'ordre public que seule
la France a qui n'est garantie ni par la
Constitution ni par la CEDH ni par les
traités européens c'est le Conseil
d'État qui le dit expressis verbis dans
le dans le l'avis qu'il a transmis pour
le pour ce texte et qui empêche par
exemple et c'est la loi de la République
de pouvoir expulser quelqu'un qui est
arrivé avant l'âge de 13 ans sur le
territoire national et qui a commis des
méfits par exemple à 18 ans et demi donc
prenons deux cas le cas d'une personne
qui est arrivé à 13 ans et demi qui a 19
ans à
euh voilà une vie administrative qui
fait que cette personne n'est pas
française n'a pas demandé la nationalité
française n'est pas ement sur le
territoire national là j'ai le droit de
l'expulser enfin j'ai le droit de
l'éloigner en l'occurrence j'aiit mettre
un qtf droit de partir par contre
quelqu'un qui arrive à 12 ans et demi et
qui a 18 ans et demi commet des crimes
je n'ai pas le droit de l'expulser parce
que la loi de la République empêche de
l'éloigné de même pour ceux qui sont
mariés en France de même pour ceux qui
sont depuis plus de 20 ans sur le
territoire national de même pour ceux
qui ont pu avoir des enfants même
lorsque les crimes ou dél sont en
rapport avec les enfants d'ailleurs j'ai
un cas extrêmement précis où la vie
privée et familiale a été caractérisé et
évoqué et notamment la loi française m'a
été opposée parce que cette personne qui
pourtant faisait des attouchements
sexuels sur ses propres enfants ne
pouvait pas être expé territoire
national parce qu'il y avait des enfants
sur le territoire national ce qui était
une décision très difficile à comprendre
mais qui est conforme évidemment à la
législation telle qu'elle existe moi je
vous propose de lever ces réserves
d'entre publici c'est articles 9 et 10
alors avec une difficulté très forte sur
lequelle nous reviendrons c'est qu'il y
a le régime de l'expulsion et le régime
de l'éloignement qui n'est pas la même
le même régime pour lequel le Conseil
d'État insista pour lequel nous ayons
deux articles différents il y a une ame
qui n'est pas l'ame a médicale d'État
mais quielle l' arrêté ministériel
d'expulsion que le ministre peut prendre
y compris pour les étrangers réguliers
sur le territoire national et qui ont
commis des crimes et des délits et là il
faut par exemple que quelqu'un al le
texte du Sénat a été largement modifié
monsieur le Président mais quelqu'un qui
a des peines qui en cours 5 10 ans de
prison donc c'est évidemment des peines
importantes puissent même régulier sur
le territoire national être expulsé du
territoire national et puis a
l'éloignement c'est-à-dire un étranger
en situation irrégulière qui lorsqu'il
commet les mêmes effets aujourd'hui il
ne peut pas être éloigné parce que
évidemment nous avons ces réserves
d'ordre public ces réserves d'ordre
public nous souhaitons les enlever sauf
une seule il y en a une qu'on ne peut
pas retirer que les enfants les moins de
18 ans qui commettent des actes de
délinquence avant 18 ans parce que je
rappelle que le ministre d'intérieur
n'est pas le ministre des mineurs
étrangers c'est le garde des saut c'est
une question de justice une question de
procureur de la République et nous avons
signé la Convention Européenne des droit
de l'enfant qui évidemment empêche de
faire cela sauf décision expresse du
juge puisque c'est le juge qui permet
l'éloignement des des mineurs mineurs
mais de tous les autres cas euh je
propose que nous puissions supprimer ces
réserves de publi lorsque les étrangers
ont commis des actes qui menacent
l'ordre public des violences conjugales
des atteintes contre les policiers du
trafic de stupéfiant et bien évidemment
tout ce qui relève des crimes pour que
nous puissions expulser ou éloigner tous
les étrangers non pas par rapport à leur
statut d'arrivée sur le territoire
national mais par rapport à ce qu'ils
font contre la nation se rajoute à ça un
article 13 qui est assez nouveau et
assez puissant il faut bien le dire dans
le débat j'imagine qu'on aura monsieur
le Président qu'on a eu au Sénat qui
prévoit en effet le retrait euh la
suppression du titre de séjour de deux
étrangers soit qui commettent des actes
de délinquence soit qui ne respectent
pas les valeurs de la République au sens
de la loi séparatisme je donne un
exemple aujourd'hui si les policiers ou
les gendarmes découvrent dans le
téléphone de quelqu'un des vidéos répété
de décapitation que cette personne n'est
ni avocat ni Journaliste et P voir des
messages de daesh s'il n'y a pas
transfert de ces message nous ne pouvons
pas considérer que cette personne tombe
sous le cou de la loi nous pouvons en
revanche considérer qu'il adhère à une
idéologie radicale bien évidemment la
multiplication de ces messages montre
que c'est pas un bon signe d'intégration
quand on est étranger sur le sol de la
République et aujourd'hui si je peux
faire une action avec la DGSI pour
pouvoir fichier administratif cette
personne je ne peux pas lui retirer son
titre de séjour ce que incompréhensible
pour les Français bien évidemment donc
l'article 13 prévoit notamment
l'adhésion valeur de la République tel
que défini par loi séparatisme et validé
par le Conseil constitutionnel je sais
que le concept a pu paraître flou
lorsqu'on l'a évoqué monsieur le
Président mais il nous est bien utile et
je crois que validé par le Conseil
d'État par le Conseil constitutionnel il
est très efficace pour nous protéger
contre tout signe effectivement d'atate
contre la République donc simplification
drastique des
procédures intégration avec exigence
d'intégration notamment par la langue
euh travail de fermeté extrêmement fort
contre les délinquants étrangers voilà
le sature du projet de loi c'est rajouté
monsieur le Président les dispositions
que je ne reviendrai pas que vous avez
évoqué qui ne sont pas d'ord de
l'irrecevabilité mais aussi des
dispositions voulues par le gouvernement
je pense notamment à des questions aussi
simples que le travail que fait le le
juge de liberté de la détention j'ai
désormais décidé de mettre dans les
centres de rétention administratif des
personnes dangereuses et non plus des
des étrangers qui n'ont commis aucun un
acte de délinquence ce qui change la
nature des centres de rétention
administratif et qui permet désormais au
juges de liberté de la détention sans
doute d'avoir un œil particulier sur ces
personne qui représente une dangerosité
il y a des dispositions imaginé
également pour connaître l'identité
d'une personne aujourd'hui miseintérieur
lorsqu'il fait procéder à des
interpellations lorsque des personnes ne
sont pas en régularité du fait du séjour
pour appliquer les eqtf il ne peut pas
rechercher dans l'appartement ou dans la
voiture la pièce d'identité que pourant
cette personne a caché pour pouvoir
évidemment euh définir de quelle
nationalité il est pour pouvoir
reconduire cette personne dans son pays
d'origine c'est une disposition par
exemple que nous que nous demandons mais
il y a aussi des dispositions qui nous
paraissent intéressantes dans le débat
politique et parlementaire la le
conditionnement des laissés passer
consulaires vis-à-vis des visas imaginés
par le Sénat moi j'y suis
personnellement favorable on aura
l'occasion sans doute d'en d'en reparler
mais aussi tout un tas de de
dispositions qui nous permettent d'être
plus efficace par exemple dans le le
drame d'Ancy un demandeur d'asile en
France qui avait déjà l'asile dans un
pays européen je dis pas un demandeur
d'asile qui avait demandé l'asile
ailleurs je parle de demandeur d'asile
qui avait déjà l'asile dans un pays
européen bah on peut pas traiter en
express sa demande d'asile et donc ce
que nous proposons c'est que quelqu'un
qui a déjà l'asile dans un pays européen
B on puisse évidemment lui dire assez
vite qu'il n'aura pas l'asile en France
puisque il est désormais protégé puisque
il n a pas de pays européens dans
l'Union européenne qui soit une
dictature il a évidemment la possibilité
de connaître un pays de de refuge en
urrence là c'était la Suède dans le cas
de de celui qui a attaqué des bébés à à
ANC et il est évident que les Français
ne comprennent pas ce sujet comme
d'autres sujets de réfugiés qui auraient
eu le droit d'être réfugié en France on
pense à des citoyens russes d'origine
tchchenenne qui euh auraiit euh sans
aucune contestation possible eu retirer
leur droit d'asile en France parce qu'il
retourner par exemple l'été dans leur
pays d'origine où ils étaient pourtant
pour chasser à Chechen qui retourne dans
Chechen l'été demandant l'asile en
France c'est pas extrêmement cohérent
aujourd'hui le droit leur garde une
qualité pour rester sur le territoire
national évidemment l'idée de ce texte
et de le retirer cette qualité pour
pouvoir évidemment les expulser du
territoire national partant du principe
qu'on ne peut pas repartir dans le pays
qui est censé vous persécuter notamment
il y avoir une résidence secondaire ce
qui est parfois le cas des cas que nous
avons eu à à connaître voilà il y a
beaucoup de dispositions qui ont été
rajoutées y compris de la part du du
gouvernement dans un texte qui euh vous
l'aurez compris est un texte qui euh euh
va euh aussi être dans la difficulté
juridique parce que chacun sait que le
droit des étrangers est extrêmement
encadré moi je m'en orgueilis l'avis du
Conseil d'État sur le projet de loi
initial du gouvernement je regrette
d'ailleurs que les présidents des
assemblées notamment le président du
Sénat n''est pas saisi le Conseil d'État
sur des dispositions extrêmement
intéressantes mais mais difficiles
puceque évidemment le contrôle de
constitutionnalité était important il
n'épuise pas tous les débats ce ce
projet de loi bien évidemment notamment
les débats de nature constitutionnel et
conventionnel mais je voudrais dire ici
que je je porte un projet de loi
ordinaire et qui ne m'appartient pas de
de faire faire un projet de loi
constitutionnel ou conventionnel les
deux je crois peuvent se compléter selon
les opinions que l'on peut avoir je
terminerai par dire monsieur le
Président que nous avons une réforme des
préfectures qui est de nature totalement
réglementaire qui va accompagner ce
texte de loi grâce au moyens que le
Parlement a accordé au ministère de
l'Intérieur pour la première fois vous
le savez les effectifs des préfectures
vont remonter l'idée étant que désormais
dans la réforme des préfectures qu'on va
appliquer en 2024 parce que je suis bien
conscient des difficultés des agents des
préfectures et de la difficulté du
service public qui est rendu nous
concentrons les moyens sur les primos
demande c'est les gens qui arrivent sur
le territoire national et qui vont
déposer un titre de séjour vis-à-vis de
leur régularité évidemment sur le titre
de séjour et de ce point de vue
l'amendement qu'a déposé monsieur buffet
sur l'étude à 360°gr est intéressante
l'idée évidemment qu' n'est pas de
casier judiciaire l'idée qu'il réussisse
l'examen de français et dans le cas où
ces personnes pourraent avoir un titre
pluriannuel ensuite passer vers
l'automaticité du titre de séjour pour
éviter que des personnes qui depuis 20
ans depuis 30 ans depuis 40 ans sur le
territoire national soit à faire encore
des que dans les préfectures ou même
parfois tomber dans l'irrégularité alors
qu'ils sont parfaitement intégrés et
d'avoir simplement une alerte le jour où
l'une de ces personnes pourrait
connaître une difficulté vis-à-vis des
valeurs de la République ou vis-à-vis de
leur casier judiciaire et donc de
changer finalement la méthode de travail
se concentrer sur les primotx arrivants
permettre l'automaticité du
renouvellement ce qui à mon avis
correspond à ce que demandent depuis
très longtemps les parlementaires de
tbur je terminerai bien sûr pour vous
parler monsieur le Président l'article 3
et 4 l'article 3 a donc été supprimé par
le Sénat réécrit en article 4 bis qui
prévoit des régularisations dont ta
c'est effectivement une bonne chose le
rapporteur général souhaite travailler
sur une écriture nouvelle ce qui est
important je dis ici devant les
parlementaires c'est de lever le lien
qu'il y a entre l'employeur et l'employé
Dans la régularisation aujourd'hui nous
ne pouvons pas régulariser une personne
si l'employeur dans le métier dans
lequel il est s'oppose c'est un droit de
sevrage c'estd que quelqu'un vient me
voir pour me dire je veuxê être
régularisé je ne peux pas régulariser
cette personne la loi m'en empêche un
article du code du travail c'est la loi
c'est pas le règlement si l'employeur
refuse de signer le surfa pourquoi
l'employur ne veut pas signer le SERFA
pour deux raisons la première c'est
peut-être parce qu'il a pas envie de
montrer qu'il embauche lui-même les S
papiers et que en le signant il avoue
quelqu part son délit et deuxièmement
parce qu'il paye une taxe à l'OFI et et
notamment il a surout pas envie de payer
cette taxe à l'OFI mais enfin pendant ce
temps-là cette personne ne va pas sortir
de la régularisation et donc si cette
même personne prenant le cas d'une femme
ne peut pas être régularisée aujourd'hui
elle est obligée si je dire pour être
régularisé par exemple de faire un
enfant ou de se marier sur le territoire
national pour être régularisé en
circulire Vals au nom de la famille
c'est-à-dire que nous sommes dans un
monde très particulier où on sait très
bien qu'on ne peut pas qu'on a devant
nous quelqu'un qui travaille dans une
entreprise et qu'on ne peut pas
régulariser cette personne parce que
l'employeur ne veut pas signer le SERFA
donc le but essentiel de l'article 3
indépendamment des régularisations qu'il
fait naître dans les du métier dit
entention et dans les zones
géographiques tendues on oublie toujours
les zones géographiques dans dans l'
dans l'article initial du gouvernement
c'est de faire sauter ce lien entre
employeur et employé et de permettre à
l'employé seul d'être régulariser dans
les conditions que définira le Parlement
et puis a évidemment l'article 4 qui est
celui des des de du travail des
demandurs d'asile contrairement à ce
qu'on dit et ce qu'on répète les demasil
ils ont le droit de travailler en France
simplement ils ont le droit de le faire
après 6 mois et la question qui se
posait c'était pour ceux qui avaient un
taux de protection important de pouvoir
le faire avant 6 mois le Sénat pour le
coup c'est le seul article qu'il a
supprimé et je voudrais ici dire que sur
les 27 articles proposés par le
gouvernement un seul a été supprimé par
le Sénat ce qui prouve sans doute
indépendamment des rajouts qui ont été
fait que non seulement le texte du
Gouvernement est bien vivant mais il a
été approuvé par une très grande
majorité de
sénateurs merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur le rapporteur général vous avez
la parole en premier pour une de 5
minutes oui merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre Mesdames et
Messieurs les les corapporteurs mes
chers collègues nous sommes réunis pour
vous entendre monsieur le Premier le
ministre pardon euh sur le projet
l'immigration mais je j'anticipe mes
chers collèg le projet de loi
immigration adopté par le CMA le 14
novembre dernier je voudrais rapidement
vous l'avez fait monsieur le ministre en
en retracer les principales orientations
en tout cas initiales premièrement nous
voulons déployer des stratégies
supplémentaires des voies nouvelles
d'intégration notamment par
l'apprentissage du français et c'est une
mesure que beaucoup de gouvernements
n'ont pas souhaité réaliser par le passé
nous voulons aussi mettre fa à des
situations de maltraitance à l'égard de
bon nombre d'étrangers présents sur
notre sol c'est par ex exemple
l'interdiction vous l'avez dit Monsieur
le Ministre de la rétention
administrative des des mineurs c'est
aussi l'objectif de la régularisation
des métiers en attention parce qu' tous
les employeurs ne sont pas de bonne foi
c'est la lutte contre les passeurs c'est
aussi la lutte contre les marchands de
sommeil et contre les conditions de
logement inhumaines parfois dans
lesquelles trop d'entre eux sont tenus
second objectif nous voulons renforcer
notre efficacité pour expulser les
étrangers délinquants considérant que
leur place n'est plus n'est pas sur le
sol de la République et c'est notamment
le sens de la levée des protections
contre l'éloignement dont bénéficient
parfois des auteurs de délit parfois de
crime parfois aussi de
multirécidiviste dans ce contexte le
Sénat a fait son travail et nous allons
faire le nôtre certaines déposition du
Sénat mérite d'être approfondies vont
parfois dans le bon sens je pense au
meilleur encadrement du titre de séjour
étranger malade je pense au renforcement
du contrôle caractère réel pardon et
sérieux des visas étudiants à la
question de l'apprentissage du français
y compris d'ailleurs dans certaines
situations de regroupement familial et
puis d'autres modifications sont
contestables parfois sur le fond parfois
sur la forme c'est le cas de la
suppression de l'aide médicale d'État
qui constitue monsieur le président de
la commission des lois la signaler un
colossal cavalier législatif et le
rapport un rapport sera rendu le 4
décembre prochain par Patrick
stéphanignier et claudvin qui permettra
d'éclairer le débat peut-être de le
prolonger mais je rappelle que la
dernière fois qu'il y a eu une
modification une évolution de l'a
médicale d'État c'était dans le cadre
d'un projet de loi de finances et il y
avait au banc la ministre de la Santé
d'Alor et donc c'est à la fois une
question de santé publique de santé
collective et c'est aussi une question
budgétaire de la même manière que nous
nallavons pas à travers ce texte
réformer le code civil et sa partie sur
la nationalité je pense que c'est un
débat qui n'est qui est peut-être même
un débat de nature présidentielle en
tout cas nous verrons dans les
prochaines années enfin nous aurons vous
l'avez dit monsieur le ministre le débat
sur la
régularisation notamment dans les
métiers en tension une régularisation
forcément ciblée forcément bornée dans
le temps et y compris depuis le départ
l'article 3 initial fixé un objectif au
31 décembre 2026 peut-être pourrons-nous
l'adapter et sur ce point je fais un un
constat très simple la majorité
sénatorial défendait il y a encore
quelques quelques jours quelques
semaines quelques jours le slogan d'une
certaine façon zé régularisation et elle
a finalement validé la nécessité dans
notre pays d'une politique raisonnée de
régularisation à la fois pour nos
besoins économiques et pour les besoins
de l'intégration des personnes
concernées et sur ce point je proposerai
à à notre commission avec collègue
corapporteur que nous puissions trouver
une solution qui ne soit ni le droit
automatique général et absolu qui pose
une série de difficultés réelles ni le
pouvoir discrtionnaire du préfet tel que
le Sénat a pu le prévoir et de ce point
de vue nous aurons bien sûr de
l'occasion d'en débattre longuement
quelques mots également sur le
renforcement du rôle du Parlement en
matière migratoire sur et sur la
proposition d'une politique dite de
quotas il y a dans le texte du Sénat sur
ce point précis de trèsérieux très
sérieux obstacles constitutionnels très
sérieux le premier d'entre eux c'est que
un un parlement ne peut pas s'obliger à
lui-même de débattre dans l'avenir sur
quelque sujet que ce soit y compris bien
sûr sur la question migratoire la
deuxième inconstitutionnalité c'est que
le Parlement ne peut pas déterminer les
chiffres de l'immigration ça n'est pas
son rôle et ça n'est pas la lettre de
notre Constitution par conséquent il
faudrait une réforme de la Constitution
en revanche que le Parlement et certains
le souhaitent et nous aurons ce débat le
7 décembre cher Annie jeevard mais en
l'occurrence nous pouvons en revanche
considérer que sur la base des éléments
que le gouvernement communiquera il y
ait la possibilité de débattre sur les
objectifs
annuels M
dans le cadre de l'immigration de
travail dans le cadre des visas
étudiants et d'ailleurs ce sera pour la
majorité présidentielle l'occasion de
rappeler ses ambitions la première cause
de migration en France ce sont les visas
étudiants ça n'est pas l'immigration
familiale ni même et encore moins le
regroupement familial 108000 titres visa
étudiant 15000 au titre du regroupement
familial et nous pourrons afficher nos
ambitions et nous pourrions le faire en
effet annuellement je je ne veux pas
être beaucoup plus long monsieur le le
président mais rappeler simplement un
j'espère que la tonalité de nos débats
sera non seulement de la plus grande
courtoisie républicaine ça je n'en doute
pas mais à la fois précis exigeant parce
que cette question elle est elle est
elle-même sensible très délicate elle
engage une partie de notre avenir je
pense que la tonalité de débat en tout
cas moi je j'y verrai au rôle qui qui
est le mien devra être celle-ci et puis
ensuite je terminerai par dire monsieur
le Président deux titres sont essentiels
parmi beaucoup d'autres sur la
simplification structurelle à la fois de
la justice de l'
et sur le contentieux administratif et
du droit des étrangers j'espère là aussi
que nous prendrons évidemment le temps
d'en débattre d'en discuter parce que
parfois nous ciblons les sujets qui font
l'actualité médiatique et parfois au
renoncement de sujets plus exigeants
c'est vrai et qui sont plus essentiels
je vous
remercie madame la rapporteur du titre
premier madameod
Laforge
merci le président monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur général et mes corapporteurs
mes chers collègues j'ai donc l'honneur
effectivement de rapporter le titre
premier de ce projet de loi il a pour
ambition d'assurer une meilleure
intégration des étrangers par la langue
et par le travail je vais commencer par
la langue le dispositif tel qu'il était
initialement proposé par le gouvernement
incarne les deux axes hein sur lequel
repose ce projet de loi le premier
l'article premier ça a été indiqué rend
obligatoire la maîtrise d'un certain
niveau de français pour l'obtention
d'une carte pluriannuelle et de l'autre
l'article 3 prévoit des formations en
langue étrangère au bénéfice des
salariés hophones afin de favoriser leur
intégration dans le monde du travail
toutes les personnes que nous avons
auditionné on n'a pas fini nos auditions
mais elles ont insisté sur la maîtrise
de la langue comme un élément moteur
d'intégration dans notre société en
effet comment accéder au marché de
l'emploi comment se faire comprendre
comment comprendre les autres si
finalement on ne maîtrise pas la langue
malgré une suppression de l'article 2 en
commission le Sénat finalement
souhaitait maintenir ces deux
dispositions et je m'en félicite
l'article 1emer a néanmoins été amendé
dans une direction que nous ne
partageons pas toujours j'y reviendrai
bien évidemment au cours de nos débats
surtout le Sénat à ce que tu as ajouté
de nombreuses dispositions à ce chapitre
alors au départ il y avait deux articles
et il y en a une douzaine aujourd'hui et
de nombreux articles touchent à la
nationalisation et au droit du sol
toutes ces dispositions ne me semblent
pas pertinemment insérées dans ce
chapitre qui est consacré comme je l'ai
indiqué à l'intégration par la langue ni
d'ailleurs dans le reste de ce projet de
loi qui ne concerne pas les questions de
naturalisation s'agissant de
l'intégration par le travail en second
lieu le travail offre non seulement une
voie vers l'autonomie financière mais
permet de pratiquer la langue et de
tisser des liens sociaux le projet de
loi dont nous allons débattre au cours
des semaines à venir porte des ambitions
je le dis inédites et fort forte en la
matière les chapitres 2 et 3 du titre
1ier lui sont consacrés je souhaite
évoquer rapidement l'article 3 devenu
l'article 4 bis puisque ça a été indiqué
par le rapporteur
général je crois que utile que l'examen
de cet article par notre assemblée soit
l'occasion de travailler à une version
opérante c'est UNP un triple excusez-moi
impératif un impératif humaniste car les
situations de travail illégales sont
trop souvent le terrain d'atteinte à la
dignité humaine un impératif de justice
qui impose notamment de mettre fin à la
nécessité de la coopération de
l'employeur et enfin un impératif
économique parce que d'après les
derniers chiffrre de la DARES notre pays
compte environ 350000 emplois vacants si
la rédaction du Sénat nous semble en
l'état à travailler je crois que revenir
à la version
initiale ne sera pas forcément le bon le
bon chemin et il nous importe de
travailler à un nouveau dispositif comme
l'a indiqué notre rapporteur général SAG
de l'article 4 qui est relatif à
l'accélération de l'accès au marché du
travail par les demandeurs d'asile
ressortissant de pays bénéficiant d'un
taux de protection internationale élevé
en France je vous proposerai mes chers
collègues de rétablir cet article en
effet les étrangers ont de fortes
chances de rester sur le territoire et
autant qu'ils s'intègrent rapidement ils
trouvent un chemin aussi rapide vers
l'autonomie financière c'est d'ailleurs
ce qu'il souhaite je ne suis pas
ailleurs je suis pas ailleurs favorable
à la version sénatoriale de l'article 8
qui remplace la contribution spéciale
par une amende administrative
sanctionnant les employeurs d'étrangers
ne détenant pas un titre les autorisants
à travailler cet article est important
il répond à un enjeu de contrôle du
travail illégal mais aussi de prévention
de l'exploitation et d'équité économique
je me réjouis que nos travaux sur ce
projet de loi débutent et je sais
pouvoir compter sur beaucoup d'entre
nous pour donner à ce titre consacré à
l'intégration des étrangers par la
langue et par le travail sa pleine
portée je vous
remercie merci monsieur le rapporteur du
titre 2 Monsieur Philippe
Pradal merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur général madames et Messieurs
les corapporteurs mes chers collègues
les sujets abordés dans les titres qui
sont confiés à mon rapport sont
importants et particulièrement sensibles
puisqu'il s'agit dans le cadre du titre
2 de rendre possible l'éloignement des
constituant une menace grave pour
l'ordre public et de mieux tirer les
conséquences des actes des étrangers en
matière de droit au séjour le titre de
BIS quant à lui composé entièrement
d'articles issus des discussions au
Sénat comporte des dispositions
destinées à agir pour la mise en œuvre
effective des décisions d'éloignement
nous avons déjà avec le rapporteur
général et mes corapporteurs que je
salue mené de nombreuses auditions et
conduit des échanges avec les services
du ministère notre discussion générale
intervient néanmoins relativement tôt
elle me paraît donc être l'occasion de
vous faire part des convictions qui sont
les miennes mais aussi des sujets sur
lesquels mon opinion n'est pas encore
arrêtée ainsi que des questions sur
lesquelles monsieur le ministre pourra
peut-être nous apporter son éclairage
c'est donc avec beaucoup de prudence et
de modestie que je formule ces premières
analyses le titre 2 comporte des
dispositions ambitieuses qui abordent
des questions sensibles et engageantes
pour notre société je pense notamment
aux articles 9 et 10 qui prévoi
d'assouplir les régimes de protection
dont bénéficient certaines catégories de
ressortissants étrangers en raison des
liens d'attachement qu'ils entretiennent
avec la la France cette mesure est
concie pour faciliter les décisions
d'expulsion et le prononcer de la peine
d'interdiction du territoire cependant
nous devonsonnaître que ce dispositif a
subi des modifications importantes au
sein du Sénat notre responsabilité
aujourd'hui est de travailler ensemble à
établir un équilibre en accord avec les
principes constitutionnels et
conventionnels qui guident notre
démarche l'article 11 du texte permet le
relever signal éthique des étrangers
sans leur consentement lorsqu'ils
refusent de le faire ce qui je le
rappelle est un délit cette mesure me
semble proportionnée à en jeu et le
Sénat lui a ajouté des contraintes
supplémentaires il faudra veiller à ce
qu'elle ne limite pas le caractère
opérationnel de cet objectif je tiens à
souligner l'avancée majeure que
constitue l'article 12 qui interdit la
présence en centre de rétention
administrative des mineurs de 16 ans
cette disposition va dans le bon sens et
je suis convaincu que nous pourrons
poursuivre la réflexion au cours de nos
travaux sur la question de la place des
mineurs en rétention
administrative autre enjeu important
l'article 13 qui prévoit d'encadrer la
délivrance le renouvellement le retrait
de titre à l'ône de critères autour
desquels nous devrions nous retrouver
ainsi ne pas laisser des étrangers sur
notre territoire lorsqu'ils constiue une
medace grave pour l'ordre public tout
comme exiger une résidence habituelle en
France pour les titulaires de titres de
longue durée sont des mesures de bon
sens qui ne devrait pas susciter de
veines polémique il en va de même pour
le respect des principes de la
République précisément définis à la
différente de la précédent tentative de
2021 cette mesure je le rappelle ne fait
qu'étendre un dispositif qui existe déjà
et et est de nature à favoriser
l'intégration des étrangers le Sénat a
souhaité renforcer le dispositif selon
des modalités dont l'opportunité peut
paraître inégal mais nous aurons tout le
loisir d'en débattre concernant le titre
de BIS ajouté par le Sénat il comporte
diverses mesures qui pour certaines font
sens et pour d'autres soulèvent des
interrogations l'article 14a permet de
conditionner la délivrance visalon
séjour et l'aide publique au
développement à la bonne coopération
migratoire le dispositif me paraît
intéressant mais semble pouvoir être
amélioré pour en accroître
l'efficacité même observation pour
l'article 14 B qui rend obligatoire
l'information par les préfets des
organismes de sécurité sociale et de
Pôle emploi des décisions d'qtf et créer
une obligation de radiation une fois la
décision devenue définitive des
améliorations doiv pouvoir être
apportées pour rendre ce dispositif
encore plus opérationnel de même les
dispositions prévues par les articles 14
C qui Allore la durée maximale
d'assignation à résidence d'un étranger
faisant l'objet d'une TF para de nature
à améliorer la mise en œuvre effectif
des mesures
d'éloignement l'opportunité de l'article
14d interroge un petit peu plus
puisqu'il consacre l'unicité de la
délivrance de l'aide au retour or ce
point est déjà garanti par un texte
réglementaire je partagerai également
avec vous la prudence sur l'article 14e
qui paraît réinttroduire une disposition
précédemment supprimée à raison par la
loi en septembre 2018 pour une
immigration maîtrisée un droit d'asile
effectif et une intégration réussie nous
allons donc avoir à battre de l'ensemble
de ces questions comme le rappelait le
rapporteur général avec exigence
précision et sérieux et je l'espère dans
un climat serein et constructif je vous
remercie merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le rapporteur de titres 3 4 et
5 monsieur ludovicque
mendz merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur général mesame madame et
Messieurs les cor rapporteurs mes chers
collègues j'ai l'honneur d'avoir été
nomé rapporteur pour les titres 3 à 5 de
ce projet de loi d'ailleurs misise en
avant à plusieurs reprises prise par le
rapporteur général et et le ministre de
l'Intérieur le titre 3 d'ailleurs
contient des mesures qui j'ose l'espérer
devrai être consensuelles pour nous tous
euh ainsi que l'article 14 renforce la
sanction contre les réseaux de passeur
en criminalisant l'infraction d'aide à
l'entrée au séjour à la circulation si
elle est commise en bande organisé et
présente un danger pour les personnes il
cible également les dirigeants des
réseaux afin là aussi de lutter contre
les filières d'immigration clandestines
dont les premières victimes sont souvent
exploitées sont des enfants des femmes
et des hommes qui ont besoin de
protection dans le même esprit l'article
15 durcit la répression à l'égard des
marchands de sommeil afin de lutter le
plus efficacement possible contre ceux
qui exploitent la vulnérabilité des
étrangers loin des polémiques
politiciennes je pense que nous pouvons
tous nous retrouver non seulement sur
les objectifs mais aussi sur les
modalités qui sont proposé le titre 3
garantit aussi un renforcement des
contrôles aux frontières en prévoyant le
contrôle par les transporteurs de la
nouvelle autorisation de voyage ethas en
permettant la visite sommaire de
voitures particulières pour éviter le
contournement les contournement constaté
et sur cet aspect je vous renvoie à ce
que nous avons fait au sein de la
commission des lois et et en publique
sur le code des douanes récemment
modifié et enfin en permettant de
refuser le visa à une personne qui ne
justifie pas avoir respecté une
précédente
OQTF le titre 4 propose une réforme
ambitieuse et structurelle de notre
système d'asile je vais insister plus
particulièrement sur les deux
dispositions qui figuraient dans le
texte initial transmis par le
gouvernement il s'agit d'abord de
l'article 19 qui prévoit la création de
pôles territoriauxx fr asile ces pôles
territoriaux permettrai de renforcer les
guichets uniques qui existent
aujourd'hui au sein des actuels Gudas le
demandeur peut enregistrer sa demande
auprès des services préfectoraux
recevoir les conditions matérielles
d'accueil de la part de l'OFI l'article
19 prévoit qu'il puisse également avoir
un premier contact avec un agent de
lofpra pour l'introduction de sa demande
d'asile cette réforme me paraît une
bonne chose pour le demandeur qui sera
accompagné par un agent mieux armé pour
le guider dans ses premières formalités
notamment le choix de la langue
d'entretien qui est parfois un vrai
casse-etête sur certains territoires et
permettra d'accélérer les délis de
traitement de demande je suis donc
convaincu que l'expérimentation prévue
par le Sénat n'est pas nécessaire et
j'espère que nous parviendrons à
convaincre qu'un déploiement progressif
avec des sites pilotes de ces de ces
pôles territoriaux et la meilleure des
solutions à trouver j'appelle par
ailleurs votre attention sur l'article
20 qui a été adopté par le Sénat dans sa
version initiale et qui propose une
réforme de la CNDA destinée à rapprocher
le demandeur d'asile et le juge de
l'asile l'article 20 prop ose de créer
des chambres territoriales pour la CNDA
qui siège pour l'heure presque
simplement qu'à Montreuil et qui siège
qu'à Montreuil pas presque d'ailleurs et
quand on arrive de Tarbe ou de certains
territoires de France où le les voies de
transport sont compliqué c'est assez
complexe pour montrer un montreil et se
faire entendre euh il propose également
avec des garanties de généraliser la
formation avec un juge unique qui n'est
pour le moment utilisé que dans un
nombre de cas restreints enfin le titre
5 constitue le titre 5 constitue une
avancée majeure dans la modernisation et
la Simp simplification du contentieux
des étrangers au cœur de cette réforme
des règlements contentieuses l'article
21 qui a fait l'objet d'ajustement
significatif par le Sénat dans sa
rédaction actuelle cet article propose
de réduire le nombre de procédures
applicables à trois au lieu de la
douzaine qui a été dénombrée par le
Conseil d'État dans son étude cette
simplification facilitera non seulement
le travail des acteurs impliqués dans le
domaine mais garantira également un
accès à la justice plus rapide et
équitable pour les individus concernés
les articles 21 et 24 propose également
des mesures concrètes pour améliorer le
fonctionnement de la justice rendue dans
ce cadre la délocalisation des audiences
dans des salles spécialement aménagées
situé à proximité des lieux de retention
ou des zones d'attente offre une réponse
adaptée à l'exigence de rapidité et
d'efficacité du traitement judiciaire de
ce type de contentieux la facilitation
la facilitation de la vidéo audience
tant devant le juge administratif que
devant le juge des libertés et de la
détention participe aussi et je le crois
à l'objectif de bonne administration de
la justice notre responsabilité est de
trouver le juste équilibre entre
efficacité et protection des droits de
l'étranger justiciable enfin l'article
25 tient lui aussi compte de de manière
très concrète à l'évolution du
contentieux des étrangers et permet
d'adopter les règles procédurelles à la
raité de contentieux cette disposition
tire notamment les leçons de
l'expérience du traitement judiciaire
des migrants arrivé à bord de l'ochan
Viking à Toulon en novembre 2022 comme
nous l'avons rapporté à la commission
des lois ce débat nous devons l'avoir
nous pouvons plus nous ne pouvons plus
le repousser nous devons l'accepter tel
qu'il est car oui certaines dispositions
ajouté au Sénat sont utiles à notre pays
toutes les supprimées seraient une
erreur ces trois titres proposent donc
des dispositions qui me paraissent
essentielles et sur lesquelles je ne
doute pas que nous pourvons trouver un
nous pouvons avoir pardon un débat
apaisé et trouver un accord constructif
et utile pour les français pour les
ressortissants et pour le
gouvernement monsieur le rapporteur du
titre 6 Monsieur Olivier servard merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
madames messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues j'ai l'honneur d'avoir
été nommé rapporteur du titre 6 de de ce
projet de loi je voudrais en cette
qualité être ici la voie des territoires
ultramarins en effet si le titre 6 ne
comporte à ce jour que deux articles il
ne concerne pas moins des enjeux majeurs
tout d'abord son article 26 a vocation à
déterminer l'application spécifique aux
outromè des mesures qui seront votées
par notre assemblée tandis que l'article
27 détermine les modalités d'entrée en
vigueur de certaines de ces dispositions
à ce titre je tiens à saluer la démarche
du gouvernement qui a pris eng agement
devant le Sénat d'inscrire directement
dans la loi les dispositions applicables
à certains territoires d'outr m plutôt
que d'avoir recours à une mise en œuvre
par ordonnance l'amendement adopté au
Sénat sur cet article a ainsi permis
d'exclure du champ de l'habilitation
légiféré par ordonnance la Guadeloupe la
Martinique la Guyane la Réunion Mayotte
et Saint-Pierre et miclon nous aurons
ainsi pour C territoire la possibilité
de déterminer directement dans le projet
de loi les mesures qui qui que nous
souhaitons voir appliquer en revanche
Saint-Martin saint-martinemi wal Futuna
la Polynésie française et la
Nouvelle-Calédonie feront l'objet
d'ordonnance à ce stade la situation de
ces collectivités mérite entièrement de
faire l'objet d'un débat parlementaire
devant la représentation nationale et je
me réjouis que nous puissions le faire
ici toutefois si c territoire ultrarin
justifie pleinement l'attention du
législateur ils ne peuvent pour autant
faire l'objet d'une approche
monolithique les 11 territoires
d'outremè habités présentent une
diversité d'enjeux qui ne peuvent être
abordés sous le prisme d'une norme
unique ainsi la situation de la Guyane
qui compte 35 % de personnes étrangère
sur son sol n'est pas comparable à la
Guadeloupe où ce chiffre s'élève à 4 %
en situation irrégulière de même la
Guyane qui partage des centaines de
kilomètres de frontières terrestres avec
le Surinam et le Brésil ne présente
nécessairement pas les même difficulté
que les îles de Saint-Pierre et Miquelon
au largeamérique du Nord qui ne compte
que 80 étrangers sur leur sol dès lors
certaines de ces collectivités font face
à des flux importants
d'entréesrégulières le cas de Mayotte et
sa titre ce titre emblématique puisque
un/ers de la population sera en
situation irrégulière sur l'île tandis
que d'autres collectivités peineent au
contraire à attirer la main d'œuvre
suffisante pour répondre aux besoins du
marché du travail par exemple
Saint-Pierre et miclon
c'est pourquoi en tant que rapporteur
j'ai choisi de mener une concertation
avec l'ensemble des 11 territoires
situés en NREM pour chacune de ces
audition j'ai associé l'ensemble des
représentants du territoire service de
l'État déconcentrés élus locaux
parlementaires et association uvrant
dans le domaine afin de recueillir tous
les points de vue et bâtir des
propositions faisant l'objet de
consensus je porte la conviction
profonde qu'aucune mesure ne doit être
adopté sans une très large adhésion des
territoires
concernés et cette conviction guidera
mon travail lors de l'ensemble des
discussions que nous allons animer dans
les semaines à venir je tiens d'ors et
déjà à insister sur la nécessité de
réfléchir à des mécanisme de
territorialisation des métiers en
tenstion définis par l'article 4 ter du
projet de loi une telle liste ne saurait
être défin de manière uniforme et
unilatérale pour les territoires
d'outromè qui présentent des
particularités très fortes en terme
d'emploi et de besoins de main- d'œuvre
ainsi le SO de mécanisme de consultation
des acteurs locaux a été à plusieurs
reprises exprimé par les territoire que
j'ai entendu de même la durée de titre
de séjour délivré dans le cadre du
mécanisme de régularisation de l'article
4 bis devrait pouvoir être modulé afin
de tenir compte de l'éloignement et des
délais de traitement de la délivrance
des titres de séjour dans certains
territoires d'outrreemè le travail de
concertation que je mène actuellement à
vocation à se poursuivre dans les
prochains jours et je vous proposerai à
son terme chers collègue monsieur le
ministre des solutions sur mesure pour
chaque territoire d'outreomè le cas
échéant en fonction des souhaits que
leur représentant m'auront exprimé et
des besoins que ces auditions auront
permis d'identifier le cadre
constitutionnel nous permet de procéder
à ces adaptations afin de tenir compte
des caractéristiques et contraintes
particulières de ces collectivités je
formule le souhait que nos travaux au
sein de cette commission nous permett de
nous saisir pleinement de cette
opportunité afin d'accorder à ces
territoire toute l'attention qu'il
mérite à cet égard monsieur le ministre
que pensez-vous de cette démarche qui
permettrait d'avoir le cas échéant un
article par territoire je vous remercie
merci on a fini avec les expressions des
rapporteurs j'ai donc appelé les
orateurs des différents groupes je
rappelle que la durée d'expression des
orateurs est de 4 minutes monsieur
Guillaume gouffi Valante pour le groupe
Renaissance merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur général madame la rapporteur
messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues au nom du groupe Renaissance
permettez-moi de saluer votre travail et
la clarté de vos propos qui viennent
nous éclairer sur les enjeux de ce
projet de loi sur sa philosophie et la
manière dont vous envis ager ses
évolutions après son adoption au Sénat
le 14 novembre dernier les sujets
migratoires sont un des enjeux de notre
époque et des années à venir nous sommes
face à un défi humain sur lequel nous
savons les attentes de nos concitoyens
fortes nous sommes face à un sujet qui
reviendra certainement aussi de manière
régulière devant notre assemblée aussi
il est important d'aborder ce texte avec
une certaine humilité et un réel sens
des responsabilités il est important de
l'aborder en sachant de quoi nous
parlons exactement premièrement
ettâchons de ne jamais l'oublier nous
parlons d'hommes de femmes enfants qui
sont amenés bien souvent contre leur gré
à quitter leur territoire les raisons
elles sont connues du fait des
conséquences du dérèglement climatiques
des conflits et des guerres pour des
raisons économiques sociales ou
politiques ce sont près de 130 millions
de personnes qui sont considérées comme
déplacées dans le monde en 2023 et si la
pression migratoire se fait de plus en
plus forte sur nos pays de l'Union
européenne ce sont bien majoritairement
les pays les plus vulnérables qui
accueillent la majorité de ces personnes
déplacées parler de l'immigration c'est
aussi parler des valeurs que porte notre
pays pays de notre modèle républicain et
social c'est également parler de notre
souveraineté de nos politiques
d'intégration parler d'immigration c'est
parler de notre cohésion sociale et
notre avenir c'est parler d'Europe et du
monde dans lequel nous vivons un monde
qui au fond n'est qu'un village où
chaque événement qui survient peut avoir
des conséquences sur notre société les
réponses apportées par le projet de loi
présenté par le gouvernement sont de
nature à répondre à ces enjeux dans le
respect de nos valeurs et des attentes
de nos concitoyens d'abord en venant
renforcer considérablement nos
politiques d'intégration en facilitant
l'apprentissage de la langue en revoyant
à la hausse aussi nos attentes en la
matière en assumant de renforcer
l'intégration par l'accès au travail par
ailleurs conditions synéquanon d'une
bonne intégration ensuite en facilitant
les règles d'expulsion avec la remise en
place de la double peine pour celles et
ceux qui ne respectent pas les règles de
notre société et en alourdissant les
sanctions à l'encontre des réseaux
mafieux de trait humaine qui organisent
une partie de l'immigration irrégulière
pour reprendre vos mots monsieur le
ministre oui c'est être gentil avec les
gentils et méchant avec les méchants
enfin nous nous devons aussi à travers
ce texte de simplifier encore un certain
nombre de procédures afin de répondre
plus rapidement aux demandes de séjour
sur notre territoire ou d'obtenir du
statut de réfugié en outre nous
n'oublions pas que ce texte ne se suffit
pas à lui-même il s'inscrit dans la
continuité de la loi de 2018 qui a
permis de diminuer par deux les délais
de traitement de demande d'asile de pr
dans la continuité de la loi de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur également qui nous a permis
d'augmenter de 25 % les crédits dédié à
l'intégration et d'ouvrir un travail de
refonte importante des préfectures comme
vous le rappeliez à ce contexte
législatif national j'ajoute bien
entendu les travaux essentiels menés au
niveau européen qui doivent fonder une
grande partie des réponses à ce défi le
texte qui nous provient du Sénat a été
aprement discuté et amendé par nos
collègues sénateurs le sujet est
difficile mais je formule le vœux que
nos débats se déroulent dans le même
état d'esprit républicain que ceux que
nous avons pu suivre à distance au
Palais du Luxembourg bien entendu si
nous saluons le fait qu'un compromis a
pu être trouvé au Sénat afin que le
texte y soit adopté en gardant
d'ailleurs la majorité des mesures du
projet initial la quasi totalité
d'ailleurs je ne vous cache pas le fait
que sur un certain nombre de points qui
ont été ajoutés nos désaccords sont
réels à aucun moment nous ne pourrons
accepter les despositions qui ont été
introduites sur la me sur le droit de la
nationalité sur les MNA sur la
restriction de l'accès aux prestations
sociales par exemple toutefois fort de
la volonté de répondre aux enjeux posés
par ce texte et
fort toutefois fort de la volonté de
répondre aux enjeux posés par ce texte
et fort de la volonté d'adopter des
dispositions les plus claires et
efficaces possibles c'est bien entendu
avec attention que nous regardons
certaines dispositions qui ont pu y être
ajouté et certaines discussions qui sont
de nature à améliorer ce projet de loi
que nous regarderons avec efficacité et
dans l'attachement des les valeurs qui
sont les nôtres pour l'adopter à la fin
nous l'espérons vous merci merci merci
moi aussi je dois un petit peu
domestiquer le matériel de la salle la
Martine monsieur gilet pour le groupe
rassemblement national
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues quand on parle
d'immigration nous devons nous poser
deux questions la première quel est
l'impact de l'immigration sur la vie de
nos compatriotes et sur notre pays la
seconde que veulent nos compatriotes en
la matière si je ne n nullement les
quelques améliorations que ce texte
contient je sais aussi combien la gauche
et une partie de la majorité vont tenter
de le modifier ici à l'Assemblée pour
accentuer le laxisme migratoire je sais
aussi combien même en sa sortie du Sénat
le texte ne répond pas à toutes les
attentes des Français ni à l'urgence de
la situation dans les médias vous
affichez une lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière et en même temps vous
souhaitez la régularisation des
travailleurs clandestins sé vérité
affichée et en même temps l'acisme
migratoire la réalité c'est que comme
vos prédécesseurs vous organisez les
appels d'air sur le droit du sol rien
d'efficace n'est prévu sur la politique
d'immigration régulière rien non plus or
depuis qu'Emmanuel Macron est président
la France a délivré 1,6 million de
premers tites de séjour à des immigrés
extraeuropéens c'est un record rien non
plus sur l'immigration irrégulière Vous
estimier le 2 novembre dernier devant
notre commission entre 600 et 900000
étrangers irréguliers sur le territoire
national votre incapacité et votre
manque de volonté à maîtriser nos
frontières sont malheureusement évidents
pire vous ne prévoyez rien pour couper
les pompes ent de l'immigration le
nombre de bénéficiaires de l'AME était
de 400000 en 2022 ce dispositif coûte
1,2 milliard d'euros au français chaque
année et si les sénateurs ont eu la
sagesse de reprendre la mesure de Marine
Le Pen consistant à remplacer laame par
une aide médicale d'urgence la première
ministre exige que vous réintroduisiez
ce dispositif coûteux et injuste pour
les Français en ce qui concerne la
demande d'asile qui a triplé en disant
votre projet ne durcit aucunement la
procédure malgré son dévoiement
permanent les étrangers obtiennent chez
che nous plus facilement le statut de
réfugié coutreerin qu'en Suède qu'en
Norvège qu'en Autriche ou qu'au
danemarque car c'est bien là le sujet le
dévoiement du droit d'asile a une
incidence sur ceux qui peuvent
réellement y prétendre en plus d'avoir
un impact sur l'économie du pays que
dire aussi de l'expulsion des étrangers
en situation irrégulière et de l'absence
totale du principe de priorité nationale
dans ce projet de loi vous êtes
également mué sur le problème de
l'hébergement inconditionnel des
migrants clandestins alors que tant de
Français n'arrivent pas à se loger
correctement ensuite et c'est peut-être
plus grave encore vous proposez monsieur
le ministre derrière la prétendue
fermeté affichée pour assoir vos
ambitions personnelles d'adopter un
article qui va aboutir à la vague de
régulation de régularisation de
clandestin la plus massive de l'histoire
de notre pays oui l'article 3 a été
supprimé en hémicycle du Sénat après
avoir été approuvé en commission y
compris par les helleurs d'ailleurs mais
non seulement cet article a simplement
pris une autre forme en l'article 4 bis
mais en plus votre majorité va tenter de
le réintroduire sous sa forme initiale
sous une forme ou sous une autre le
résultat est le même vous souhaitez
donner une prime à la clandestinité
alors que la surreprésentation des
étrangers dans la délinquence est une
réalité et que 5 million de Français
sont sans emploi votre proj va accentuer
les avantages au profit d'étrangers
clandestins clandestins donc délinquants
vous ignorer les problèmes de notre pays
les failles pour notre sécurité
collective pour les comptes publics pour
les salaires des Français et pour
l'économie monsieur le ministre l'heure
est grave c'est pour cela que les
Français sont 83 % à demander un
référendum le propose Marine Le Pen et
qu'ils veulent une politique migratoire
ferme c'est pour cette raison que les
députés du rassemblement national
amenderont ce texte afin de renforcer
les conditions de séjour pour les
étrangers en finir avec l'ame et le
droit du sol refonder la politique
française de l'asile lutter profondément
contre l'immigration irrégulière
redonner enfin à la France la maîtrise
de ses instruments juridiques François
miteran disait en 1990 88 pardon ceux
qui sont clandestins il faut qu'ils
rentrent chez eux comme quoi même ceux
qui qui ont une responsabilité dans le
déclin de notre pays peuvent avoir des
moments de lucidité merci madame ellisa
Martin pour le groupe la France
insomis merci de me donner la parole la
liberté c'est l'esclavage l'ignorance
c'est la force tel est l'esprit de votre
loi monsieur Darmanin personne n'est
dupe que cela soit nous la France
insoumise la gauche ou bien les
associations les collectifs les
syndicats les institutions les avocats
personne n'est dupe dans le contexte
d'aras de l'attaque d'aras monsieur
Darmanin vous avez défendu votre loi
comme la plus dure et la plus ferme
présentée depuis 30 ans comme une
réponse au terrorisme en quoi une
dégradation majeure des droits
permettrait de lutter contre le
terrorisme votre projet est mensongé il
est fondé sur le postulat selon lequel
notre pays serait submergé par une
prétendue vague migratoire or si l'on
rapporte le nombre de réfugiés
accueillis dans notre pays à la la
population notre pays est le 20e pays
d'accueil dans l'Union européenne à
contre-courant des mythes que vous vous
plaisez à alimenter votre projet est
superflu c'est le 29e texte sur
l'immigration depuis
1983 toujours àourir inlassablement
derrière la politique du chiffre votre
politique et votre projet est trompeur
cette inflation législative n'a
aucunement pour but de développer une
politique digne pour tous comme nous le
demanderions au contraire elle vise à
rendre notre pays de plus en plus
hostile à celles et ceux qui pourraient
y espérer y trouver des conditions
d'existence digne à même même vis-à-vis
de ceux qui d'une façon légitime au sens
premier du terme devrai pouvoir y
trouver protection et asile le
démantèlement d'ailleurs du système
d'asile que votre texte acterait et
représentatif de cette tendance votre
texte est dangereux en effet nous
assistons à travers cette dégradation
inédite des droits des étrangers et du
droit d'asile à une insupportable
inversion de la hiérarchie des normes
comme d'autres comme des humains le
droit humain le droit de l'enfant tout
ça est passé pardessus bord votre projet
est inhumain vous avez recours à des
concepts malléables à souhait pour
justifier le durcissement de ces mesures
d'éloignement et la soi-disante
augmentation de ces taux d'exécution au
détriment des personnes malades des
enfants et de la réalité du
fonctionnement de la procédure en droit
des étrangers et son application votre
projet est un projet de division
division entre les uns et les autres
division entre ceux qui sont ici et ceux
qui voudraient pouvoir s'y installer
dans votre vision étrangers riment avec
criminel migrant riment avec humains au
moindre droit alors même que les
sciences humaines s'accordent
unanimement sur l'absence d'impact entre
et de lien entre l'immigration et la
délinquence vous avez ouvert la porte te
à toutes les régressions évidemment et
vous le saviez la droite sénatoriale s'y
est engouffrée reprenant adoptant les
pires disposition retrait du titre de
séjour par exemple pour motif d'adhésion
au djihadisme alors que ces mêmes
dispositions ont été censurées par le
Conseil constitutionnel dans la loi
séparatiste allongement de la durée de
rétention administrative maximale de 3 à
18 mois comme dans l'Italie de mélonie
suppression de l'aide médicale d'État
alors même que huit personnes éligibles
sur 10 n'ont pas recours à cellees-ci
alors qu'elles alors qu'elles y auraient
droit selon les données de Médecin du
Monde vous prétendez être juste en
régularisant dans votre texte initial
les travailleurs étrangers dans les
métiers en tension nous n'accepterons
pas cette vision utilitariste et
hypocrite des travailleurs vous
prétendez vouloir réformer nos
institutions et en particulier la
procédure d'asile dont la France
pourrait être fière sous prétexte d'une
réduction des délais et d'un
rapprochement des entre les demandeurs
et les structures nous n'accepterons pas
l'impartialité que vous souhaitez
définir définitivement mettre àas de la
CNDA nous n'accepterons pas la fin de la
dépendance de l'OFPRA de l'indépendance
de l'OFPRA au pays des droits de l'homme
tous les humains sont égaux mais selon
vous il y en a madame an jeunevard pour
le groupe les
républicains merci monsieur le président
de la commission des lois monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
madamees et Messieurs les rapporteurs
chers collègues permettez-moi tout
d'abord de vous exprimer le plaisir que
j'ai à rejoindre votre commission pour
l'examin des textes de loi immigration à
la fois le projet de loi issu des
travaux du Sénat mais aussi la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle des
républicain pour lesquels j'ai l'honneur
d'être oratrice au nom de mon groupe
monsieur le ministre nous vous
auditionnons aujourd'hui en
préfiguration de l'examen de votre
projet de loi destiné à contrôler
l'immigration et améliorer l'intégration
initialement composé et de 27 articles
le texte en comporte désormais 96 c'est
dire combien les travaux menés par nos
collègues sénateurs l'ont transformé en
profondeur la situation que nous
connaissons justifie à nos yeux la
fermeté des sénateurs à l'égard d'une
situation migratoire hors de contrôle
chacun connaît les chiffres ils sont
plus qu'alarmants et comment s'étonner
dès lors que 74 % des Français rejettent
la politique du gouvernement en matière
migratoire cette opinion est est un fait
qui nous met en face de nos
responsabilités je dirais même que c'est
l'heure de vérité notre pays est à la
fois laxiste et impuissant c'est donc du
côté de la fermeté qu'il faut aller car
en matière d'ouverture nous sommes si
j'ose dire largement pourvus les
chiffres en attestent ils disent une
réalité dont nous n'avons pas le droit
d'ignorer les conséquences en matière
d'insécurité de perte de souveraineté de
perte de cohésion nationale de
déséquilibres financiers et sociaux
assouplir et durcir l'impossible oxyor
pour reprendre l'expression de Pierre
brochan ce texte permettra-t-il de
remédier au problème le Sénat s'y est
employé et a produit un texte qui mesure
après mesure corrige l'existant et nous
aurons matière à le corriger encore quen
ferez-vous les premières déclarations de
membres de votre majorité et ce soir
encore permettent de nourrir bien des
inquiétudes en matière de métier en
tension certains veulent revenir à la
rédaction initiale qui crée une nouvelle
filière d'immigration et de nouvelles
sources de contentieux au moment même où
le taux de chômage des des immigrés est
de 16 % où le taux de chômage en
catégorie A augmente funeste en même
temps si les régularisations que la
France conduit massivement depuis 1981
avait résolu les problèmes et Taris les
flux ça se saurait régulariser les
métiers enenttention c'est amorcé une
pompe inépuisable nous dit encore
l'ancien directeur de la
DGSE quant à l'AME qui n'est l'un que
les que l'un des 11 dispositifs
existants en matière de santé des
étrangers certains dans votre majorité
au gouvernement exige sa restauration en
caricaturant le dispositif que nous
proposons de lui substituer et qui
garantit pourtant la protection de la
santé publique mais la principale raison
qui nourrit nos doutes sur l'efficacité
de ce texte et qu'il ignore délibérément
les freins à son application exécuter
les eqtf ou les expulsions mettre en
place des plafonds migratoires ou dur
les conditions d'accès au regroupement
familial pour ne citer que quelques
exemples du texte se heurteront au
droits conventionnel et sa jurisprudence
ou au cours souveraines national la
gestion de l'immigration dans notre pays
est largement dictée par des
dispositions
supranationales seul une réforme de la
Constitution assurera une pleine
effectivité de ce texte redonnera à la
France le droit d'accueillir sur son sol
qui elle veut et la la possibilité de se
protéger d'une immigration massive et
subie qui porte à aux intérêts
fondamentaux de la nation vous le savez
monsieur le ministre le président de la
République le sait aussi c'est pourquoi
nous avons déposé une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle qui seule nous
permettra de reprendre le contrôle nous
verrons bien lors de son examen le 7
décembre prochain ce que le Parlement
souverain en dira monsieur le ministre
comprenez bien que les républicains
parfaitement conscients des enjeux
veulent que cette loi ne soit pas la 40e
qui rejoigne la longue série de lois
inutiles ou inefficaces merci les
républiques veulent un vrai changement
de paradigme non pas gérer les flux
migratoires mais en finir avec
l'immigration Monsieur Emmanuel Mandon
pour le groupe
démocrate merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre mesdames Messieurs
les rapporteurs mes chers collègues le
groupe démocrate aborde l'examen de ce
projet de loi avec un double souci d'une
part bien comprendre l'attente de
réforme de l'opinion publique à laquelle
il veut répondre et d'autre part être
fidèle aux valeurs humanistes qui
fondent notre conception de la
démocratie où toutes les réconciliations
doivent être possies le devoir du
législateur est de les garantir ainsi
que les principes républicains pour y
parvenir le projet initial réaliser un
certain nombre d'équilibre entre deux
impératifs l'intégration réussie pour
les étrangers en situation régulière et
la maîtrise efficace de l'immigration
irrégulière la réussite de l'intégration
d'abord elle passe par la maîtrise de la
langue qui est la garantie première de
la volonté de participer à un pays avec
son mode de vie et par l'engagement dans
le travail pour gagner sa vie la
maîtrise de l'immigration irrégulière
ensuite projet du gouvernement
souhaitait supprimer un certain nombre
de facilités qui est qui était qui était
autant de brèche dans la protection de
notre pays contre l'immigration
clandestine il raccourcirait ainsi
opportunément les délais de procédure
pour l'examen initial des requêtes et
des recours en particulier les réforme
la Cour nationale du droit d'asile nous
déplorons que dans sa volonté de
dissuader à toute force l'immigration
clandestine et de limiter l'immigration
illégale le Sénat est toutefois pêché
par esprit de système en raccourcissant
ainsi trop les délais au détriment du
droit au recours effectif en imposant
des exigences sans doute excessives aux
étudiants étrangers ou en définissant
entre autes étroitement les condition du
regroupement familial le Sénat a porté
des atteintes qui nous paraissent
disproportionné disons-le au libert
constittu constitutive des principes de
la République et sur tous ces points le
groupe démocrate soutiendra des
amendements de suppression tout d'abord
évidemment il faudra revenir sur la
suppression pure et simple en l'état de
la me et supprimer les dispositions
relatives à la nationalité manifestement
sans lien avec le projet initial ce
qu'il faut faire c'est définir des
règles claires pour l'entrée bien sûr et
le séjour des étrangers en particulier
pour les mineurs non accompagnés faire
respecter notre souveraineté lutter avec
vigueur contre les passeurs et les
marchands de sommeil lutter sans doute
aussi contre le dévoiement du droit
d'asile à cet égard nous saluons la
volonté de réduire les délais de
traitement des demandes sur la question
des métiers en tension le compromis
trouvé au Sénat sous l'impulsion de
notre partenaire le groupe centriste
Union centriste ouvre un chemin et nous
constatons qu'en laissant la main au
préfet il inscrit dans la loi ce qui en
fin de compte est toujours la réalité
nous en comprenons l'esprit mais nous
nous interrogeons sur l'impact réel
s'agissant du nombre de régularisation
et et les métiers concernés en outre le
groupe démocrate souhaite la
clarification des responsabilités
respectives du maire et de
l'administration dans la vérification
des conditions de vie des étrangers et
est d'ailleurs attaché également à la
reconnaissance explicite par la loi du
rôle des associations enfin le groupe
démocrate souhaite poser la question
opérationnelle de l'application de ces
des dispositions légales en clair nous
pointons ici la capacité de
l'administration à s'y adapter la
question se pose particulièrement à
propos du traitement expérimental dit à
360°gr des demandes de titre de
séjours en conclusion vous l'aurez
compris nous sommes vraiment attachés à
un texte équilibré et pour cela nous
devons nous donner toutes les chances de
réussir cette réforme par un travail de
fond en
responsabilité avec pragmatisme et
Humanisme je vous remercie monsieur HERV
Solignac pour le groupe
socialiste merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre il y a 1 an vous
présentiez un texte avec le ministre du
Travail dans un duo assez bien rodé et
je dois confesser monsieur le ministre
que ce texte initial constituait une
base de discussion intéressante sur
certains aspects s'agissant notamment de
l'intégration par le travail qui de MEUR
de notre point de vue le moyen le plus
opérant pour accueillir dignement un
étranger dans la communauté nationale à
cet égard le ministre du seuple déclaré
je le cite il y a une forme d'absurdité
du système on enferme certains étrangers
dans l'inactivité et d'autres dans
l'inégalité vous-même monsieur le
ministre vous avez enfoncé le clou je
vous cite à votre tour nous ne donnons
peut-être pas assez de titre de séjour
aux gens qui travaillent et qu'un
certain patronat utilise comme une armée
de réserve alors on s'interroge entre le
texte présenté il y a 1 an et le texte
qui nous arrive du Sénat que s'est-il
passé on devait examiner un texte
méchant avec les méchants et gentils
avec les gentils on se retrouve avec un
texte méchant avec tout le monde ce
projet de loi désintègre plus qu'il
n'intègre il accroit les contrainte et
multiplie les motifs de contentieux au
fond on se demande qui est le vrai
Gérald d'armanin celui qui présente un
texte en conseil des ministres dont on a
le sentiment qu'il s'inscrit dans un
cadre républicain ou bien celui qui
donne des avis de sagesse coupable au
Sénat parce que la fin justifie les
moyens alors venons-en au fond à ce
stade le droit des étrangers va
poursuivre sa vie dans le pays de
l'Absurdie et le royaume de l'hypocrisie
à cet égard la liste est longue on peut
par exemple dans ce pays travailler
avoir le devoir de payer des cotisations
et ne pas avoir de droit en retour
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
travailleurs irréguliers sont dans cette
situation profondément injuste quant à
celui qui ne travaille pas qui ne
travaille pas pardon donc parfois sous
le le coup d'une qtf absurde parce qu'
inapplicable il restera soumis à la
clandestinité et à une épreuve terrible
pendant des années avant que la
République ne consente à l'accueillir en
son sein par ce texte vous cédez au myth
de l'appel d'air selon lequel si on
traite trop bien les populations
étrangères qui arrivent sur notre sol
alors ça va être la submersion au nom de
ce mythe que fait-on et bien on dégrade
l'accueil de ces populations étrangères
pensant qu'on va tarir la source et ça
n'est pas la lutte contre les passeurs
ou les marchands de sommeil qui va
modifier cette réalité chacun sait que
notre politique migratoire n'est ni
généreuse ni ferme elle est brouillonne
confuse et souvent illisible la France
accueille mal protège mal intègre mal et
même je le dis ici reconduit mal les
Français doivent comprendre que ce texte
en l'état c'est plus de précarité plus
de travail dissimulé plus de contentieux
plus de gens malades en un mot c'est
plus de désordre le groupe socialiste
défendra une politique de l'ordre répu
Iain avec des critères d'admission clair
une véritable politique d'accueil et
d'inclusion notamment par le travail
mais aussi par l'éducation
l'enseignement du français comme des
valeurs de la République l'accès à la
santé bien entendu une répartition aussi
organisée et solidaire en Europe comme
sur le territoire national des moyens
enfin pour instruire correctement les
droits des étrangers ou pour protéger
les mineurs non non accompagné nous
voulons croire ici qu'il existe une
majorité de députés pour faire revenir
ce texte dans le champ de la République
et de ses principes s'agissant des
débats que nous aurons sur notamment la
suppression de la me les conditions de
maîtrise de la langue française cette
terrible franchise de 5 ans que le Sénat
a introduit pour accéder aux allocations
sociales les quotas ou bien encore la
remise en cause du droit du sol sachez
que pieds à pied sur chacun de ces
points et bien d'autres encore sans
idéologie mais pas sans idéal le groupe
socialiste se battra pour ramener ce
texte dans le champ de la République
dont il est malheureusement sorti merci
Monsieur Laurent marcangelli pour le
groupe horizon merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre madames
et Messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues cela a été dit au cours des
dernières décennies de nombreux textes
ont eu à débattre de ce sujet qui par
d'innombrables raisons nous anime toutes
et tous profondément la question de la
politique migratoire elle est sensible
car elle touche au cœur ce qui fait la
France ce qu' a faite et ce qu' la fera
or depuis des décennies nous souffrons
d'une incapacité à nous projeter d'une
incapacité à fixer une trajectoire cette
incapacité elle conduit parfois à des
largesses des des permissivités mais
également des injustices les Français ne
les acceptent plus à juste titre la
réponse à la question migratoire elle
inquiète légitimement nos compatriotes
elle suppose d'établir de la nuance
cette nuance elle n'empêche en rien la
fermeté et surtout surtout le réalisme
c'est un sujet bien trop sérieux pour
que le débat public se limite à la
petite phrase n'en déplaise à certains
il faut le reconnaître et ne pas avoir
peur de le
dire notre pays connaît parfois des
tensions exacerbées en raison d'une
immigration que certains de nos
compatriotes considèrent comme
subit notre modèle social ainsi que nos
services publics sont soumis à une forte
tension qui pousse nos capacités
d'intégration à leurs extrêmes limites
que d'un point de vue économique
l'immigration est un moteur mais qu'elle
entraîne aussi parfois la paupérisation
de nos travailleurs dire enfin que nous
sommes face à un véritable vertige
démographique pour les décennies qui
sont devant nous il est donc grand temps
de changer de braquer de porter une
véritable vision de la politique
migratoire française car notre système
actuel est trop fragile et il doit être
adapté pour préserver la cohésion
nationale est-ce que ce projet de loi va
régler toutes les difficultés en la
matière je ne le crois pas pourrait-on
s'en passer la réponse est non oui ce
texte est indispensable même si nous le
savons tous il ne suffira pas il est
indispensable car il tend vers un
système dans lequel nous serons capables
de ne pas subir de ne plus subir ou de
de moins subir notamment sur le
recesserement des conditions de
regroupement et de réunification
familiale ou encore sur la limitation du
renouvellement des carte de séjour
temporaire il est indispensable aussi
parce qu'il est grand temps de muscler
notre stratégie d'éloignement vous
l'avez dit monsieur le ministre nous
partageons avec vous la nécessité de
pouvoir lever un certain nombre de
protections lorsqu'un étranger constitue
une menace pour l'ordre public de la
même manière il faut donner au préfet
les moyens de refuser ou de retirer
tites de séjour des étrangers lorsque
les cas se présentent soyons extrêmement
clair un étranger qui ne se conforme pas
au principe républicain et constitue une
menace pour l'ordre public doit être
éloigné ou expulsé il est indispens
enfin car il replace les valeurs de la
République la langue le travail au cœur
de l'intégration cette exigence
républicaine ce n'est même pas une
condition c'est un préalable
l'immigration ne saait conduire à un
délitement de nos valeurs fondamentales
le travail en fait partie c'est une
condition incontournable de
l'intégration et de la nécessaire
contribution de chacun à notre pays il
ne suffira pas néanmoins car depuis la
création de l'espace Schengen agir seul
en la matière n'aurait que peu de sens
il faut qu'une action collective
européenne se déploie au côté bien sûr
d'une stratégie nationale de protection
de nos frontières à ce titre nous
espérons que le pacte asile
d'immigration aboutira avant la chéance
de 2024 juin il ne suffira pas enfin car
en matière d'éloignement ce n'est pas
seulement notre arsenal juridique qui
manque d'efficience mais bien notre
capacité réelle à éloigner les
intéressés nous n'avons donc qu'une
seule option crédible agir sur les pays
sources en conditionnant l'attribution
de l'aide au développement à la
coopération en matière de réadmission et
en limitant drastiquement le taux et la
durée de délivrance des visas nous ne
pouvons continuer à financer massivement
des projets structurants dans ces pays
sans exiger une coopération efficace en
matière de de réadmission mon le
ministre est-il véritablement possible
de consiller cette politique
d'attractivité internationale menée par
la France avec une politique de
réduction rationnelle de nos flux
migratoires je vous remercie monsieur
Benjamin Luca pour le groupe
écologiste merci monsieur le ministre le
passage à la caisse du supermarché est
un véritable calvaire pour le
porte-monnaie de nos concitoyens N
enseignants son sont à bout et les
inégalités scolaires demeurent parmi les
plus élevés de l'OCDE 3 millions
d'enfants ne partent jamais en vacances
des milliers de gens crèvent de froid
dans la rue dans des passoirs thermiques
l'ONU nous alerte sur l'accélération du
Grand réchauffement bien réel celui-ci
la France est régulièrement condamnée
pour ses régressions en matière de
liberté ou de droits humains mais vous
vous paralysez le débat public déjà
suffisamment englouti sous les thèmes et
les termes de l'extrême- droite avec une
question comment durcir encore les
condition
d'accès et d'accueil dans notre pays
quel cadeau fait à Marine Le Pen peu
importe si vous savez au fond que vous
ne pouvez rien faire en réalité contre
un phénomène humain la migration qui
existait avant vous et qui existera
après vous ne pouvez et vous ne pourrez
rien plus que vos 29 prédécesseurs qui
ont produit 29 lois sur le sujet en 40
ans ces 29 lois monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur et la 30e ne fera pas
exception n'auront eu que deux effets
plus d'argent dans la poche des passeurs
qui indexent directement leurs tarifs
sur les difficultés à passer nos
frontières et plus de cadavres qui
flottent en mer de Méditerranée ou qui
gèl dans les
Alpes peu importe pour vous si la
majorité des migrations se fonte entre
pays du Sud anéantissant le grand délire
de submersion migratoire peu importe
pour vous si aucune étude statistique
aucune réalité historique aucun fait ne
vient accréditer l'hypothèse de
potentiel appel d'air avec des
politiques plus inclusives
peu importe pour vous si la part des
étrangers en France est globalement
stable dans notre pays depuis des années
peu importe pour vous si des milliers de
gens honnêt vivent travaillent aiment
enrichissent notre pays chaque jour sans
papier ne parlez pas de votre article 3
préalable mieux que rien mais presque
rien peu importe pour vous les valeurs
qui font de la République et sa devise
qui consacre la fraternité peu importe
pour vous notre histoire faite de
transformation et de migration peu
importe pour vous si avec ce texte vous
abîmez l'image de la France dans le
monde son rayonnement avec un signal de
repli et de rabourrissement peu importe
pour vous si les étudiants étrangers
repartent quasi tous dans leurs pays
d'origine après leurs études et n'ont
rien à faire dans les statistique de
l'immigration peu importe pour vous si
la vraie urgence c'est de mettre des
moyens sur l'inclusion sur l'hébergement
sur la protection des mineurs pour
garantir la dignité de toutes et de tous
peu importe pour vous tout cela vous
voulez votre loi à tel point que vous
sacrifiez votre promesse d'équilibre
malant point dès le texte initial à
toutes les compromissions avec la droite
radicalisée donnant votre blancin pour
faire entrer par pansentier le programme
de Marine Le Pen et de son père dans la
loi on l'a vu avec l'avis de la
malnommée sagesse donnée par le
gouvernement sur la suppression de
l'aide médicale d'État monsieur le
ministre de
l'Intérieur vous pouvez encore je le
crois éteindre l'incendie que vous avez
vous-même allumé puisque vous nous
promtiez il y a plus d'un an ce texte a
connu un parcours chaotique vous nous
premietiez deux choses un équilibre et
une majorité l'équilibre il n'est
misiblement pas au rendez-vous j'entends
ici les paroles des uns et des autres et
la majorité vous ne l'avez pas vous
n'avez pas à tel point que vous avez été
obligé de vous rallier sur bien des
aspects je le dis opposition la droite
radicalisée au Sénat et que vous serez
obligé comp tenu de cette absence de
majorité d'entamer avec elle ici un
marchandage mortifère sur le dos de
l'État de droit sur le dos de droit des
exilés et sur le dos de nos principes
les plus fondamentaux vous pouvez encore
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
apaiser notre pays suspendre cette folle
surenchère vers laabî en suspendant
l'examen de ce texte et en nous
permettant de retrouver des vrais débats
sur les vraies préoccupations des
Françaises et des Français pour leur
pouvoir d'achat pour la dignité pour
l'inclusion et pour l'intégration voilà
ce que sera la boussole des écologistes
dans ce débat monsieur le ministre pour
faire autre chose des exiler que des
menaces ou des variables d'ajustements
économiquesci madame ela fustillon pour
le groupe gauche démocrate
républicaineà merci Monsieur le le
président monsieur le ministre je veux
commencer par dire combien les débats au
Sénat les mots choisis pour parler des
personnes exilées marquent ou peut-être
d'ailleurs confirment un basculement de
très nombreuses propositions tournent le
dos tout bonnement à toute volonté
d'intégration dans notre pays de
personnes étrangère
elle se rapproche finalement du principe
de de préférence nationale et je crois
qu'elles ne font pas que flirter avec de
grands ponifs racistes elles illustrent
en fait assez bien les propos que je
trouve très inquiétant euh de Pierre
brochan euh qui expliquait il y a peu
que nous sommes ligotés par notre État
de droit je pense profondément le
contraire et je crois que le laisser
faire du gouvernement au cours de ces
débats au Sénat est particulièrement
coupable coupable de légitimer une
vision euh suspecte de l'étranger alors
cette loi tout ça n'a rien d'étonnant
finalement puisque vous avez offert la
possibilité tous ces potentiels le
boulevard dans un contexte politique
hystérisé par le mythe de l'appel d'air
et celui du Grand remplacement pourtant
je le rappelle d'autres l'ont fait la
France n'est pas le plus grand pays de
l'immigration en Europe loin de là la
France n'est pas non plus le pays qui
accueille le plus de réfugiés en Europe
et à l'échelle européenne la France n'a
jamais accueilli les grands vague de de
réfugiés au prorat de sa population ou
même de sa richesse alors sous couvert
de lutte contre ce chimérique appel
d'air ce sont les droits des personnes
qui sont bafouées cette réforme accélère
ou cherche à accélérer certes les
procédures d'examen des demandes d'asile
mais elle le fait au détriment de leurs
droits elle accentue la mise sous
contrôle des demandeurs d'asile facilite
les expulsions durcit les conditions
d'accès au titre de séjour affaiblit les
droits et garantit des personnes
étrangère c'est également un projet de
loi qui s'inscrit dans un récit de
Racine xénophobe qui cherche à créer un
trait d'union Abe entre immigration et
délinquence un discours relayé
volontiers par vous monsieur le ministre
en usant d'un vocable maniquéen
définissant qui sont les gentils et qui
sont les méchants je vais vous dire
heureusement que de merveilleux auteurs
jeunesse comme Tony hungerur sont passés
par là pour expliquer à nos enfants que
le monde est un tout petit peu plus
compliqué que celui-là un discours
véhiculé par vous tantôt par des tweets
quotidiens tantôt par des circulairesant
invitant à multiplier les octtf tout en
sachant qu'elles ne sont pas possibles
dans bien des cas et les placements en
rétention pour les auteurs de la notion
très large et arbitraire de trouble à
l'ordre public le volet méchant est donc
bien présent avec une véritable
criminalisation des migrants et au
passage des assauts de solidarité et
cela au mépris de nos engagements
conventionnels nous notons en revanche
les très lourds manques de ce projet de
loi je pense notamment et bien à la
question de l'hébergement tout de suite
de l'accueil inconditionnel en réalité
je rejoins les propos d'un d'un collègue
précédent la question ici n'est pas le
laxisme ou la fermeté mais le désordre
créé par les politiques migratoires que
vous mettez en œuvre personne n'est
satisfait du fait et bien qu'il y ait
des personnes exilées qui se retrouvent
à la à la rue dans décampement d'abord
eux évidemment ne peuvent accepter mais
nous non plus nous ne pouvons l'accepter
et les citoyens qui vivent autour non
plus mais la seule réponse possible
évidemment c'est de permettre d'abord et
bien qu'ils soient hébergés qu'ils
puissent travailler et que les enfants
soient scolarisés en fait l'accueil est
bon pour notre cohésion sociale il est
bon pour le respect des droits mais il
est bon pour notre cohésion sociale la
régularisation des des travailleurs sans
papier dans le texte aujourd'hui mais
visiblement aussi a été réduit en
première version de texte à une approche
utilitariste limitée au seul métier en
tenstion nous combattrons évidemment
cette idée en défendant une
régularisation de toutes et tous par le
travail merci Monsieur Christophe nagen
pour le groupe liberté indépendant
outreemire et
territoire merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues
nous allons pendant ce mois qui arrive
avoir l'occasion d'échanger sur ce
qu'est notre immigration notre façon
d'intégrer et sur ce qu'elle devrait
être si on regarde dans le détail
la partie législative qui nous est
propre n'est pas majoritaire dans le cza
si on prend en compte la partie
réglementaire et la partie européenne
nos moyens sont donc limités faut avoir
l'honnêteté de le reconnaître nous
devons être lucide aussi quant au
principe de réalité qui s'impose
pragmatisme et équilibre cela doit nous
guider tout au long de l'étude de ce
texte sur l'article 1 par exemple est-ce
sa place dans ce texte et si oui la mu
ne risque-t-elle pas de continuer à
aggraver la surcharge dans nos hôpitaux
et dans leur services d'urgence cette
question est réelle nous devons nous la
poser comme nous devons aussi nous poser
le besoin de revoir le panier de soins
qui peut interpeller nos concitoyens sur
sa largesse il en va de même pour
l'article 3 d'un côté il faut des
critères stricts qui ne laissent aucun
doute sur le but d'une intégration par
le travail en cohérence avec les besoins
des territoires et de ces entreprises il
faut aussi des critères clairs qui ne
servent pas de pompe d'aspiration mais
il serait incohérent d'occulter la
réalité de la main d'œuvre étrangère en
France il faut donc trouver une foie de
passage sur les métiers en tenstion qui
est réelle et qui est une réelle demande
de nos entreprises dans une grande
majorité voire dans la totalité de nos
territoires ce serait une aberration
d'occulter cette demande économique
omique par contre concernant certaines
de ces entreprises il faut aussi penser
à des sanctions fortes pour celles qui
profite de ce système et qui exploite
des situations qui sont
difficiles un réel besoin aussi de
réforme
administratif on doit repenser notre
façon de faire non seulement pour
réussir à minimiser au maximum les
délais mais aussi pour être plus
efficace et pour ça un seul seulement un
investissement massif dans nos services
est nécessaires et si on reprend un
rapport qui a eu lieu qui a été rendu
récemment on voit bien que c'est dans
nos préfectures qu'on a et dans ce
service étranger qu'il y a eu énormément
de moyens qui ont été supprimés ça
interroge et ça montre surtout qu'on a
besoin de plus réinvestir dans ces
services au sein de au sein de nos
préfectures et on a aussi besoin de
beaucoup plus
départementaliser les services en lien
avec l'immigration on parlera notamment
de l'OFI de la CNVA et autres on a
besoin d'une territorialisation et sans
doute d'une d'une départementalisation
qui aiderait énormément à résoudre un
certain nombre de de problèmes enfin une
mesure essentielle l'éloignement des
étrangers menaçant l'ordre public elle
doit être plus rigoureuse plus rapide
exigeante et ne souffrir d'aucune
faiblesse sur des obstacles que nous
aurions nous-mêm créé bref ce texte doit
amener ce que les 29 autres n'ont pas
fait sans doute moins d'accueil mais
pour une meilleure
intégration afin de répondre au réel
difficultés de notre temps présent et
futur et enfin pour les non inscrits et
pour une duré de 2 minutes
madameemuard
merci monsieur le Président
l'augmentation rapide du nombre
d'étrangers en France participe à
l'embolie de beaucoup de nos services
publics cette citation n'est pas de moi
mais d'un ancien Premier ministre
Édouard Philippe comme quoi quitter
l'exercice du pouvoir permet apparemment
d'ouvrir les yeux sur la réalité la
politique d'immigration de la France est
un échec plus de 320000 titres délivrés
en 2022 contre 277000 titres en 2019 et
une immigration clandestine que nous
n'arrivons toujours pas à maîtriser sans
même parler de la jugulée ce n'est
malheureusement pas nouveau mais
monsieur Macron n'a rien solutionné
victime de son en même temps permanent
il explique à la fois qu'il veut être
ferme sur les expulsions mais en même
temps qu'il faut encourager
l'installation d'im d'immigrés dans les
campagnes il dénonce une politique
absurde à la fois inefficace et
inhumaine mais il oublie que c'est sa
propre majorité qui a élargi la
réunification familiale aux frères et
sœurs de réfugiés et que le regroupement
familial a grimpé d'environ 18 % en 2021
après avoir augmenté en 2000 20 de 28 %
pour autant je refuse le fatalisme en
matière d'immigration une grande
diversité de solutions existe chez nos
voisins européens Royaume-Uni Allemagne
ou Danemark dont nous pourrions nous
inspirer à condition d'y mettre le prix
des bonnes pratiques des nué d'idéologie
dans le cadre d'une réelle vision
stratégique éviter les appels d'air
renforcer l'assimilation renforcer les
conditions d'acquisition de la
nationalité française être ferme avec
les délinquants étrangers et cetera j'y
ajouterai quelques mesures toutes
simples comme la suppression du droit du
sol refuser automatiquement d'accorder
l'asile à une personne faisant l'objet
d'une OQTF faire en sorte que le droit
d'asile ne soit pas tous les jours
détourneré avec l'aide d'association qui
joue contre notre pays mais aussi contre
ceux qu'elle prétendent défendre ou
encore refuser de marier un clandestin
lorsqu'il fait l'objet d'une TF par
exemple monsieur le ministre j'espère
simplement mais sincèrement que le petit
jeu parlementaire du détricotage ne
donnera pas une fois encore une image
catastrophique de notre pays car je suis
sûr d'une seule chose les Français nous
nous attendre sur des mesures efficaces
et de bon sens afin de redonner le droit
à la France d'accueillir sur son sol qui
elle veut je vous monsieur le ministre
vous avez la parole pour la réponse aux
orateurs des groupes merci monsieur le
Président peut-être dire d'abord au
rapporteur au sens très large du terme
que je les remercie de leurs
observations et et de leur
positionnement je pense que ce qu'il
évoque est dans l'esprit du texte de loi
à la fois déposé par le Gouvernement
mais aussi modifié par le Sénat et que
je souscris à la plupart de leur
remarques dire à à Olivier serva
évidemment je je suis favorable il le
sait aux articles définis pour les
outremèes article par article territoire
par territoire c'est vrai que ce sera
original pour le texte de loi mais qui
permettra à chacun des territoires
ultramarins de se sentir respecté et
effectivement il y a pas la même
difficulté à Mayotte qu'il y en a en
Guyane qu'il y en a à Saint-Pierre et
miclon ce serait absurde de faire un un
titre ultramarin et d'englober tout ça
avec des dispositions générales et
encore pire peut-être insultant les
renvoyer à une ordonnance je voudrais
d'ailleurs dire que vous le savez la
nouvelle quédonie et la poliie française
ne sont pas concernés renvoie par
ordonnance parce qu'ils le souhait et
parce que par ailleurs l'application du
droit n'est pas la même la même la même
chose que les les régimes des
territoires qui sont gouvernés par
article 73 de la Constitution donc
monsieur serva faisons ensemble article
par article si les territoires le
souhaitent des consultations et des
dispositions particulières qui
s'adaptent aux difficultés de chacun de
de de ces territoires alors peut-être
plusieurs questions ont été évoquées je
constate cependant que s'il y a beaucoup
de critiqu contre le texte de loi pas
pas pas tous évidemment je remercie les
groupes de la majorité et notamment et
le groupe pilote de de le soutenir
évidemment des modules au prè que je
suis parfaitement prêt à entendre il y y
a pas beaucoup de propositions dans la
part de ceux qui ont montré ont montré
non je je je m'inquiète pas je je le
constate voilà c'est c'est c'est un peu
c'est un peu dommage parce que je je
crains aussi que ce qui sera intéressant
ce qui sera intéressant c'est de parler
du texte de loi tel qu'il existe et pas
tel qu'il est commenté parce que j'y
retrouve pas toujours les les les les
articles de loi il compris d'ailleurs
modifiés par par le Sénat et et donc je
pense qu'il serait bien me semble-t-il
que nous discutions du projet de loi tel
qu'il existe et pas celui qui eu été
inventé par exle je sais pas vous avez
été voir la la rétention à 18 mois il
pas elle est pas dans le pas dans le
texte par exemple mais sans doute euh
est-ce plus simple quand on discutera
amendement par amendement article par
article il y aura peut-être moins moins
de suivi médiatique sans doute était
pour ça qu'il y avait des propos
peut-être très généraux et qui ne
correspondaient pas au texte de que j'ai
proposé dire au rassemblement
national dire au rassemblement national
que le sujet n'est pas l'immigration
régulière dans ce texte de loi c'est
évidemment l'immigration irrégulière et
sauf à être contre l'immigration tout
court mais je n'ai pas compris ça de vos
propos y compris celle de votre
candidate éction présidentielle il vaut
mieux une immigration régulière qu'une
immigration irrégulière et que dans
l'immigration régulière il doit y avoir
un débat pour savoir ce qu'on souhaite
comme immigration régulière mais c'est
le débat de tous les pays au monde de
tous les pays au monde euh et soit on
fonctionne par Quota soit on fonctionne
par objectif soit on fonctionne par
métier on peut fonctionner évidemment
par zone géographique après il y a des
choix qui sont faits par les grands pays
démocratiques mais il y a toujours une
immigration régulière donc ce que nous
combattons c'est immigration IR
régulière évoquer le nombre de titre de
séjour que nous donnons pardon n'a pas
beaucoup de sens ce qui est intéressant
c'est est-ce qu'on est capable de lutter
contre l'migration irrégulière par
ailleurs vous faites semblant de voir
que vos dispositions n'empêcheront en
aucun cas euh les demandes as puisque
aucune disposition d'ailleurs ni dans
votre programme puisque vous en faites
référence ni dans celle des voisins
européens qui sont inspirés parfois par
votre politique démontre leur efficacité
et et je voudrais dire en quelques mots
parce que ce qui est intéressant dans
cette histoire migratoire c'est notre
comparaison avec d'autres pays européens
qui on à peu près les mêmes difficultés
que nous voilà d'abord c'est tout à fait
faux de dire que nous avons le pays où a
meilleur taux de protection vous l'avez
dit c'est une contrevérité flagrante en
France c'est 40 % le taux de protection
après CNDA c'estàdire que nous on est
grosso modo à 25 % à l'OFPRA et par des
mesures de justice administrative que ce
soit les les premières instances ou les
appels à 40 % de protection des
personnes qui demandent l'asile en
Allemagne c'est 46 % et en Italie je
crois que chez vos amis ils sont à 62 %.
donc vous voyez nous sommes le pays dans
les trois grands pays qui nous
accompagnent nous avons le moins de taux
de protection donné à demandeurs d'asile
en France c'est là où on a le moins de
chance de l'obtenir et pourtant nous
avons à peu près les même demandeur
d'asile donc je pense que c'est déjà
assez difficile monsieur le député pour
ne pas dire des idiocies qui sont des
contrevérités flagrantes parce que là
dans ces cas-là on va pas s'entendre y
compris sur le constat et ce qui est
inquiétant dans votre sujet c'est que on
a l'occasion d'en reparler on ne donne
aucunement la possibilité de trouver des
solutions sauf celle que nous procédons
c'est-à-dire une simplification
drastique des procédures parce que je
regarde ce qui se passe en Italie je
regarde ce qui se passe en
Grande-Bretagne prenons l'exemple de la
Grande-Bretagne c'est très intéressant
la Grande-Bretagne monsieur Johnson a
été élu sur grosso modo votre programme
politique qui consiste à faire le frxit
bon donc vous êtes pour la sortie de
l'Union européenne la sortie des traités
européens et même même même j'entends
dire la sortie de la CEDH donc peut-être
que il y a un débat il y a peut-être un
débat désormais mais bon c'est pas grave
mais on voilà donc la Grande-Bretagne la
Grande-Bretagne est sortie la
Grande-Bretagne est sortie des traités
européens qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il
n'y a jamais eu autant d'immigration
irrégulière en Grande-Bretagne jamais eu
autant bon deuxièmement il n a jamais eu
autant de peu d'expulsion du territoire
britannique 5000 entrées 5000 sorties
pardon sur 1 million d'étrangers il y a
5000 expulsions 5000 expulsions du
territoire britannique par an nous quand
on est nous à 20000 22000 alors qu'on a
à peu près deux fois moins d'immigration
irrégulière chacun convient et regardez
la Cour suprême britannique qui a
retrouvé dit-il dis-il les Anglais leur
souveraineté la Cour suprême britannique
vient de dire au gouvernement de
Monsieur sunac le pauvre qui désormais à
l'héritage de Monsieur Johnson que non
seulement cette histoire de Rwanda ne
tenez pas debout puisque personne n'a
jamais envoyé un réfugié au Rwanda ni le
Danemark ni la Grande-Bretagne je pense
qu'on pourrait se le dire c'est une
disposition qui est imaginé personne n'a
jamais mis en place la Cour suprême
britannique dit non seulement que cela
était contraire aux engagements
internationaux de la Grande-Bretagne et
que par ailleurs même s'ils étaient
sortis de la CEDH dit la Cour suprême il
ne pourrait pas appliquer cette
règlementation c'estàd qu'il faudrait
pas sortir de la C l'OPE faut sortir du
monde monsieur le député pour appliquer
votre programme et c'est très difficile
de sortir du monde puisque la Cour
suprême britannique évoque le fait que
quoi qu'il arrive vous faites de la
poute de perlin Pimpin parce que vous
savez très bien que c'est compliqué
alors il y a une deuxième solution c'est
Madame mélonie alors c'est vrai que
Madame Méloni c'était intéressant blocus
naval on l'a pas vu arriver et fin
d'immigration régulière par un projet de
loi immigration il y a jamais eu autant
vous l'avez vu d'immigration irrégulière
depuis 5 ans en en Italie à tel point
que Madame mélonie et raisonnablement
elle a appelé à secours la Commission
européenne et notamment madame Verlen
qui pour rigoler mais c'est vrai c'est
ce que vous dites au français et que ce
soit l'anglais l'image anglaise ou
l'image italienne c'est c'est un échec
parce que c'est évidemment une question
très difficile que celle de
l'immigration quand on regarde nos
voisins qui ne réussissent pas mieux que
nous et parfois font bien pire que nous
et à la fin elle appelle madame mélonie
Madame Van derlayen qui vient à
Lampedusa et elle vote madame mélonie et
je je suis le premier concerné pour être
le ministre qui représente la France
depuis 3 ans et demi maintenant dans les
Conseils des ministres de l'Intérieur
européens sur la proposition française
elle adopte notre Pact migratoire sur
Eurodac sur le règlement screening donc
je pense qu'il faut regarder les choses
maintenant avec attention nous avons des
comparaisons nous savons ce qu'est
l'application du programme du
rassemblement national à l'étranger
c'est des mensonges vis-à-vis des
Français alors beaucoup de difficultés
pour ceux qui l'évoquent je suis très
preneur évidemment de vos de vos
contre-exemples dans quel pays là
l'arrivée de populistes comme vous ont
donné des résultats pour la population
la protection d'immigration aucun vous
n'êtes capable de me citer aucun pays
monsieur le députés alors que nous avons
deux qui malheureusement ont essayé
d'appliquer une partie de vos pr de vos
présupposés et c'est un échec assez
assez flagrant vous pourriez au moins
vous en rendre compte et peut-être
essayer de constater que le texte vous
n'en avez pas parlé mais j'espère qu'on
en parlera dans le débat qu'il s'agit de
la lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière qui s'agisse de la
pénalisation effectivement des des des
passeurs qu' s'agisse de la
simplification administrative pourrait
au moins trouver grâce pour dire ça au
moins ça peut permettre d'avancer je con
ça d'ailleurs qu'il a un petit décalage
entre ce qu'a dit votre présidente votre
candidate au présidente de groupe et est
ce que vous dites désormais on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler peut-être
dire également à à Madame madame Martin
que j'ai entendu l'argument plusieurs
fois et je l'entends répéter mais c'est
pas parce que c'est répété que c'est
vrai vous dites a 29 textes depuis 1983
bon très bien la belle affaire c'est
vrai que je dis pour ceux qui ont
participai monsieur Solignac monsieur
Lucas des majorités qui appartenaient au
gouvernement de Monsieur Hollande il y a
eu trois textes d'immigration en 4 ans
sur Monsieur Hollande ça c'est c'est
tout à fait vrai il y en a eu qu'un seul
en 6 ans de la part du président de la
République voilà je sais pas combien
vous avez de disposition pour évoquer
non mais il y a eu un seul texte en 6
ans il y a eu texte en 6 ans il y en a
eu qure il y en a eu trois en 4 ans sous
Monsieur Hollande donc si vous faites
une critique c'est celle de la gauche
voilà donc je je vous en remercie
Monsieur Lucas mais vous n'avez pas
précisé que c'était notamment était
présent du MGS monsieur Lucas je savais
pas je suis moins spécialiste que vous
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois euh peut merci merci monsieur
le Président donc pourquoi et je n'en
fais pas grillef à Monsieur Holland euh
pourquoi parce que il faut adapter mais
parce qu'il faut adapter notre
législation à par définition le
mouvement des hommes et les difficultés
on compare les choses il y a 15 ou il y
a 20 ans mais il y a 15 ou il y a 20 ans
par exemple les minurs qui étaient à ma
place bah ils avaient des relations
diplomatiques avec le Sahel avec le Mali
avec la Libye avec l'Irak avec
l'Afghanistan c'est pas du tout le cas
aujourd'hui les réfugiés climatiques
c'est quelque chose d'assez nouveau ça
fait 5 ans qu'il y a entre 25 et 30
millions de personnes qui sont déplacé
euh dans le monde 60000 personnes par
jour c'était pas le cas il y a 20 ans
euh la question de la pénalisation de
l'orientation sexuelle notamment la
question d'étrangeor bah c'est une
question qui était qui est extrêmement
nouvelle en tout cas pour les
gouvernants depuis euh quelques années
et pas il y a 25 ou il y a 30 ans et
quand il y a des actes terroristes quand
il y a daesh quand il y a l'état
islamique quand il y a des difficultés
extrêmement fortes bah c'est normal que
le président Hollande propose des
dispositions donc ne faisons pas ne
donons pas des arguments populistes non
plus je je dis au parti dit au
gouvernement vous avez fait trois loin
en 4 ans donc laissez-nous pour une fois
une loi en en un quinquena monsieur
colon en a fait une en 2018 il y a des
avantages des inconvénients à la loi
colon il y a des avantages certains on
est passé de 1 an à 5 mois pour l'étude
de de demandeur d'asile on a changé la
vie de de min de dizaines de milliers de
personnes voilà alors après moi je veux
bien les comparaisons mais monsieur
Lucas si vraiment on était aussi dur
pourquoi le gouvernement vert et
socialiste en Allemagne prend des
dispositions parfois bien plus dures que
les nôtres le gouvernement vert je sais
pas si vous avez vu ce qui se passe en
Allemagne mais mais regardez ce qui se
passe à côté de chez nous vous avez vu
les les dispositions annoncées par le
gouvernement allemand alors si vous
dites que je vous je parais trop dur
faut vraiment exclure rapidement de la
l'Internationale verte vos vos collègues
vert vousmême vous en riez parce que
parce qu'évidemment c'était j'imagine
c'était
j'imagine un argument de tribune auquel
vous ne croyez vous-même même pas bon
euh pour Monsieur soignac et même
monsieur Lucas bon j'entends j'entends
ce que vous dites alors vous arrivez à
faire 4 et 4 8 minutes je parle pas de
la France insoumise ou du Parti
communiste je parle vraiment là pour le
coup de de partis qui me semble-t-il
étit sont des partis de gouvernement je
je veux y croire sans désigner à seul
instant les progrès sociaux les progrès
que ce texte apporte et que vous vous
avez pendant 50 ans réclamé dans
l'opposition sans jamais l'avoir fait
dans la majorité la suppression des
présen des mineurs dans les centres de
rétention administratif ça fait 50 ans
que tout le monde le réclame non non
mais vous n'avez pas parlé monsieur ch
mais laissez-moi vous dire parce que
laissez-moi vous dire c'est quoi une
belle idée de gauche ça permettrait
monsieur vous avez préféré capturer le
propos sans doute parce que ça vous
servait mais il il y aura plus de
mineurs dans les centres de rétention
administratif demander demander demander
par le Défenseur des droits demander par
le Défenseur des enfants demand demandé
par la CEDH demandé par l'ensemble des
associations c'est nous qui le faisons
vous n'avez pas un mot pour dire il n'y
aura plus de mineur dans les centres de
rétention il y a voilà c'est quand même
incroyable les cours gratuits les cours
gratuit les cours gratuits pour les
étrangers les cours gratuits pour les
étrangers nous le faisons
pardon monsieur car n'avez pas la parole
vous l'urez tout à l'heure pour 2
minutes monsieur le ministsie minist
passé au Sénat j'ai don un avis
favorable au groupe socialiste lorsqu
qu'ils ont voulu mettre 18 ans le Sénat
a pas voulu je dis ici que je don un
avis favorable 18
pas un mot pour le dire vous n'avez pas
osé le dire parce que en fait ce qui
vous intéresse c'est évidemment de
camper dans des positions idéologiques
vous n'osez pas dire que c'est nous
c'est le gouvernement du président de la
République c'est cette majorité qui
mettra plus de mineurs dans les centres
de rétention administratif et on devrait
tous s'en satisfaire et on devrait tous
se dire je constate que le gouvernement
socialiste ne l'a jamais fait ne l'a
jamais fait ni monsieur Jospin ni ni
Monsieur Hollande personne ne l'a
monsieur miteran ne l'a fait nous le
faisons les cours gratuits pour les
étrangers les cours gratuits pour les
étrangers bon ben voilà c'est formidable
les cours pour les étrangers nous
le faisons ça a été réclamé par toutes
les associations à tout moment c'est
nous qui le faisons le fait que pendant
les heures de travail payé par
l'employeur on apprennent le français
c'est un magnifique progrès social ça
évite que la femme de ménage qui fait
1h30 de RER pour venir travailler à 4h
du matin 1h30 pour repartir n'aille pas
à 15h reprendre des cours parce qu'elle
s'occupe de ses enfants de sa famille
tout simplement de sa vie qu'elle
qu'elle a des difficultés extrêmement
forte à suivre ces cours le titre de
séjour et qui est quand même une idée
formidableonstruction avec le groupe
communiste du Sénat qui a pas
manifestement la même position que
Madame fossillon mais c'est c'est un
autre sujet entre communiste et je
laisserai évidemment cela dans vos dans
vos débats c'est extraordinaire de dire
on va pouir donner un titre de séjour à
quelqu'un qui est exploité voilà c'est
me semble-t-il extrêmement cohérent mais
ça fait rire personne parce que vous
vous manifestement vous avez une vision
très théorique de la vision de de
l'immigration et l'exploitation des
personnes en l'occurrence parce que vous
n'osez pas dire qu'il y a des progrès
importants alors que tout ne vous
satisfasse pas moi je le comprends bien
c'est pas la loi et les filles c'est pas
la loi du Parti communiste ça c'est
certain et et je je je mesure la
différence àissal qu'il y a entre nous
sur certains points mais vous pourriez
au moins dire que sur certain
dispositions ce texte n'est pas avoué à
hégémonie alors madame madame jeev j'ai
entendu vos votre propos je me permets
de de vous dire que qui peut le plus
peut le
moins j'entends le débat sur la question
constitutionnelle et conventionnelle je
crois que dans le cas britannique la
démonstration est faite que évidemment
même en sortant des traités européens
même en sortant euh c'est pas ce que
vous dites exactement mais on pourrait
on en parlera lors de la PPL
constitutionnelle évidemment même en
sortant ou en écrasant les règles de la
de la CEDH il y a des dispositions qui
s'imposeront et il y aura toujours des
juges ça c'est je je vous l'accorde il y
aura toujours des juges qui jugeront et
qui me donneront un avis évidemment y
compris au nom de principe qui créeront
eux-mêmes bon donc je sais que vous ne
souhaitez pasevenir sur la séparation
des des pouvoirs donc la question est de
savoir qu'est-ce qu'on peut évidemment
faire dans notre Constitution la
convention européne des droits de
l'homme qui peut nous permettre
d'adapter parce qu'après tout tout est
est discutable vu que tout ça est
évolutif d'adapter les choses ça c'est
un débat constitutionnel nous pensons
nous que nous pouvons largement
améliorer les choses avec la loi
ordinaire sans renier no principes et
sans surtout tourner le dos à l'Europe
parce que en faisant ça on tourne un peu
le dos quand même aux engagements
européens à tous les traités européens
qui ont été poussés par tous les
présidents de la République qui
appartiennent à votre famille politique
du général de Gaulle jusqu'à Nicolas
Sarkozy une fois qu'on a dit ça
euh M à part le débat est oui mais le
nôtre je dis bien volontiers bien sûr
évidemment une fois qu'on a écarté cette
idée constitutionnel et Connel parce
qu'on aura ce débat à un moment donné il
y a tout ce qu'on peut faire qui ne
relève pas de la Constitution relève pas
de la CEDH qui relève de de de notre de
notre pouvoir français souverain et du
pouvoir du législateur est-ce que vous
êtes pour ou contre le fait d'imposer
comme dans tous les pays européens sauf
deux un examen de français pour un titre
de séjour long ça c'est pas la CEDH
c'est pas la Constitution c'est quelque
chose très concret est-ce qu'on est
d'accord pour dire il faut un examen de
français pour un tire de séjour plannuel
ça pas besoin encore une fois de réforme
constitutionnelle est-ce que vous êtes
pour ou contre que nous augmentions le
temps d'assignation à résidence pour les
personnes qui sont dangereuses c'est ce
que prévoit le texte ça c'est pas la cdH
c'est pas la la la la Constitution
est-ce que pour ou contre la coerciss
pour qu'on prenne les empreintes des
étrangers pour savoir s'ils sont mineurs
ou majeurs et pour connaître leur
identité ça c'est c'est il y a que il y
a plus que la France on est plus que
deux pays aussi à ne pu le faire ça
c'est pas la Constitution c'est pas la
convention européne des droit de l'homme
est-ce qu'on est pour ou contre de
criminaliser les passeurs
puisqueaujourd'hui c'est un délit
partout ailleurs c'est un crime sauf
chez nous est-ce qu'on est pour ou
contre le retour du du retrait pardon du
titre de séjour pour adhésion à idologie
radicale j'entends dire que vous êtes
pour qu'on retire les titres de séjour
qu'on expulse les salafistes ou les
Frères musulmans par exemple du
territoire national il y a pas de
disposition qui existe ca nous vous le
proposons très clairement des gens qui
sont dans la radicalisation on puisse
les expulser du territoire national
est-ce que vous êtes pour ou contre la
simplification des procédures proposé
par Monsieur buffet lui-même nous
reprenons inextince le rapport de
Monsieur buffet ça c'est pas la
Constitution c'est pas la Convention
européenne des droits de l'homme est-ce
que vous êtes pour ou contre qu'on
supprime les dispositions qui
aujourd'hui empêcheent M inur d'expulser
des étrangers délinquants parce que par
exemple ils sont arrivés avant l'âge de
13 ans sur le territoire national il y a
que la France qu' a ça il y a que la
France et vous savez tous que ça a été
fait au début des années 2000 et c'est
pas de réforme constitutionnelle c'est
pas de réforme constitionnelle le
Conseil d'État expressist verbis dit
dans son arrêt dans son avis pardon que
c'est expressément pas constitutionnel
et expressément pas conventionnel que
avoir ses réserves et que bien sûr
législateur a le droit de revenir sur
les dispositions est-ce qu'on est pour
ou contre une application du droit
particulier à maotte ou en Guyane comme
l'a fait voter des sénateurs Maoris ou
les sénateurs guyanis dans la
hautechambre donc il y a des choses
madame jeunevard sur lesquelles on aura
peut-être des désaccords
incontestablement je reviens pas sur les
dispositions que vous AZ évoqué au début
parce que je crois que le président de
la commission des lois mais vous n'étiez
pas arrivé a évoqué le principe
d'irreevabilité on pourra toujours en
discuter à l'envie mais sur le texte de
loi en tant que tel il y a des choses
qui ne relèvent pas d'une réforme
constitutionnelle ce serait une drôle
d'excuse et serait ce serait surtout
l'idée qu'on n pas envie d'avancer que
de ne pas donner à nos policiers les
moyens par exemple aussi bêtement qu'à
la frontière italienne de regarder ce
qui se passe dans les véhicules de moins
de 9 places aujourd'hui les policiers
peuvent pas dans la bande de 20 km
arrêter des passeur avec des moteurs de
de bateau entre le nord et le et la
Belgique quand on va traverser la Manche
est-ce qu'on a besoin de la réforme
constitutionnelle donc il y a des débats
de nature européen et constitutionnel
que je ne veux pas trancher ici ils
trancheront le moment venu bien
évidemment il peut y avoir des
désaccords je comprends bien mais toutes
ces dispositions je je ne je j'ai du mal
à comprendre pourquoi il faut changer
absolument la constitution ou la
convention européne des droits de
l'homme pour les adopter pour des choses
aussi bêtes que chou parfois mais qui
empêche très concrètement nos policiers
nos gendarmes nos préfets de faire leurs
travail et d'améliorer l'intégration
donc moi je fais le vœu en effet que
l'on puisse y réfléchir ensemble enfin
je terminerai pour dire que je suis très
favorable la disposition qui a été
évoqué et notamment par Monsieur
marcangelli sur le lien entre visa et
LPC il est évident qu'il faut aider le
gouvernement de la République à dire au
pays qui ne délivre pas de LPC qu'il ne
peut pas y avoir de visa sans que il y
ait une discussion diplomatique et
parfois une contrainte il y a eu des
dispositions qui ont été imaginées par
le Sénat mais je veux dire à la majorité
qu'elles étaient dans le comité
interministériel dès 2019 du le
président de la République a évoqué
lui-même de conditionnement je sais que
c'est une question difficile entre
l'aide au développement et certains pays
qui ne jouent pas le jeu des laisser
passer consulair ou qui sont des des des
gens qui persécutent pour des raisons
sexuel ou des raisons religieuses une
partie de leur population je pense que
c'est effectivement un débat qui est
compliqué qui est original mais mais qui
mériterait d'être mener et puis je
voudrais dire que l'argument qui est de
dire on est passé de 27 à 90 articles et
c'est le Sénat qui a fait les autres
articles c'est pas tout à fait vrai il y
a une vingtaine de création d'articles
du fait du gouvernement par 26
amendements que j'ai moi-même proposé
donc on peut dire au minimum qu'il y a
une coconstruction 50 50 ça peut
s'entendre avec effectivement beaucoup
d'abilité mais l'argument de on est
passé 27 à 90 grâce au Sénat il y a 26
am am qui ont été adopté par par le
Sénat qui ont créé autant d'articles
avec notamment des choses qui
intéressent tout le monde et qui sont
difficiles comme l'asile en rétention
c'est la première fois que nous
l'imaginerions la prolongation de la
durée maximale d'assignation résidence
je l'ai dit le raccourcissement des
délais entre déplacement de rétention ou
la réforme entière du JLD qui là aussi
n'est pas de valeur constitutionnelle
alors à la fin je terminerai par dire
qu'il est évident que c'est difficile de
gérer le ministère de l'Intérieur et de
mener une politique migratoire c'est
très très très difficile et et il est
évident qu'il y a des échecs bien sûr et
que moi ce que je viens demander au
Parlement c'est des moyens
supplémentaires pour être plus efficace
est-ce que ce texte comm monsieur Mar
règle tout non il règle pas tout bien
évidemment qu'il règle pas tout et il y
a bien sûr un équilibre à avoir et
chacun dans son groupe politique met
l'équilibre où il souhaite je veux
simplement vous dire que le ministre
d'intérieur que je suis et tous les
services qui sont sous mon autorité quel
que soitent les ministres essaie de
faire le maximum de ce qu'il peut avec
les moyens qu'il a puisqu'il respecte
les de la République mais je prends
l'exemple de monsieurquissen puisque ça
c'est quand même me semble-t-il très
intéressant
monsieurquissen il est il est depuis
plus de 50 ans sur le territoire de la
République il a quatre enfants nés en
France majeurs il est propriétaire il
s'est marié en France il est un imam
radical il n'a rien fait il n'a aucun
casier judiciaire sauf qu'il est un imam
radical nous le savons comme tel il les
fichess depuis des années et des années
et des années l'État se demande comment
se débarrasser de ce naséabon monsieur
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé l'état
heureusement pour la République vous
n'yavez jamais été à sa tête je dis pour
la France insoumise qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé il s'est passé que vous avez voté
une loi qui s'appelle grosso modo la loi
séparatisme et qui donne un principe
général
contre la la vie normale et la
radicalisation le passage à l'acte
terroriste il y a le séparatisme et nous
avons défini une disposition qui nous
permett de séparer des gens qui touchent
profondément le fonctionnement de notre
nation fort de cette loi j'ai fait
procéder par le préfet du Nord à
l'expulion de Monsieur cuissen dans des
conditions très difficiles à la fin des
fins il n'est plus sur le territoire
national et il a appliqué lui-même et
c'est une très bonne chose le fait qu'il
devait plus rester il ne peut plus
revenir sur le territoire national le
tribunal administratif m'a donné tort
c'est vrai parce qu'il était né en parce
que il avait quatre enfants en France
parce qu'effectivement il s'était marié
en France parce qu'effectivement mais à
la fin des fin le Conseil d'État me
donne raison et oui c'est ça d'être
ministre de inérieur et parfois avir les
mains dans le camboui et parfois on
réussit pas parfois on réussit et
parfois on va voir de on va voir le juge
on lui dit regardez cette personne est
dangereuse regardez cette personne est
mortifère regardez l'esprit du lichateur
et à la fin on me donne raison j'en tire
pas une GLOR particulière je dis juste
que il faut aller devant le juge et il
faut pouvoir le faire aujourd'hui sur
4000 cas de délinquants étrangers
Parents mesdames et messieurs les
députés 4000 cas par an je ne peux même
pas aller devant le juge pour demander
l'expulsion parce que vous m'autorisez
pas à y aller puisque vous avez voté une
loi il y a 20 ans qui m'empêche de le
faire à la fin bien sûr il y aura un
juge moi je suis pas tout-puissant je ne
suis pas ministre dictateur je suis si
on peut avoir un débat normal sans rire
et sans récaner de la part de la France
insommi je pense qu'on y gagnerait en
démocratie voilà c'est une chose
importante que de parler des hommes et
des femmes voilà et et pas de pas avoir
de discours humanistes à l'extérieur et
ne pas traiter sérieusement les
personnes ça serait une très bonne chose
et je pense qu'un débat digne ne serait
positif pour tout le monde puisque son
débat extrêmement sérieux qui parle à
l'intérêt général de l'État de la
sécurité défançais la sécurité des
personnes mais bien sûr que il y a 4000
personnes par an que je pourrais
expulser davantage si la loi me
l'autorisit voilà et moi je vais vous
dire sur les plus de 3000 demandes
d'expulsion que que j'ai demandé 2500
ont été expulsés en 202 3 ok la justice
et moi je la respecte profondément voilà
m'a refusé 500 cas sur 3000 mais j'en ai
expulsé 2500 il y en a 4000
supplémentaires que je ne peux pas
expulser parce que vous avez pas voté
cette disposition ce texte de loi mais
je pense que dans ces cas-là il faudra
qu'on en parle et qu'on en parle chacune
à nos électeurs bien il me reste 12
inscrits on commence par Monsieur Thomas
rudigo pour 2 minutes
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre l'intégration est un pilier
fondamental pour faire nation est une
part très importante de ce projet de loi
cela concerne bien évidemment
l'apprentissage de la langue et le
groupe Renaissance en fera un point
crucial dans les débats je souhaiterais
monsieur le ministre même si vous l'avez
déjà beaucoup développé que vous
puissiez nous préciser un certain nombre
de mesures sur ces questions
d'apprentissage du français cela
englobera également l'accès à
l'éducation aux soins de santé et à tout
ce qui permet de créer du commun et là
aussi la recherche d'un équilibre sera
nécessaire et nous nous y employerons
par ailleurs le volet relatif au travail
est évidemment essentiel il est
primordial que nos politiques comblent
les besoins du marché du travail mais
aussi valorisent les compét des
personnes qui sont sur nos territoire et
qui ont envie de s'intégrer je ne compte
plus le nombre d'entrepreneurs artisans
ou commerçants qui me font remonter qui
nous font remonter des situations
incompréhensibles où des personnes
étrangères sont empêché de travailler
pour des formalités administratives
contraignantes sur des postes qu'il
n'arrivent pas à pourvoir par ailleurs
encourager l'accès à l'emploi dans des
secteurs en demande tout en garantissant
des conditions équitables est une
approche nécessaire et nous nous y
employerons lors des débats à ce titre
je souhaiterai monsieur le ministre
attirer votre attention sur les délais
en préfecture qui sont encore bien trop
longs surtout dans certaines préfectures
avec de grandes métropoles comme Lyon et
le rô et cela est bien trop long pour
nombre de personnes concernées et
enquistant ainsi un grand nombre de
situations quelles sont donc les mesures
monsieur le ministre que vous envisagez
de prendre pour réduire les délais dans
les services concernés dans nos
préfectures je vous
remercie madame is
Diaz merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues ce
projet de loi fait éclater au grand jour
la discorde qui règne au sein de la
majorité macroniste tout d'abord ce qui
a attiré notre attention ce sont les
modifications calendaire de ce texte
pour rappel il a été annoncé à l'été
2022 il a ensuite été remplacé par un
débat sans vote en hémicycle en décembre
2022 voyant que ça coincait dans la
majorité le président de la République a
envisagé en mars 2023 de le saucissonner
en deux projets distinctes un sur
l'immigration avec vous monsieur le
ministre puis un sur le travail avec
Monsieur dus sopt qui au passage a
disparu les radars
puis le président de la République s'est
rétracté un mois plus tard en ce qui
vous concerne monsieur le ministre c'est
sûr que lorsqu'on a un collègue par
ailleurs président de la commission des
lois qui annonce vouloir élargir les
droits des étrangers extraeuropéens
notamment en leur octroyant le droit de
vote et d'éligégibilité aux élections
municipales et qui cossigent une tribune
dans Libération avec l'extrême gauche
pour soutenir la régularisation des
clandestin on se dit que dans vos
réunions de la majorité il doit y avoir
de l'ambiance mais je crois que pire que
cette instabilité de calendrier et ces
petites pot de banane que vous vous
envoyez entre vous ce qui est grave
c'est que vous n'êtes pas d'accord entre
vous sur le fond du texte prenons un
exemple la transformation de l'aide
médicale d'État en aide médicale
d'urgence en octobre monsieur le
ministre vous êtes dit favorable à cette
évolution depuis vos collègues les
ministres verérant Rousseau ainsi que
Madame borne ont exprimé leur opposition
à vos propos quant à Madame firmain
lobodau ministre délégué aux professions
de santé on ne sait pas trop ce qu'elle
pense de tout ça en en bref en ce qui
vous concerne monsieur le ministre vous
avez dû sortir les rames pour essayer
d'expliquer pourquoi vous avez changé
d'avis sur l'ame on vous a ai vu arguer
qu'une suppression de laame serait
censurée par le Conseil constitutionnel
c'est quand même pas très sérieux quand
on est ministre de l'Intérieur de se r
de se rendre compte de cela seulement
maintenant ainsi ma question est la
suivante alors que près de tr/4 des
Français souhaitent une transformation
de laame en en Amu est-ce qu'ils peuvent
nourrir l'espoir que vous retourniez
encore votre veste sur ce sujet et si
vous ne le faites pas les 78 % des
Français qui ont une mauvaise opinion de
la politique migratoire que votre
gouvernement mène n'ont aucune raison de
changer d'avis madame Diaz la démocratie
c'est compliqué vous devriez peut-être
essayer au rassemblement national ça
vous changerait par ailleurs défendre le
texte du Gouvernement dans une tribune
non non non mais défendre défendre le
ça peut aussi vous changer vous devriez
le lire plutôt que de raconter des
choses erronées vous avez l'habitude en
tant que soutien inconditionnel de la
Russie d'avoir recours aux fausses
informations Monsieur Thomas
porte monsieur le monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre vous l'avez dit
dans Le Parisien vous rêvez de supprimer
la me le Sénat l'a fait pour vous et
contrairement à ce que vous avez dit en
introduction on ne vit pas de laame
depuis 1893 l'aide médicale gratuite qui
était l'héritière de l'aide médicale
d'État résiste aux assaut démagogique
xénophobe et raciste depuis 1893 elle
subit des attaques à répétition avec
pour dernière en date la réforme de 2021
qui complique déjà le recours à l'aide
médicale d'État les exilés confrontés au
au stress du du statut migratoire pardon
précaire aux expériences traumatisantes
et aux obstacles sociaux et
institutionnels doivent au nom de nos
valeurs humanistes être une population
prioritaire en matière de santé publique
au lieu de cela dans la France de
l'égalité de la fraternité dans la
France de 2023 dans la France que vous
rêvez vous nous proposez de supprimer la
me un dispositif élémentaires garant du
respect des droits de l'homme et des
principes éthiques en matière de santé
laame repose sur les fondements
essentiels elle a été instaurée il y a
130 ans pour des enjeux de santé
publique des milliers de soignants et de
médecins vous ont rappelé à l'ordre dans
une tribune vous vous manipulez les
Français avec de faux arguments
économiques vous agitez les peurs vous
alleimonter les haines l'agitation du
mythe de lappel d' est une diversion
cynique comme si un exilé prenait le
temps de lire le code de l'action
sociale et des familles français avant
d'embarquer sur un bateau de fortune
laame c'est 0,4 % des dépenses
d'inurance maladie sur un total de 242
milliards d'euros il y a les grandes
phrases et il y a la réalité
curieusement vous n'évoquez jamais un
budget largement sous-utilisé
représentant seulement 0,04 % des
dépenses de santé plutôt que de vous
attaquer au délinquants financiers vous
préférez priver délibérément toute une
population d'accès aux soins prenant
leur risque conscient de propager des
maladies transmissibles un chiffre en
2018 les prétendu fraude à laame
représente 38 cas pour un montant
équivalent à 500000 € soit 0,06 % des
dépenses de l'assurance maladie c'est
200000 fois moins que les 100 milliards
d'euros d'évasion fiscal pourtant
monsieur le ministre je ne vousi jamais
entendu prétendre supprimer l'évasion
fiscale fort avec les faibles faible
avec les puissants allez-vous laisser
votre nom dans l'histoire comme celui
qui mettra fait un 130 ans de solidarité
monsieur éc Pouget
oui merci président monsieur le ministre
je voudrais vous interroger de manière
précise sur deux deux questions en
particulier en ce qui concerne
l'ame au Sénat vous avez émis un avis de
sagesse pour le transformer en aide
médicale d'urgence or lorsque l'on on
regarde vos différentes interventions
médiatiques on s'interroge et votre avis
a l'air plus nuancé à l'on du texte qui
arrive à l'Assemblée
nationale pourriez-vous nous préciser si
vous êtes toujours favorable à la
transformation de l'aide médicale d'État
en aide médicale d'urgence qui a obtenu
votre avis de sagesse au Sénat et qui
respecterait le cadre européen en nous
mettant au niveau des autres pays
européens le deuxième sujet qui est qui
n'a rien à voir avec celui de la me
concerne les octtf vous avez évoqué à
plusieurs reprises la future inscription
des étrangers sous octtf dans le fichier
des personnes recherchées j'avais
moi-même déposé des amendements au
printemps dernier pour aboutir sur ce
thème-là ça n'a pas été ça n'a pas pu
être possible je vouais savoir si vous
êtes toujours favorable à l'inscription
des des personnes étrangères sous OCF
dans le FPR ce qui serait un outil
supplémentaire pour nos policiers et
savoir si à l'onne de ce texte on
pouvait avancer sur ce sujet je vous
remercie madame Marie tarami merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre trois interrogation suite au
cette première partie de réponse d'abord
sur l'article 1 nouveau qui pose comme
principe que la première délivrance
d'une carte de séjour pour temporaire
portant la mention étudiant qui est
mentionné à l'article 4221 est
subordonné au dépôt d'une caution par
l'êtranger quel est le montant estimé à
priori par ou juste ou raisonnable de
cette caution par vos services et quel
en sera le mode de calcul sera-t-il
apprécié au regard du coût de la vie en
France ou au regard euh d'autres
éléments comme le coût de formation ou
l'existence même de bourse ou d'aide
l'article 12 vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure dans vos réponses initialement
prévoit d'interdire le placement en
centre de rétention donc de moins de 16
ans il entend aussi compléter les
dispositions du CCDA en modifiant
l'article 741 et donc la France a été
condamnée à neuf reprises par la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme sur le
fondement de l'article 3 de la
Convention et la Convention
Internationale des Droits de l'Homme
confè une protection à toutes les
personnes de moins de 18 ans sans
distinction donc si j' je sais pas je
voulais bien que vous je vous entend
confirmer est-ce que vous êtes ouvert à
cette possibilité de prévoir l'âge à 18
ans ça c'est c'était ça aurait été donc
une proposition d'amendement et
l'article 20 pour terminé qui prévoit
que le jugement à juge unique devant la
CNDA devient la règle de droit commun et
en précisant que justement la décision
de la Cour nationale de droit d'asile
sont rendu sauf exception par le
président de la formation justement du
jugement statuant seul donc vous
comprenez qu'en réduisant justement les
jugements en formation collégial le
gouvernement exclut de fait le
représentant du Haut commissariat au
réfugiés donc de la formation de
jugement et que seul souvent connaît la
situation géopolitique justement du pays
d'origine donc a priori donc la volonté
du gouvernement n'est pas d'améliorer le
traitement du contentieux donc
pouvez-vous nous préciser votre
raisonnement sur cette évolution merci
Monsieur Castellani
merci président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues nous savons tous que
nous sommes face à un problème complexe
complexe parce qu'il hérite d'une longue
histoire et d'une accumulation de
situations passées complexe aussi parce
qu'il engage l'avenir et la démographie
nous enseigne que la pression migratoire
ne pourra que croître avec le temps nous
nous pensons que nous avons respecté
deux impératifs d'humanisme et de
réalisme d'humanisme en n'oubliant
jamais que nous traitons du destin
d'être humain qui porte avec eux leurs
devoirs certes mais également leurs
droits y compris d'ailleurs le droit à
la santé de réalisme aussi face à la vie
économique avec le besoin des
entreprises des secteurs tendus face à
la vie sociale et des conditions de vie
de de de travail de logement qui sont
quelquefois inhumaine face aussi à la
nécessité d'intégrer et donc de
maîtriser la langue face enfin à
l'impératif de sécurité et de respect de
l'ordre public qui va d'ailleurs bien
plus loin que la réalité migratoire en
face à ces difficultés moi je poserai
pas de question on vous en a déjà posé
beaucoup j'aimerais simplement dire que
pour nous la solution c'est le respect
de la loi en toute circonstances mais
d'une loi dont l'élaboration devrait
être dictée par le respect de ces deux
principes en tout cas c'est ce que nous
défendrons nous à travers nos
amendements merci Madame C
Dupont merci monsieur le Président
messieurs les rapporteurs monsieur le
ministre chers collègues je reste pour
ma part interpellé si ce n'est
interloqué par la teneur du seexe voté
par le Sénat et les les marqueurs
d'extrême droite qui sont nombreux et en
tant que membre de la commission des
finances et non pas membr de la
commission des lois je compte sur la la
sagesse de votre commission pour
corriger tout ce qui mérite de l'être
pour ma part je suis très attachée à la
réintroduction d'un titre de séjour
travail métier en tension de plein droit
à l'initiative des salariés et sans
décision discrétionnaire du préfet qui
alourdit aussi son quotidien ne
l'oublions pas je suis aussi très
attaché à l'anticipation de l'accès au
travail des demandeurs d'asile de façon
générale et plus particulièrement sur
les demandeurs d'asile de nationalité
fortement protégé dans une logique
d'accélération de leur
intégration de si de là puisque je fais
ce travail fin des 96 articles sortis du
Sénat je note quelques mesures
intéressantes comme le fait de passer
par une expérimentation de la nouvelle
organisation de franceasile afin de
mesurer et d'évaluer l'efficacité d'un
tel dispositif avant son son déploiement
et c'est en tant que rapporteur spécial
de la commission des finances sur ce
sujet de la mission immigration asile
intégration que je m'exprime d'autant
plus que il me semble plus urgent de
renforcer le maillage territorial de
l'OFI qui est limité dans un certain
nombre de régions dont les plus grandes
la proximité n n'est tout de même pas
évidente hein par rapport au servicees
de l'OFI donc je pense qu'il faudrait
plutôt accentuer et prioriser les moyens
sur ce déploiement et enfin monsieur le
ministre vous avez évoqué la réforme de
de de des préfectures sur ce sujet de la
délivrance des titres et j'aimerais
avoir votre éclairage sur les moyens
consacrés en préfecture justement à
cette délivrance puisque j'ai regardé
que j'ai constaté que l'action 2 de la
mission administration territoriale de
l'État voit ses crédits diminuer en 2024
alors même qu'on aura une activité plus
dense donc j'aimerais avoir monsieur
CRAT merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre tous les jours
entre 10h et midi votre compte Twitter
s'active vous y publiez une liste
d'expulsion réalisé par vos services
vous y faites du name and shame nommé
et et couvrir de honte avec des motifs
de plus en plus flous votre fil devient
un mur de la honte où sont montrés du
doigt les étrangers des anonymes que
vous montrez comme des trophées de
chasse à quoi servent ces publications
monsieur le ministre plutôt que
d'essayer de mettre valeur vos résultats
en matière d'expulsion qui ne convint
personne pourquoi ne pas visibiliser la
violence aveugle du patriarcat dont sont
victimes les femmes en donnant des
visages au féminicide qui endro chaque
jour notre pays au lieu de jouer les
gros bras sur La Daille de l'argenteuil
à vouloir nettoyer la France au carcher
comme votre mentor vous faites des pavés
sur Twitter vous voulez vous démontrer
que vous êtes ferme vous attisez surtout
la haine des racistes en les nourrissant
de fait divers avons-nous un ministre de
la République face à nous un chroniqueur
c'est news vous cherchez tellement à
occuper l'espace médiatique que vous
révélez de plus en plus votre in
compétence vous avez expulsé un homme
comme un délinquant alors qu'il était la
victime d'un vol à l'arracher 10 plus un
conjoint de français une autre fois un
enfant français envoyé dans les Comores
sur un délit de fesse une autre fois un
homme expulsé a dû être rapatrié en
France parce que vous n'aviez pas vous
n'aviez pas daigné attendre son recours
et que la justice vous a donné tort
quand allez-vous respecter et faire
respecter le droit plutôt que de draguer
la droite je crois que que ça soit chez
LR et chez leurs électeurs ils ont déjà
repousé vos avances assez lourdes
monsieur le ministre il est temps
d'arrêter les frais vous allez lancer
cette 30e loi sécuritaire sur
l'immigration et vous la lancez avec une
série de tweet en bandeannonce pour
exciter une pensée de droite vous
reprenez des rhtoriques qu'on retrouve
chez Monsieur sootti chez Monsieur
Madame Le Pen chez Monsieur Zemour et
vous alimentez les lub xénophobes et
nous ne pouvons que constater l'échec de
ce choix au travers des ans
l'immigration est traité comme une
source de délinquence alors que c'est
avant tout un phénomène aussi vieux que
l'humanité et elle connaît une crise
d'accueil et de solidarité C son
d'instrumentaliser faire une
instrumentalisation permanente de ce
sujet à des fins
populistes monsieur Monsour
camardine merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues si
nous sommes nombreux ce soir c'est parce
que nous considérons que le sujet de
l'immigration est un sujet très sérieux
quand sur le territoire hexagonal il
place Trô à 10 % tout le monde a peur à
Mayotte on est a-udessus de 60 % sur un
territoire de 374 km² avec plus de
450000 habitants euh population réelle
290000 monsieur le ministre dossiers en
cours d'instruction des gens qui
demandent toujours à venir à Mayotte
plus de 100000 titres de sé jour qu'on a
enfermé sur une cocote une cocote minute
plus de 80 % de nos écoles euh peuplé
d'enfants de parents d'origine
étrangères quand elles sont pas
immigrées euh plus de 200000 gamins en
face à 70 km de là qui attend d' aller à
l'écolé à Mayotte des financements que
l'État n'arrive plus à suivre 11000
naissances tous les ans à Mayotte dont
75 % des gamins de parents d'origine
étrangère étrangère bref voilà la
situation et donc cette situationl oui
monsieur le rapporteur oui monsieur le
ministre ne peut pas être traité comme
on traite les la question migratoire à
Paris euh ou je ne sais dans quelle
région de l'Hexagone nous avons besoin
ici des mesures spécifiques des mesures
fortes qui permettent effectivement
d'endiguer et de permettre aux mauré de
ne plus fuir leur territoire mais de
pouvoir revenir sur leur territoire et y
vivre ces mesures nous allons faire un
certain nombre de propositions mais
d'ors et déjà je voudrais les soumettre
à votre sagacité un principe selon
lequel il y aura pas de régularisation
quand on vient de manière clandestine à
Mayotte quel que soit la dur qu'on fera
on fera pas de régularisation on peut
aller à Paris demander la régularisation
mais à M il y aura pas de régularisation
et je le dis d'autant plus à l'aise que
lorsque je demande aux collègues qui
sont là de venir de laisser les gens
venir ici tout le monde quel que soit
les bain il votent contre mais tout le
monde a le M sur le cœur donc nous aussi
on a le M sur le cœur on dit mais on ne
peut pas c'est je dirais en fait
monsieur le Président j'auris j'aurais
fini c'est fini euh oui que la la la cdH
monsieur le Président la cdH quand la
France était c'est la cdH quand la
France y adhéré il a fait des réserves
s'agissant de Mayot j'aurais souhaité
merci beaucoup que d'ici là vous
puissiez nous faire
madame merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le ministre pour cette
présentation moi j'ai deux questions la
première c'est concernant la dignité de
l'accueil des étrangers nous avons tous
connu les fil devant les préfectures
celles-ci ont disparu mais en tant que
parlementairire nous recevons dans nos
permanences des étrangers qui sont dans
l'incapacité d'avoir l'accès au droit et
je souhaiterais savoir si on ne peut pas
dans ce texte cela apporter des
garanties d'accès au droits aux
étrangers qu'il demandent sur le
territoire alors peut-être serace dans
l'amélioration que vous envisagez des
préfectures mais peut-être faudrait-il
le préciser dans la loi la deuxième
question c'est sur la CNDA je comprends
bien l'objectif de la réforme de la CNDA
qui s'inscrit dans cette recherche de de
raccourcissement des délais de
d'instruction des dossiers ne beaucoup
de spécialistes s'inquiètent de cette
réforme il y aura sans doute des
tribunes qui vont paraître à ce sujet
est-ce qu'il ne faut pas plutôt prévoir
un moratoire par rapport à la CNDA
puisque elle fonctionne pas si mal elle
juge plus de dossiers que de personnes
qui rentrent sur le territoire elle juge
plus de elle jugee plus de dossiers que
ceux qui lui sont soumis chaque année
donc il n'y a pas d'embolisation de la
CNDA et je ne suis pas sûr que la la fin
de la collégialité puisse apporter des
garanties par rapport à l'examen de
dossiers qui sont extrêmement complexes
et sur lesquels il faut mesurer aussi le
caractère pourquoi pas dangereux d'un
certain nombre d'étrangers qui voudrait
entrer sur le territoire de la France
donc rejoignant aussi les préoccupations
qui sont les vôtres je ne suis pas sûr
que le recours au juge unique soit la
solution qui garantit en fait le la la
meilleure analyse et puis vous savez il
y a une question quand même entourant la
CNDA c'est c'est la question de la
formation insuffisante des juges de
l'asile et la question du cadre
déontologique applicable au président et
à ses sœurs bacata et je pense que tout
cela mériterait une analyse peut-être un
peu plus merci
préciseoufa merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je veux commencer
par saluer le travail des forces de
l'ordre et des enquêteurs qui ont
procédé à un vaste coup de filet à nî et
arrêter les auteurs présumés du meurtre
de Fayed un petit Maoré de 10 ans tué
par le narcotrafic je veux aussi vous
alerter sur la vague de violence qui
sème à nouveau la TER terreur à maotte
depuis plusieurs semaines à Sada à
bandrabois à mamouzu à wangani des
bandes de barbares qui pillent
vandalisent incendie agresse et sème la
mort nuit et jour pour nous à maotte les
enjeux migratoires sont un sujet de
sécurité mais il provoque surtout une
crise hors du commun la plus grave que
connaît notre pays plus de la moitié de
la population est étrangère en grande
partie en situation irrégulière notre
territoire implose les services publics
sont saturés notre seul hôpital sert
d'abord les étrangers qui arrivent en
grande détresse point d'ame à Mayotte et
nous attendons là-dessus puisque la
dépense pour la santé des étrangers se
fait actuellement au dépend de la santé
des maorés Mayot territoire le plus
pauvre de France accueille le plus
d'étrangers et nous n'en pouvons plus la
modification de l'acquisition de la
nationalité porté par le sénateur Tanier
il y a plusieurs il y a plusieurs années
est passée sans aucune modification de
la Constitution Mayotte ne peut plus
entendre ce faux argument pour défendre
l'inertie comme nous n'acceptons plus le
refus de mettre fin au visas
territorialisés qui fixe les étrangers à
maotte et transforme notre île en cocote
minute l'argument de l'appel d'air ne
tient pas puisque Mayotte implose déjà
sous la pression migratoire et nous
n'avons besoin et nous avons surtout
besoin de la solidarité nationale pour
faire face ma question monsieur le
ministre quelle mesure avez-vous prévu
pour Mayotte dans votre texte je vous
remerci Monsieur Jean-François
coulom merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre de l'Intérieur la
France insoumise se place ici
aujourd'hui en porte-voie des agents de
l'Office français des réfugiés des
apatries de lofpra qui ont été en grève
grève à laquelle se sont joints des
agents de la CNDA Cour nationale du
droit d'asile ils ont été en grève et le
seront de nouveau prochainement afin
d'alerter sur leurs conditions de
travail désastreus qu'aggrave votre
projet de loi mais aussi et surtout pour
demander le retrait de son chapitre 4 et
dénoncer votre politique du chiffre
cette politique du chiffre que vous
aimetant au détriment des salariés des
demandeurs d'asile des droits humains et
du bon sens une politique du chiffre de
plus en plus poussée avec des procédures
de plus en plus complexes des délais de
plus en plus courts avec comme maître
mot la régulation et les économies mais
venons-en au fond pour l'OFPRA est-ce
afin d'accompagner au mieux et au plus
près les demandeurs que vous voulez
créer des pôles france-asile et
territorialiser l'OFPRA la réalité
monsieur Darmanin c'est qu'en soumettant
l'OFPRA à la tutelle politique et
administrative des préfets vous mettriez
fin à son indépendance pour la CNDA vous
voulez territorialiser la cour supprimer
la collégialité et supprimer la présence
du Haut commissariat au réfugiés la
réalité est que vous renversez un
principe fondamental et que cette
proposition met en danger réel l'équité
et l'impartialité dans l'examen des
recours tous ces constats ne sont pas
les nôtres monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur mais ceux de plus de 200
professionnels travaillant à la CNDA de
grvistes de représentants des avocats de
très nombreuses associations
humanitaires face face à cela ma
question qui est aussi celle des agents
de l'ofpr et de la CNDA des grvistes et
association en soutien est la suivante
monsieur Darmanin pourquoi voulez-vous
mettre fin à l'indépendance et à
l'impartialité de l'OFPRA et de la CNDA
que répondez-vous à ces agents monsieur
Fabien
diilippo merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre de l'Intérieur deux
questions en ce qui me concerne la
première sur les délais administratifs
de traitement des demandes vous avez
évoqué l'embolie des des juridictions on
constate autant qu'on est dans nos nos
préfectures des délais qui sont très
très longs vous avez parlé de la
priorité au prime demandeur est-ce que
dans les services des étrangers il y a
aujourd'hui les capacité nécessa pour
pour absorber ces ces flux de demande
parce que et bien comme vous l'avez dit
plus longtemps on se maintient en
attente d'un d'une réponse sur le
territoire et plus l'expulsion devient
devient impossible la deuxième question
je compléterai une question sur l'aide
médicale d'État qui vise à prendre en
charge les besoins médicaux des des
clandestins et les restrictions que les
républicains ont voulu il a posé en la
transformant en aide médicale d'urgence
on est loin des caricatures faites par
la gauche il ne s'agit pas de ne plus
soigner les gens qui porteraient des
maladies grav ou qui porteraient des
maladies très contagieuses je vous
rappelle et c'est écrit sur le site de
l'Assurance maladie au corps que l'aide
médicale d'État prend en charge au bout
de 9 mois pour les personnes qui ont
violé nos lois présentes illégalement en
France le recollement des oreilles les
prothèses d'épauules ou de genoux la PAE
d'anau gastrique et le traitement du
canal carpien donc sur ces sujets-là je
pense qu'on peut évoluer le contribu
français ne comprend plus qu'il a à
prendre en charge de tel type de frais
de santé pour des personnes qui ont
violé nos lois c'est ça l'objet de notre
demande et je voulais avoir votre
position par rapport à cet état de fait
monsieur Arthur de la porte merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre bon tout à l'heure vous avez
d'une certaine manière dit la gauche on
entend pas vos propositions mais je
crois que on a été extrêmement clair
déjà dans ce qu'on a pu dire et par
ailleurs je vous renvoie au projet du du
du Parti socialiste sur le sujet on vous
le renverra par mail si vous le
souhaitez pour avoir un peu de lecture
et je vous assure que la vision n'est
pas du tout celle que vous présentez
aujourd'hui et je vais reprendre un peu
ce que disait ma collègue el aillon tout
à l'heure il y a ce qu'il a dans dans la
loi et il y a des horreurs encore plus
après le Sénat il y a surtout ce qui n'y
est pas et nous notre rôle c'est de
faire le droit mais aussi de lutter
contre le longroit je vais prendre deux
exemples sur lesquels j'aimerais avoir
un retour de votre part le premier c'est
ce qui se passe à la frontière en
particulier à la frontière
franco-italienne avec ce qu'on appelle
les locaux de mise à l'abri monsieur le
ministre ces locau ne sont pas définis
dans le droit ils sont absents également
de ce texte et il s'avère que on
constate dans ces dans ces lieux des
conditions qui s'apparentent à de la
privation de liberté sans pour autant
qu'il y ait un accueil digne des
personnes qui sont ni qu'elles aient
accès à leur à l'exercice de leurs
droits fondamentaux ça c'est le premier
point monsieur le ministre et donc je
souhaiterais avoir votre réaction sur ce
point deuxième sujet je vais prendre le
département du Calvados il y a deux
campements importants le prier à camp
avec une centaine d'Afghans le deuxème à
wistream avec à peu près 200 soudanis
ces deux pays sont des pays en guerre
une bonne partie des personnes notamment
à wistriam la majorité d'entre eux ont
fait une demande d'asile pour autant ces
personnes restent dans des camps n'ont
pas accès à l'hébergement d'urgence il y
a un problème d'accès au droit
aujourd'hui pour les demandeurs d'asile
monsieur le ministre je ne vois pas ça
dans le texte et j'attends votre réponse
sur ce point également je vous remercie
dernier orateur inscrit monsieur Jordan
Guitton merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre ma question sera
simple et portera sur les chiffres de
l'immigration et de l'avenir de votre
action selon les données de votre
ministère en 2022 plus de 320000
premiers titres de séjour ont été
délivrés plus plus de 160000 personnes
ont demandé l'asile en 2022 et selon vos
propres mots lors de l'audition au Sénat
vous estimez entre 600000 et 900000 le
nombre de personnes présentes
irrégulièrement sur le territoire
national appelé clandestin vous qui
parlez je cite plusieurs fois de fermeté
à propos de votre texte dans la presse
en audition et qui évoquer un texte
d'intérêt général sachant qu'en 2022
donc nous avons accueilli un peu moins
de 500000 personnes dans notre pays et
que vous estimez qu'il y a entre 600000
et 900000 clandestin envisagez-vous si
votre texte est adopté une baisse réel
de l'immigration légale exclure plus de
clandestins que vous n'alllez en
régulariser je vous rappelle que nos
compatriotes sont en droit de savoir
alors que selon plusieurs sondages il
souhaite une déminition considérable à
plus de 71 % des flux de l'immigration
sur le territoire national et qu'il
souhaite aussi un référendum sur
l'immigration que votre majorité a
refusé pouvez-vous aussi nous assurer
que l'exécution des taux des qtf va
enfin augmenter si votre texte est
adopté et allez-vous avec cette loi
exclure les 4000 personnes étrangères
suivi pour radicalisation pouvez-vous
donc enfin nous assurer que les flux
migratoires légaux et illégaux vont
enfin baisser comme le réclame nos
compatriotes ou allez-vous faire
malheureusement l'inverse je vous
demande de répondre à mes questions qui
sont d'intérêt national lorsqu'on
connaît les conséquences néfastes de
l'immigration pour notre pays que nous
dénonçons depuis des années je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre pour
réponse à tous les orateurs merci merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président merci aux
orateurs peut-être répondre à Monsieur
Go mais ça correspond à d'autres
questions notamment celle posée par
Monsieur di Philippo ou madame Dupon sur
le fonctionnement des des préfectures je
je veux redire une nouvelle fois que
j'ai parfaitement conscience du mauvais
service public rendu à nos concitoyens
qui ont envie d'accompagner des
personnes qui veulent être régularisé ou
qui vont renouveler leur titre de séjour
ou par des personnes étrangères qui
voudraient accéder en effet à leur droit
je profite par dire à madameammer que si
elle veut préciser dans le texte de loi
la façon dont on accède au droit il est
évident que que je donnerai un avis
favorable pour pouvoir bien sûr
permettre à chacune et à chacun de faire
valoir ses droits devant les services
publics dans des conditions pas facile
où on parle mal français parfois pas du
tout dans des conditions évidemment
parfois d'ilétrisme dans des conditions
évidemment de de violence qu'on a subi
donc je pense qu'il y a bien une
explicitation de ces droits c'est bien
naturel c'est pas du tout évidemment
opposé au fait qu'on puisse être par
ailleurs ferme puisque évidemment on
rentre dans des dans des cas prévus par
le législateur et qu'il faut évidemment
que le non recours à son droit ne puisse
pas exister dans la République française
donc je voudrais ici le le dire pour
précéder un éventuel dépôt d'amendement
dire donc à Monsieur ridicose à Madame
Stella Dupont et à Monsieur di Philippo
que le sujet c'est à la fois la
numérisation de de ce qu'on appelle le
Boffice puisque vous avez vu qu'il y a
laanf donc laanf c'est quoi c'est c'est
la numérisation des procédures pour les
étrangers si j'étaéis rapide je dirais
l'impôt à la source appliqué aux
préfectures puisque tout était en papier
quand je suis arrivé au ministère de
l'intérieur avec des conditions
extrêmement difficiles avec des
étrangers qui changent de préfecture et
donc évidemment des difficultés à suivre
cela et ça c'est le travail évidemment
que doiv faire notamment les services
puisqueen 2025 nous aurons terminé la
nef en 2024 pourépondre en partie au
crédit qu'évoqué Madame Dupont on a 60 %
des des procédures dématérialisées au
1er janvier 2024 donc on peut imaginer
quand même qu'on y fa quelques économies
dire à Madame Dupont que sur la il y a
une augmentation d'effectif de 400
personnes dans les préfectures que vous
avez voté dans la lopmie je vous en
remercie mais par ailleurs il est aussi
vrai qu'on a 20 % de vacatair donc on
emboche plus de vacatair dans les
préfectures aussi parce qu'il une manque
d'attractivité de certains métiers euh
et par ailleurs qu'il fallait assez vite
répondre à un besoin client que vous
avez vous-même évoqué donc le coût d'un
vacataire évidemment pas le même que la
coup d'un d'un fonctionnaire mais
s'équilibrera dans l' LPFP que vous avez
dû voir pour 25 et pour et pour 26 voilà
comment on arrive à 8 % de de moins de
crédit mais je pourrais vous exp
expliciter ça davantage si vous le
souhaitez je ve dire à Monsieur rodigo
donc à Monsieur di Philippo et à Madame
Dupont que l'idée c'est donc utiliser
vraiment la numérisation des procédures
désormais des étrangers pour le
backofice permettre comme je l'ai dit la
présence des effectifs et notamment des
effectifs nouveaux soit ceux qui
s'occupaient du renouvellement de titre
soit ceux qu'on va affecter désormais
puisqu'on a mis plus de monde dans les
préfectures che les primos les primos
demande une fois qu'on sait que cette
personne n'a pas de casier judiciaire
qu'elle a réussi son examen de français
et qu'elle a des états civils qui sont
non frauduleux ben qu'on a donné un
titre pluannuel de permettre
l'automaticité parce qu'aujourd'hui de
mémoire je crois qu'on est à 100000
titres
renouvelable qui serait concerné en en
flux et c'est à peu près 400000 en stock
donc c'est vraiment énorme et notamment
très concentré dans les grandes régions
dans les grandes régions évidemment
urbaines et dans les départements ruraux
ils ont la ils ont la double peine
puisque évidemment il y a de moins en
moins d'ff il y a eu de moins en moins
d'effectifs dans les préfectures ou dans
les grosses sous-préfectures qui
s'occupaient d'étrangers notamment dans
la ruralité et donc euh euh vraiment je
veux dire c'est le le le la révolution
copernicienne qu'on va imposer aux
préfectures de s'occuper des Primot et
de rendre automatique euh les euh les
euh titres de séjour euh que sur lequel
la République a déjà euh euh si je dire
délibéré ça veut dire qu'il y a quand
même un appel pour le préfet un système
informatique qui fait que quand
quelqu'un est arrêté par les services de
police de gendarmarie coné par la
justice ça remonte au préfet qui donc du
coup peut empêcher l'automaticité du
titre euh ou retirer le titre de séjour
notamment sur l'article 13 qu'on a
évoqué tout à l'heure mais l'idée de
tous ceux qui ne posent aucun problème
de pouvoir avoir le renouvellement je
dis d'autant plus que encore une fois
nous mettons nous même dans
l'irrégularités des personnes parce
qu'ils ont pas attend leur rendez-vous
en préfecture ça c'est un problème quand
même important c'est pas de la faute de
l'étranger c'est de la faute de l'État
français et deuxièmement on a fait des
expériences notamment avec quelques
publics très choisis je pense au Shibani
ces citoyens algériens qui ont combattu
notamment dans l'armée française mais
qui ont pas choisi la nationalité
française tout en restant sur notre sol
les gens qui entre eux désormais mais 70
80 90 parfois 100 ans qu'on forçait il y
en a beaucoup dans mon département à
aller faire de renouvellement de titrre
en préfecture du Nord alors que non
seulement ils étaient anciens
combattants parfois décorés par votre
pays il avaient choisi de rester
algérien c'est leur droit le plus strict
évidemment on avit pas les embêter à 80
ans savoir si on devait remettre un
titre de séjour c'est pourant ce qu'on
fait et ce qu'on a fait ce qui est plus
le cas aujourd'hui et donc évidemment on
va généraliser cela plus de moyens
numérisation concentration sur les
primos arrivants automaticité alerte en
cas de problème de casé judiciaire je je
pense que c'est une transformation très
importante moi je veux redire ici euh
mes mes mes remerciements profonds au
aux agents des préfectures qui souvent
euh voilà dans des difficultés
administratives et parfois avec un
public compliqué c'est bien normal parce
qu'ils cherchent à avoir leur droit
reste toujours je crois très très très
calme et très professionnel et je veux
dire à leur représentant que je pense
que cette loi va les va les servir bien
évidemment et je suis prêt j'ai dit au
président de la commission des lois de
présenter devant la commission des lois
le détail euh de cette de cette réforme
des préfectures euh lorsqu'il le
souhaitera avec les directeurs concernés
euh vous m'avez posé plusieurs questions
autour de l'Ame alors on va essayer de
redire sur un sujet compliqué mais il y
a moins de monde donc peut-être qu'il
sera d moins polémique sur quelle est ma
position personnelle puisque je me suis
exprimé et j'ai le droit d'en avoir une
bien évidemment l'aide médicale d'État
n'était pas dans le texte que j'ai
proposé au gouvernement ni au Conseil
d'État ni à la table du Conseil des
ministres ni au Sénat bon donc il y
avait pas de disposition santé dans ce
texte pourquoi parce que j'ai voulu me
concentrer sur des dispositions qui sont
déjà extrêmement compliquées qui sont
les dispositions du code des étrangers
et l'aide médicale d'État j'était 3 ans
ministre des comptes publics on en
parlait chaque année dans un débat
budgétaire puisque c'est un débat qui
relève du budget ou du code de la santé
publique pas d'un débat qui réève du
droit des étrangers bien c'est
d'ailleurs une question intéressante
puisque madame yousoufa ça peut
paraître paradoxal mais elle réclame à
Mayotte l'ame elle réclame pas à Mayotte
la me parce qu'elle est pour plus
étrangers dans l'hôpital à l'hôpital de
maotte et je pense que c'est la même
chose pour le député camardine elle
réclame laame pour qu'on puisse tracer
les dépenses des étrangers irréguliers à
mayotsk j'imagine que les députés Maoris
ont l'idée par ailleurs du coup de
pouvoir chiffrer le nombre exactement
d'étrangers qui sont à Mayot puisque bon
voilà monsieur camardi je ne Renis pas
ses chiffres mais entre 30 % de Monsieur
serva et 60 % de Monsieur cavardine je
pense que la vérité à mon avis est entre
les deux mais enfin c'est beaucoup cou
d'étranger en situation irrégulière
qu'il a à Maillotte personne ne le
conteste je crois sérieusement et
prévoit que c'est une compensation
budgétaire donc de l'État à la sécurité
sociale de voir que les étrangers qui ne
payent pas de cotisation étrangers
irréguliers puissent être quand même
soigné par des médecins qui les
soigneront quoi qu'il arrive donc
d'abord la me c'est avant tout une
question budgétaire c'est qui paye
puisque à la fin des fins les gens sont
soignés est-ce que c'est l'État qui
compense sa SQ ou est-ce que c'est la SQ
voilà et notamment à Mayotte la question
est que ce sont c'est la CQ et c'est
donc la difficulté pour l'hôpital qui
est à Maillotte de vivre de de pouvoir
fonctionner ainsi donc laame c'est avant
tout un traçage budgétaire et au moins
l'avantage de laame c'est de savoir à
quoi ça correspond mon mon avis 1 c'est
que dans ce texte de loi il doit pas y
avoir laame je l'ai dit depuis le début
et ça n'a rien de contradictoire vous
lisez sans doute très mal ou alors
peut-être que je m'exprime extrêmement
mal ce qui est une possibilité aussi
Bayons notre chemin j'ai d à titre
personnel on pouvait se poser des
questions sur la me je ne suis pas tout
à fait d'accord avec les dispositions
qui consistent à dire que laame doit
être changé au nom de son panier de
soins je pense que c'est un débat
interminable et que les médecins quoi
qu'il arrive soigneront et que par
ailleurs il y aura de l'embolie dans les
dans l'hôpital public en revanche moi je
pense qu'il y a un sujet on verra ce que
dira monsieur Stéphan et Monsieur Evin
il y a un rapport commandé par la
première ministre il y a un sujet sur le
fait que la me certes c'est 25 %
d'enfants donc il faut faire attention à
ce que l'on fait mais c'est aussi 75 %
de personnes qui sont là depuis plus de
3 ans sur le territoire national et
j'attire l'attention des parlementaires
qui soit pour ou contre laame transformé
en Amu laame tout court ou la
suppression de laame ou la progression
générale de la me sur le fait que quand
vous êtes un étranger en situation
irrégulière qui arrive en France un
demandeur d'asile qui n'a pas encore
demandé son asile par exemple il n'a pas
le droit à la me dans les trois premiers
mois de sa présence sur le territoire
national donc ça veut dire qu'on peut se
poser quand même la question de la me
est-ce que la me d'aujourd'hui
fonctionne bien c'est une question très
très intéressante parce que dans les 3
mois qui suit sa présence sur le
territoire national il peut pas être
donc du coup couvert par sa vaccination
par la partie oriante qui a une qui a
une femme enceinte et qui va donc
accoucheron et puis par ailleurs il peut
avoir les 9 mois au bout de 9 mois de
présence irrégulière l'intégralité du
panier notamment la consultation à 100 %
chez le généraliste et et et là pendant
avant 9 mois c'est aussi un problème
parce que c'est dans cette période là où
normalement on devrait être attentif à
dans sa présence sur le territoire
national en attendant de lui donner ou
pas un titre de séjour et c'est pour ça
que le projet de loi me paraît assez
cohérent le but du jeu du du du projet
de loi si je c'est d'accélérer les
procédures qu'on dise oui qu'on dise non
pendant cette période d'accélération
qu'on couvre la santé des personnes ça
me paraît évident la question qui se
pose et qui devrait tous nous
interpeller c'est pourquoi 75 % des gens
qui sont sont là depuis plus de 3 ans
sur le territoire national c'est c'est
bien qu'il a un sujet de personnes qui
restent sur le territoire national
malgré le fait qu'on leur a dit non
puisque 3 ans c'est quand même la la
fourchette haute me semble-t-il euh des
décisions de justice donc ma ma ma
position personnelle c'est que il y a
des questions qui se posent sur la me
comme toute politique publique je crois
que elle mérite d'être questionné
qu'onit d'ailleurs pour l'extension de
la me ou qu'on soit pour sa
transformation c'est pas grave d'en
parler voilà deuxièmement pas dans ce
texte là parce que dès le début j'avais
limité au code des étrangers donc c'est
un cavalier législatif évident
d'ailleurs le Sénat le sait partinemment
le gouvernement ne ni pas qu'il y a des
questions qui se posent madame la premre
ministre a commandé un rapport qui sera
rendu le 4 décembre et on ne cache rien
puisque sera rendu avant le débat au
sein de l'émicycle donc si vraiment on
avait voulu calculer on aurait demandé à
Monsieur evvin monsieur stéphanini de
personnalités je crois incontestabl dans
la question de la santé la question
d'étranger de le rendre après le débat
parlementaire on l' pas fait donc on a
rien à cacher sur ce point et il faudra
peut-être tirer des conséquences sur
laame alors il y a des questions qui de
gens qui posent la question du panier de
soins il y a des gens qui question qui
posent la question évidemment comme moi
plutôt du statut des personnes mais mais
je pense pas qu'il faille le mettre dans
le projet loi parce que par ailleurs on
sait tout ce qui sera censuré par le
Conseil constitutionnel c'est un
cavalier évident voilà et et tout le
monde le sait y compris je le sais le le
le Sénat donc à titre personnel je suis
pour réfléchir voire pour modifier laame
pas le panier de soins et je pense qu'il
faut regarder la la question de la
présence des gens qui sont durablement
sur le territoire national alors qu'on
leur a dit non qui est la conséquence le
fait que la procédure soit trop longue
et qui est donc à mon avis la raison
pour laquelle on fait ce projet de loi
j'espère aini avoir répondu au à ces
questions et je j'admet tout à fait que
d'autres membres du gouvernement et que
d'autres personnes qui soit ou pas dans
ma famille politique et un avis
contraire ça s'appelle la démocratie je
rappelle d'ailleurs que c'est le
gouvernement d'doir Philippe qui avait
modifié laame avec Madame avec Madame
Buzin et il y avait un ministre des
comptes publques à l'époque qui avait
travillé avec Madame madame Buzin le le
la question les questions que pose
euh pardon monsieur Poget donc j'aipendu
pour la me et ainsi à vous ainsi qu'à
Monsieur Madame Diaz monsieur porte et
Monsieur di Philippo pour ce qui est
concerné me semble-t-il sur la question
des ETF oui ils sont ils sont dans le
FPR désormais donc il y a une
instruction qui date de 2022 quand je me
je m'étais engagé devant vous le 17
novembre 2022 que j'ai signé qui a été
validé par le Conseil d'État parce que
cette instruction a été attaquée par un
certain n de personnes le Conseil d'État
m'a donné raison et on inscrit désormais
les personnes qui ont des TF dans le
fichier du pr la difficulté monsieur le
député vous le savez bien c'est qu'une
très grande partie de cesqtf sont
suspensifs de l'action de la police donc
c'est pas parce que nous constatons
quelqu'un que nous pouvons la la la
considérer évidemment FPR il y a
plusieurs catégories et on distingue
évidemment l'étranger en situation
irrégulière qui n'a commis aucun crime
et délit je rappelle que le délit de
séjours irrégulier a été supprimé par
une loi de 2012 mais aussi par une
directive européenne d'ailleurs élaborée
par le PPE mais le maintien de séjour du
dé maintien le séjour irrégulier est
toujours un délit c'est ce qui permet au
servic de police de faire leurs actions
c'est pour ça que le débat sur le délit
de séjour irréguliier monsieur le
rapporteur général me paraît un débat un
peu ésotérique dans les faits pour les
policiers et pour les gendarmes on aa
l'occasion d'en reparler cependant tous
ces personnes qui sont le qtf sont dans
le FPR et ils sont pas dans les mêmes
cases évidemment que ceux qui sont des
criminels c'est il y a des personnes
recherchées il y a plusieurs types de
personnes recherchées donc je voulais
vous dire qu'on a pas besoin de la loi
c'est fait depuis le 17 novembre 2022
alors après qui avant le 17 novembre
2022 des gens qui soccut F qui était si
je dire dans le stock et qui n'ont pas
été mis c'est possible puisqueévidemment
nous sincérisons ce fichier mais depuis
17v 2022 tous les nouveaux UTF pris par
toutes les préfectures de la République
les personnes sont systématiquement
inscrites par par les préfets madame
Caram m'a posé trois questions précises
je vais essayer de répondre précisément
je ne suis pas favorable à l'article 1
étudiant caution je l'ai dit au Sénat je
pense qu'il faut regarder un certain
nombre de choses qui concernent les
étudiants je je crois d'ailleurs que la
vérification des études sérieuses par
les étudiants est une bonne disposition
je je veux attirer l'attention des
parlementaires pourir dire que il y a
une difficulté c'est que les facs
évidemment les fac public voi leur
budget euh en proportion des étudiants
quisincrivent à leur fac et il peut y
avoir une tentation d'inscrire beaucoup
d'étudiants à leur fac sans qu'ils
fassent vraiment leurs études c'est une
possibilité ça pose pas la question des
étrangers ça pose la question de comment
on on rémunère les fac en France c'est
un autre sujet mais moi je suis euh
plutôt favorable à la vérification ce
qu' a d'ailleurs mis le Sénat euh alors
faut savoir ce que c'est exactement
de d'avoir fait correctement ces études
de façon réelle et sérieuse je crois que
c'est le terme exact en revanche la
caution me paraît une bizarrerie et et
même contreproductive parce que le sujet
n'est pas de prendre des gens riches
pour faire des études en France le sujet
de prendre des gens talentueux pour
faire des études en France et il y a pas
de lien entre talent et richesse me
semble-t-il donc mettre une caution pour
des gens qui viendraient de pays plus
pauvres ou même d'étranger dans P riches
qui seraient pauvre me paraît contraire
à ce qu'on essaie de faire dans la
méritocratie française donc je suis
défavorable à la caution il y a une mini
un mini paiement de visa vous le savez
mais qui n'est pas diriment me
semble-t-il parfois aidé par les
associations par les pays mais je ne
suis donc pas favorable à la caution
pour les étudiants donc je nai pas de
modalité d'expression puisque j'espère
que vous supprimerez cet article en tout
cas vous le modifierez sur l'article 12
je suis effectivement favorable comme je
l'ai dit à la suppression de la présence
des mineurs dans les centres de
rétention administratif pour les moins
de 18 ans et dès la publication de la
loi une exception vous a demandé pour
Mayotte parce qu'à Mayot ce ne sont pas
ce ne sont pas que des délinquants
mettons en cras je rappelle que plus la
moitié des condu à la frontière de
France se font à maotte dans le seul
cras qui existe à Petite Terre puisquon
un deuxiè qui va se construire à sur sur
Grande Terre et il faudra supprimer
également ça à maot mais il faut me
laisser quelques années ou en tout cas
laisser au ministre de l'Intérieur
quelques années pour créer des unités de
famille pour pouvoir évidemment éloigner
les personnes parce que quand on
supprime les présences des mineurs en CR
on supprime pas la possibilité
d'éloigner les personnes on veut bien
éloigner des familles moi en tout cas
entendons-nous bien je ne suis pas pour
ne pas éloigner
des familles je suis pour éloigner des
familles dans des conditions pour que
les bébés ou des jeunes adolescents ne
vivent pas dans un centre de rétention
administratif qui aujourd'hui on y met
que des gens radicalisés et des gens qui
sont délinquants donc quiconque a eu des
enfants en basâge c'est que c'est pas
une bonne construction mentale que de le
faire ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faut pas
éloigner des familles c'est qu'il faut
le faire dans un cadre différent de ceux
qui sont dangereux pour la société on
aura l'occasion d'en reparler mais je
suis favorable à 18
ans madame moins 18 ans madame la
députée et puis le 20 al moi j'ai pas du
tout la même lecture et je le dis ici à
plusieurs intervenants et compris à ceux
qui évoquaient la question de la CNDA de
de de du jug unique d'abord je rappelle
que le juge unique aujourd'hui il existe
c'est 50 % de ce que fait la CNDA
deuxièement jeux vous dire que le taux
de taux de protection est le même en
formation collégiale et en formation
jugunique donc on fait pas ça pour avoir
moins de Tau de protection bon après je
vais vous lire l'article parce que a
parfois des moments où où je me dis
tiens je me rappelle plus très bien où
je rêve différemment mais en fait à
chaque fois je le relis je me dis non
c'est bien je ne suis pas dansemption je
suis bien dans un monde réel monsieur
Sacha ou n'a pas sa toupie mais pour
autant je je peux dire que c'est bien le
texte de loi que nous avons non
seulement élaboré mais voté au Sénat par
ailleurs à moins que de sa propre
initiative ou à la demande du récurrant
le président de la Cour nationale du
droit d'asile ou le président de
formation du jugement désigné en cette
fin ne décide à tout moment de la
procédure d'inscrire l'affaire devant
une formation collégiale ou de la lui
renvoyer s'il estime qu'elle pose une
question qui le justifie les décisions
d' cender sont rendu par président la
formation du jugement statut en seul à
moins que le président de la Cour
nationale de droit d'asile ou le
président de la formation c'est le juge
unique ou le requérant c'estd le
demandur d'asile ou son avocat à tout
moment de la procédure c'est qu'on peut
s'arrêter et on peut dire ah ben on a
envie d'aller voir finalement le juge
collégial parce qu'il faut qu'il ait le
HR ou parce qu'il faut qu'il y a une une
décision plus large ça c'est le juge
unique c'est pas l'obligation par l'État
ou par lepra j'ai entendu des idicies
générales c'est pas du tout ça on dit
tout tout le monde doit se mettre
d'accord pour que ce soit dans le juge
unique et en plein milieu de la
procédure on peut s'arrêter pour aller
dans le juge collégial alors pourquoi on
fait ça c'est la question que vous
pouvez nous poser parce que il y a des
décisions mais la CDA le dit elle-même
il y a des décisions qui doivent être
prises de manière collégiale parce que
c'est des arrêts on va dire de principe
la jurisprudence Kabou lorsque il y
avait une question avant l'arrivée des
talibans qui nous a bousculé dans
jurisprudence des des des moments
géopolitiques du monde où bien sûr des
personnes qui arrivent peuvent faire
valoir que dans telle partie de la
région il peut avoir une person
persécution particulière une loi qui est
adoptée pour la persécution des
personnes transjor ou homosexuelles
enfin on peut imaginer plein de raisons
qui fait que bah il y a une question de
principes qui se pose et qui mérite un
jugement collégial et puis après il y a
plein de questions même si les cas sont
tous individuels qui se ressemblent vous
le savez bien comment ça fonctionne
quand même et donc y compris pour donner
très vite l'asile c'est plus facile pour
un Afghan d'avoir l'asile s'il va dans
le juge unique il l'aura puisque le taux
de protection est très élevé on donne
l'asile aux Afghans qui viennent
d'Afghanistan et qui sont pour chassés
par les talibans puis oui il y a aucune
raison de donner l'asile par principe
par principe à des Ivoiriens ou à des
Sénégalais sauf si bien sûr c'est des
opposants politiques notoir ou des
personnes qui sont persécuté en raison
de leur de leur de leur sexe mais c'est
c'est vraiment très peu le tau de
protection pour les Ivoiriens et pour et
pour les Sénégalais donc nous paraî il
nous paraît que le juge unique quand on
sait que 1 il existe déjà que de c'est
évidemment un magistrat que 3 il a le
même taux de protection que le juge
collégial que 4 il a le droit à tout
moment d'aller voir le juge collégial ça
vaut pas la fin la CND qu'est-ce j'ai
entendu la la mise à la la mise sous
tutelle acnda bon voilà là on est parti
assez loin encore une fois on n'est pas
c'est pas ce que vous avez dit Madame la
député mais estce qu'on dit d'autres
orateurs là on est parti assez loin en
tout cas n'est pas parti du texte du
Gouvernement ni même V sui par le Sénat
parce que le Sénat n'est pas venu
évidemment sur ces dispositions alors
moi je je je veux dire al l'orateur qui
qui est parti euh de la France insoumise
ouais il est il est plus là mais de là
où il est il doit nous doit nous
entendre euh je je sur la question de
nous nous faisons monter les extrêmes je
pense que c'est plutôt c'est plutôt lui
me semble-t-il par sa posture
idéologique qui soit fait monter les
extrêmes notamment l'extrême droite
Paris qu'il fait lui-même partie d'un
extrême donc c'est bien il il se rejoint
dans les outran mais soit surtout et je
pense que ça c'est inquiétant ne protège
pas les étrangers même moi je je
constate que les étrangers sont les
premiers à demander des mesures de
fermeté contre ceux qui se comportent
mal parce que c'est les gens qui se
comportent mal qui donnent une mauvaise
image des autres et et c'est une des
causes de la création du racisme et de
la discrimination et moi je n'ai jamais
vu de gens aussi fermes que les
personnes qui sont population étrangère
dans ma propre commune et je dis d'utant
plus que j'en suis par deux fois le
descendant donc on n pas la même façon
de faire c'est pas en laissant faire des
criminels et délinquants agir qu'on va
protéger et mieux faire comprendre ou
accepter l'immigration notre pays qui
l'a déjà très largement accepté depuis
extrêmement longtemps donc je comprends
pas ce raisonnement sauf à à faire
effectivement sa minutes sur les réseau
sociaux puisqueil n même pas écouté la
réponse que j'ai essayé de de lui
apporter sur je pense avoir répondu
madame sur l'accès sur l'accès au au
droit sur Madame Youssoufa a donc
compris que comme je ne veux pas parler
de la me dans le texte je ne vais pas
non plus en parler pour Mayot mais c'est
un débat très intéressant qui qui peut
se dérouler dans d'autres discussions
puisqueen ce moment il paraît qu'
discussion budgétaire ouverte et nourrie
avec le gouvernement dans un cadre
parlementaire
important donc n'hésitons pas moi je
veux dire à Madame yousoufa que je suis
très favorable à la disposition qui
consiste à revenir même à accélérer ce
qu'avait fait votre collègue tan sur les
parents aujourd'hui pour être régularisé
à maotte il faut avoir un des deux
parents qui est régulier au français
depuis 3 mois avant la naissance de
l'enfance sur le territoire national à
maotte je suis favorable à ce que nous
travaillons collectivement c'est pas
dans le texte de loi aujourd'hui mais je
savais que j'ir avant vous pour que les
deux parents doivent être réguliers pas
un seul mais les deux et depuis plus de
9 mois pourquoi pas un an sur le
territoire national 1 de je suis
favorable monsieur camardine à la
disposition qui est de dire on ne peut
pas régulariser à maotte j'ai bien
entendu la question était Mayotte j'ai
bien compris que c'était pas national à
Mayotte de ne pe pas régulariser
quelqu'un à Mayotte s'il est irrégulier
en arrivant à Mayotte voilà ce qui
laisse ce droit à l'étranger d'être
régularisé ailleurs en France mais pas à
Mayotte moi je suis favorable à cette
disposition et je suis mesdames monsieur
le député élu à maotte je suis pas de
ceux qui vous disent ce sera pas
constitutionnel on verra bien voilà on
verra bien c'est pas à moi de le dire ce
juge constitutionnel de le faire et je
veux dire ici devant vous que sinon il y
a la loi mayillotte qui arrive qui nous
permettra de corriger si le conseil
constinelle nous fait des remarques et
deuxièmement s'il y a une réforme
constitutionnelle le Président vous avez
vu souhait en faire une moi je suis pour
qu'il des dispositions particulière à
mayott parce qu'on ne peut pas gouverner
Mayotte me semble-t-il qu'on gouverne le
reste du pays vous avez tout à fait
raison sur le droit du sol et le droit
du sang à Mayotte dans des conditions
qui sont déjà différent du droit commun
voilà et ça c'est mon avis personnel
mais je pense que qui peut plus peut le
moins et on peut peut faire ses
dispositions dans le texte ordinaire on
verra ce que dira le Conseil
constitutionnel je suis tout à fait prêt
à y à y travailler
euh je crois que il y avait une question
sur l'indépendance de l'OFPRA évidemment
ni lofpra ni l'OFI ne voit revoir leur
indépendance et encore moins la CNDA
mais bon c'était évident je pense à
Monsieur di Philippo lui avoir répondu
sur la me et sur les demandes sur les
demandeurs d'asile alors pour le
Calvados alors je regardé exactement la
question de wistream je t'avoue que je
la connais moins bien que la question du
Nord pas decalé et la question des qui
est à peu près similaire parce que c'est
à peu près le même type de public qui
veulent passer en Angleterre parce que
oui voilà bon on peut avoir envie
d'aller à Calais à Boulogne surmer moi
je j'y vais en vacances et j'ai ma
maison de famille mais et à wream en
général voilà on y va surtout parce que
c'est près de la Manche et qu'on a envie
de passer là il se passe des choses
magnifiques en Calvados notamment c'est
le département de la Premier ministre je
n'oserai le critiquer et le Nord Pas De
calé est une région formidable mais
c'est pas l'endroit où en général
spontanément on a envie d'installer sa
présence bon et je le dis avec non mais
non mais voilà voilà bien sûr c'est
c'est au moins c'est réaliste voilà mais
on y est bien on y est bien je je suis
d'accord c'est pas assez connu qu'est-ce
qui se passe ils veulent aller en
Angleterre en grande partie Veer en
Angleterre c'est souvent des éitréens
bon la difficulté c'est que quand on
demande à ces personnes de voouir
déposer l'asile alors je peux comprendre
qu'il y a des moments où ils ne peuvent
pas le faire et je pense que là ce
qu'évoque madame la députée Tamer peut
être utile y compris à votre disposition
monsieur le député mais moi de ce que je
connais du Nord de la France de grande
sainte de Calais de Boulogne où il y a
15 fois moins de migrants aujourd'hui
qu'il y en avait il y a 10 ans grâce à
l'action du gouvernement de Monsieur
Hollanda et l'action très forte de
Monsieur casenu moi je pense qu'on peut
iussi remercier Monsieur casnu pour
l'action très forte quand vous étiez en
responsabilité dans la lutte contre l'
migration irrégulière le démantelllement
des des des camps de migrants vous êtes
vous moins vous êtes moins en support
mais je pense que c'est important de le
dire c'est une action socialiste
extrêmement forte et ferme contre
l'immigration irrégulière qu'on essaie
de de continuer à 15 FO moins de
migrants aujourd'hui quel est le sujet
en fait il y a moins de 5 % de ces
personnes qui demandent l'asile sur le
territoire de la République à Cala euh à
Boulogne sur Mer à grande sainte parce
qu'en fait ils veulent aller en
Angleterre ils veulent avoir l'asile ou
la protection en Angleterre et notre
difficulté c'est euh comment euh
l'Angleterre comment la Grande-Bretagne
accepte de remettre ce qui arrive
normalement dans n'importe quel autre
pays au monde une relation d'immigration
normale et d'accès légal à son pays pour
pouvoir déposer les demandes d'asile et
tant que l'Angleterre restera dans les
lunes euh du brexit sur les questions
migratoires elle se elle s'oblige à ne
pas avoir appliqué Dublin elle ne peut
plus faire de reconduite à la frontière
et elle oblige les gens a passer puisque
désormais le tunnel est complètement
bloqué par des bateaux pour aller en
Grande-Bretagne voilà et elle ne voit
pas qu'elle doit changer de paradigme
alors peut-être qu'elle le verra un jour
mais elle le voit pas pour l'instant
donc si je peux comprendre ce sujet je
peux aussi voir que par exemple dans l
pcalé monsieur le député encore une fois
je connais pas très bien la situation du
Calvados pour vous répondre avec
précision mais je le ferai la prochaine
fois je je vous le promets la difficulté
monsieur le député c'est quoi c'est que
il compris lorsqu'on propose des
hébergements souvent ils n'y vont pas
parce qu'ils ve ils veulent être soit
évidemment prêt pour le prochain bateau
soit parce qu'ils sont sous la main des
passeurs il y a aujourd'hui plus de 800
par exemple chambres de libre au moment
où je vous parle dans le Nord Pas De
calé et il y a quand même des camps de
migrants et pourtant on leur propose d'y
aller et pourquoi ils ne veulent pas y
aller parce que ils veulent passer en
Angleterre voilà alors évidemment des
conditions absolument affreus que vous
avez déc décrite et qu' convient d'abord
de remercier les gendarmes et les
policiers pour leur travail parce que
c'est pas évident ils plongent dans
l'eau vous savez bien à une eau
difficile pour sauver des des des bébés
des femmes des enfants des des des des
des des des personnes qui veulent
traverser dans ces logement des bateaux
de fortune mais euh mais je pense que
c'est pas aussi maniquin que ça en tout
cas je regarderai les choses avec
intérêt monsieur Guiton alors moi on
peut faire sondage contre sondage je
constate aussi que 80 % des Français
sont pour ce projet de loi y compris 60
% des Français sont pour la
régularisation des travailleurs métiers
en tenstion d'ailleurs je vais pas faire
ici le détail mais il y en a partout des
gens qui demandent de régularisation
dans tous les groupes monsieur Guiton je
vais pas commencer à rentrer dans le
secret professionnel ce serait pas pas
ça mais dans tous les groupes dans dans
tous les groupes voilà pourquoi parce
que c'est normal c'est c'est normal les
gens qui travaillent on souhaite les
régulariser les gens qui effectivement
méchant avec méchant gentil gentil au
moin je pense que tout le monde le
comprend les gens qui sont respectent
pas lesurs de la République je pense
qu'on veut tous sen séparer mais c'est
pas extrêmement grave donc les sondages
il faut les prendre avec avec parsimonie
parce que dans ces cas-là vous seriez
comme un seul homme évidemment favorable
au texte que nous vous proposons
puisqu'il est très largement soutenu par
les Français à des taux très très
importants par ailleurs ça ne veut pas
dire que les Français sont pas
favorables à une politique plus ferme ou
ou même un référendum sachez que vous
savez bien que pour faire un référendum
sur migration il faut d'abord faire faut
d'abord changer la constitution donc
c'est une solution intéressante mais qui
n'est pas immédiate au moins ce que je
vous propose c'est immédiat vous devriez
pouvoir les regarder alors le taux
d'application qtf je termine par là
Monsieur le monsieur le Président j'en
suis désolé mais c'est très important
parce que il pourrit le débat médiatique
d'abord aucun chiffre du ministère de
l'Intérieur n'a jamais diffusé dans
aucun document budgétaire dans aucune
documentation un tau de pourcentage
desqtf appliqué le le le pourcentage que
vous évoquez vous savez ce que vous
faites quand vous faites vous prenez le
taux des le nombre des mesures
administratives il y a pas que lesqtf il
y a aussi les ITF enfin il y a toutes
les mesures administratives que nous
prenons et vous regardez le nombre de
gens qui sont partis et vous faites une
division et vous dites ah bah vous en
êtes à 10 à 15 à 20 % bon alors d'abord
monsieur le député c'est pas comme ça
que ça fonctionne je sais que c'est
difficile à entendre mais c'est
justement l'absurdité de notre
fonctionnement sur les 120000 mesures
administratives que nous prenons dedans
essentiellement des eqtf 80 % d'entre
sont suspensifs donc ce n'est pas
honnête et vous seriez à ma place
immédiatement malgré votre bonne volonté
et même avec le programme de Madame Le
Pen vous ne l'appliqueriez pas un
meilleur meilleur taux de CITF pourquoi
parce que vous ne pouvez pas appliquer
des mesures administratives qui sont
suspensives et c'est tout à fait
malhonnête de dire il y a eu 120000
mesures en 2023 il y a eu 20000 retours
en 2023 en en faisant croire que ce sont
les mêmes puisque c'est suspensif et
qu'on met 3 ans les mesures qu'on
applique en 2023 c'est celles qui ont
été prises en 2020 2021 il y a pas
d'équivalent dans votre tableau alors
j'entends bien que nous sommes pas
extrêmement efficaces sur les retours je
suis le premier à le dire c'est pour ça
que je proppose un projet de loi mais
mais ne vous pouvez pas faire comme si
d'abord les autres pays étaient plus
efficaces ce n'est pas vrai on a tous
les mêmes problèmes parce que nous
dépendons soit de de laisser passer
consulaires qui ne sont pas donné et ça
pose d'autres questions qui qui
évidemment méritent d'être évoqué soit
d'une lenteur administrative que
j'essaie ici de combattre sans j'aurais
pas 100 % d'application des eqtf hein
moi je j'essaie d'être honnête mais je
pense que j'aurai une bien meilleure
application des ETF pour ple on qu'on
pourrait évoquer que j'ai commencé à
évoquer mais ce chiffre que que vous
donnez d'application de qtf ne repose
sur aucune réalité administrative alors
on peut toujours le continuer à dire
c'est 7 % c'est 20 % c'est 18 % personne
ne l'a jamais mesuré d'ailleurs monsieur
président la commission des lois c'est
quelque chose d'intéressant pour pour
qu'on puisse se dire voilà quand on
prend unqtf à partir de combien de temps
on applique et d'ailleurs vous savez il
y a plein deqtf qui sont et c'est même
la majorité exactement de départ
volontaire et c'est-à-dire que les
départs volontaires on ne les calcule on
ne les compte pas donc non mais mais
c'est très important il y a plusieurs
types de qtf il y a des départs forcés
c'est ceux que vous comptez il y a les
aides volonires vous avez vu que c'est
déjà les aides volontaires c'est 20 %
puisque quand on fait les forcés c'est 7
et quand on regarde avec les départs
volontaires aidé ce que fait l'OFI quand
elle donne une carte pour que les gens
repartent chez eux qui pevent toucher
cet argent qu' unee fois qu' sont partis
che c'est desjà on 20 %. il y a tous
ceux qui ont desqtf qui partent de leur
plein gré et qu'on ne compte pas pour
plein de raison peut-être que c'est pas
le bon système d'ailleurs voilà et puis
par ailleurs si on compare avec d'autres
pays regardez l'Allemagne en Allemagne
il y a quasiment pas de C on le prend
dans l'avion parce que c'est ce qu'on
appelle les les les les les tolérances
doncdong que font les les Allemands ils
disent à quelqu'un qui est irrégulier
vous avez le droit de rester en
attendant la fin de votre cours
peut-être que c'est un calcul qu'il
faudrait faire mais si j'étais venu
devant vous pour dire met fin auqtf vous
m'auriez dit monsieur le ministre vous
cassez le thermomètre donc moi ce que je
vous propose c'est le contraire c'est la
simplification drastique des procédures
pour permettre une beaucoup plus grande
application des UTF j'espère vous avoir
démontré que c'était comme ça qu'on est
arrivé puis enfin oui vous avez
parfaitement raison les 4000 délincants
étrangers chaque année moyenne ben je
pourrais procéder à leur éloignement à
leur expulsion exactement article 9
article 10 article 13 effectivement tous
seront concernés alors qu'aujourd'hui je
ne peux pas leur mettre une disposition
je peux pas les mettre dans un avion je
peux pas les mettre dans un centre de
rétr administratif tous seront concerné
c'est pour ça que j'aurais du mal à
comprendre qu'on ne vote pas ce texte de
loi qui donne vraiment une sécurité aux
Français contre des mtis récidivistes et
doncins prend fin la discussion générale
et votre audition monsieur le ministre
on se retrouve ce soir à 21h30 en
commission pour les la proposition de
loi sur les
discriminations